foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
this year saw the return of the pro
chess league and thank goodness chat so
good to have you back PCL traded Queens
oh my gosh let's go with the postseason
upon us the stakes are only getting
higher which teams from around the world
can survive to claim the next PCO
championship and also bite off a Lion's
Share of the fresh 100 000 up for grads
the semi-finals of the pro chess League
playoffs have finally arrived that's
game he all wins on the clock but also
the board him they've dominated this
match from start to finish the PCL is
here to stay who will be crowned its
next Champion whoa
the Indian water is strong around here
hello and welcome everyone to the
semi-finals of the pro chess League sit
back get the popcorn and get ready
because it is going to be an exciting
day of Chess I am International Master
Tanya sachdev alongside my good friend
the Jedi James Canty James super happy
to be back here with you we had such a
phenomenal day of quarterfinals action
what was the highlight for you the
Highlight for me was the tie breaks I
mean we thought one team had oh we got
it and then it's tie breaks right and
also the momentum was almost in the
other team's favor so those tie breaks
were amazing we were able to see a lot
more chests than uh we came for so
that's always exciting what about you
yeah completely agree with Avatar versus
mgd1 the tire breaks super exciting and
the action only heats up because there
is so much on the line it's a single
elimination match and take a look at
what the teams are fighting for well
it's a big chunk of the 100
000 price pool if you win today you go
into the finals you're guaranteed a
twenty thousand dollars not just that on
Sunday we will be revealing the big hit
us the most valued players three prizes
will go out and MVPs will take back five
thousand dollars but James prize money
that's really cool but it's also the
bragging rights of winning the protest
league and the money that we gonna spend
as well absolutely I'm gonna brag all
the way to wherever we gonna spend this
money right so that's very nice uh as
well nice payoff sitting at home
relaxing wherever you are maybe you know
they're out or playing wherever they're
playing from they're relaxing in a way
not relaxing too much because there's
some stressful games anymore emotions
that's gonna go on before the finals
it's been such an exciting Journey James
as you mentioned well relaxation is out
of the window because you've got big
semi-final matchups coming up but we
started with 16 teams after the playoffs
we had after the Swiss we had eight
teams qualifying for the quarterfinals
and the postseason has been a super fun
one we started with the Shanghai Tigers
winning against Norway Norm is the first
team to go into the semi-finals and then
the match that went down to the wire
with levitto Wizards against MGD one
going into tie breaks a super fun one
which saw MGD one come on top absolutely
and it's the top half of the bracket
that you see the yogis number one they
are very very strong you're going to see
those uh face off against the blitz
there where they defeated the blitz to
make it here and then you have the
Knights versus the Bishops of course the
knights won that battle guys if you're a
bishops fan sorry to hear that the
knights definitely won that one so of
course now we have uh these bigger
matchups here and it's only getting
bigger up until the finals
it's gonna get it's gonna be a big day
of Chess as well we will see mgd1 taking
on Gotham Knights later today but we
start with the Shanghai tigers against
the Indian yogis and here's the big
reveal drum rolls this is the squad that
the teams are putting forward to try to
punch their ticket into the finals
whoever wins goes forward the loser is
out after protest league and the first
thing that strikes me James is the
switch up by the Indian yogis they won
yesterday and they have rotated with the
Gujarati and nehal Serene for Prague and
Rana does that surprise you you no not
at all it shows the depth of the team
How deep the Indian yogis go here I mean
just GM swapping out real quick hey
throwing Prague and ronak like there
that's really strong of course after
having nihal and bit it there as well
when these players are absolutely 100
piece going up against some other piece
at his attack
and we also see the Shanghai Tai goes
with the tried and tested formula today
it will be the 17 year old Prodigy from
India the most exciting Talent
pragnananda who will be leading the
Indian yogis from the front we will see
the power siblings of Indian chess
Prague and vaishali Prague he has
mentioned his idols James have been
Magnus Carlson and vishwanathan on and
but this is a story of when your Idols
become your Rivals because Prague has
been beating Magnus in CCT and today
he's gonna try to get his team to the
finals absolutely of course alongside
his sister there so that's some family
power and Indian blood and in the Indian
water it's just a lot going on over
there a lot of camaraderie and a lot of
Peace play in the chess against other
beasts against those Tigers which are
really really stoic and they have that
really team camaraderie you can tell
that they're just ready to go as one
will oil team or one tiger as we should
say yeah
and as you mentioned the Tigers as well
they've got a phenomenal lineup they are
sticking to that tried and tested
formula with their four players take a
look at the first round pairings that
we've got the most lopsided one because
the blood one word number one takes on
Board number four we've got Prague
against Liu yipping and we've got Wei
the Phenom from China the 23 year old
Grandmaster who will be starting against
the 17 year old pranesh once again an
uneven matchup with James now Indian
yogis are the top seed they're seed
number one Shanghai Tigers seed number
four and as we progress to even matches
those very important critical round
three and round four we will see the top
Boards of the Indian Yogi because of
their seedings take on the white pieces
against the Shanghai tigers do you think
that's a big Advantage yeah absolutely I
mean I think it's an advantage if you
can take advantage right of you having
uh the black pieces when you have the
black pieces here they say oh win with
white draw with bikes especially at the
higher level here but lots of times I
mean it doesn't go that way you can't
actually win with the black pieces too
as well especially in the shorter time
control so really I think it comes down
to if you can make some Chances with the
black pieces that's really going to be
huge here in this map
absolutely we've been talking about
Prague leading from the front for the
Indian yogis and the player on the top
board from the Shanghai Tigers is a 23
year old
Grandmaster where he he's had such an
incredible impressive early career he
was just 15 when he broke the 2700
barrier he broke Magnus Carlson's record
becoming the youngest player to ever be
2700 he has a super attacking style
we've seen him bring on the creativity
on the board James one of his biggest
Immortals the game against Bruce on
Batista just sticks on my mind and even
in the protest League we've seen just
incredible attacking masterpieces by Wei
yeah he goes under the radar in fact
people don't talk about him as much but
he's absolutely 2700 just let me check
the files right the man is extremely
strong here and his repertoire is
aggressive he likes to play E4 he likes
grunfeld right very sharp lines he likes
Niner of Sicilian so very sharp player
very strong and attacking you're gonna
have to watch out for him especially at
the top board we know he's gonna you
know really be out here to get some
points today yeah
definitely so much on the line today as
the players tried to take their team
over to the coveted finals which would
mean so much in the protest League one
team two teams today will be knocked out
to will advance and elude ping the
international Master From China will do
not be fooled by that I am because he's
been playing like a super Grand Master
so far for the Shanghai tigers and James
for me it's so fascinating that since
week one the Shanghai tigers have stuck
to this roster to this lineup and Luigi
ping has been a regular in this protest
League season that actually is quite
amazing number one he's he's out he must
be at a uh obviously a hotel room we're
playing in the tournament somewhere
that's what you see a lot of times with
these players here but to keep him in
the lineup especially when you have
other players that you can swap out it's
just amazing there shows the strength of
Lou here and hopefully he's able to
bring it to them they made it this far
with this lineup something's working
they're sticking with it they're
sticking with the guns here and let's
see what happens with this lineup today
so great choice
you have very different approaches by
these themes Shanghai Tigers sticking to
their lineup while the Indian Yogi is
showing super flexibility with rotating
their own lineup after a great win in
the quarterfinals and this is going to
be a big game it starts with a pregnant
taking on Louis ping Prague with the
black pieces but there is pressure
despite being black he's going to try to
win this one absolutely of course I mean
I mean your chances are there you try to
take them you don't have to take the
risks there you just play the board
right if it gives you the chances then
you take those chances every single time
Lou here actually is going to play his
best gaming at the right pieces you have
to try to take advantage of that of
course and uh with the first move
Advantage here and see what happens with
practice no joke we all know who how
strong Prague is and he's young he beat
Magnus a few times right so we know
Prague is an absolute Beast so let's see
what happens today this is going to be a
class right here I cannot wait to see
what happens on this board for sure
it's gonna be a super fun match and lose
your pain you cannot underestimate it
underestimate him so far in the league
he scored a huge nine out of 19 being
aboard four for his team and James
that's a massive score to bring home for
from your board for ah exactly that and
I said yeah we board four doing it well
against this field we're like fourth
boards be GMS right so this is very
strong good stuff here we got a sicilian
on the
boardwani okay oh E6 line nice taste
takes takes all Theory all theories so
far nothing special
nothing special
A6
right
and usually Bishop variation of the open
Sicilian and of course there are many
ways for white to continue here but the
big approach will be will Julie decide
to go for a long side Queen side
castling or will he just simply develop
the king side bishop and go for a more
saner approach a more solid approach
with King side castling James are you
surprised with his decision to
immediately take on C6 because usually
white tends to delay that yeah I am
absolutely I mean because you get you
know as one acts of one is showing here
you got the early D5 in I'm more of a
fan of the aggressive lines with Bishop
E3 and after uh after
um Queen C7 G4 is the movie literally
just G4 out of nowhere right so it's a
very nice strong move it's fun and it's
aggressive right we get lots of Pawn up
there here this is just more uh solid I
mean of course you still have your
attacking chances move the queen E2
maybe Rook to D1 you're just playing
chess here but like did get D5 in and
the Sicilians a lot of times if you're
able to get this D5 move in you're doing
quite fine like you're okay to say the
least
and that's the whole point once you
trade on C6 you allow a Side Pawn of
black to actually come towards the
center and this break that you're
talking about is a dream of every
Sicilian player you want to strike with
D5 and that pawn on C6 really assists
that now I know ronik a little bit he's
definitely enjoying this position that
he's gotten out of the opening he loves
playing these faster speed chess formats
he really thrives in it so it's going to
be interesting to see how he tries to
create his chances on paper ranak
sagmani is a favorite on this board and
we see Zoo Yi he's got an interesting
idea definitely some home prep there
because it's an offbeat way for white to
counter the Sicilian I actually like
this uh Bishop B2 move here from Zoo Yi
here with the longer diagonal approach
is very strong but we do need to create
some chances which I see that probably
coming with an F4 F5 and some type of
Rook lift F3 G3 very aggressive
intentions open Sicilian that's what
that is anyway black with the A5 move
may be looking to play A4 and maybe a
queen B6 Bishop A6 as well stuff like
that
um
sons are actually watching too as well
so got them watching it's a slug
hopefully you got your kids watching at
home guys uh get the kids involved guys
get the kids as well very good you know
you may see them playing right here on
protesting
speaking exactly speaking of getting
your kids involved the average age of
today's Indian Yogi team is 19. yeah
James that's absolutely insane and these
are all players reaching 20 2700 the
oldest member of today's Indian Yogi
team is vaishali at 21. wow yes in the
water I'm telling you whatever they have
in the water there it's showing guys
it's definitely in the food in the water
there for sure that's funny I don't know
James that water hasn't reached Delhi
yet as a retail from that side okay
perfect yeah we gotta get some of that
Indian water over there for sure I need
a cup or two or a a gallon of that every
day just life
amazing
and we're already seeing some unfamiliar
territory in this open Sicilian so Rook
D1 played lining up that Rook on the D
file against the queen so preemptive
move in case that file opens up that's
where you want your rook and black
Returns the favor by placing his own
drugs so that if you take on D5 now if
white was to capture on D5 the usual way
to take it back would be with the c Pawn
you want more pawns towards the center
of the board but with that last move
Rook to E8 it also opens up the idea and
the flexibility of the yogis to capture
D5 with the E6 Pawn so a nice little
move played fast by both these players
they're continuing their development and
James another fun fact about ronak's
advani and I'm only saying that because
I can kind of tell that you do love them
tattoos advani has the coolest chest
tattoo in the Chess World I just heard
about that I just heard that you know
ronix Armani got tatted I was like
what's wrong he has a tattoo where
knowing
with a sleeve chat can you believe that
I cannot believe that right now I gotta
definitely uh see that that is extra
cool from him I've never expected that
from rock out here but you see smirking
at it too like yeah you right candy
you're right you're right I saw the
smirk there wow that's that's pretty
cool actually to know check that out
so what's his Instagram his
Instagram chat I'm sure you guys can
find it
yeah I'm sure we can have someone in
chat plug that in but check that out
right now
like valbar says that white actually
despite going through this slightly
off-beat part in the opening has built
an advantage a slight we see the bar
shifting closer to a wide advantage and
Yu Yi strikes for the second time in the
center now he's forcing ronak to take a
decision and ronak does just that
simplifies on he said is that a blunder
Bishop B7
what happened there wow uh Bishop takes
Eve wait this is well what is is this
right that is right I'm actually
checking right now to see I have no idea
Bishop takes Queen H5 no what is wrong
with this position oh Bishop E5 six and
Knight C5 no it's just Bishop E5 because
after Queen C8 there's an ib6 and if you
take oh you found it you found it oh man
yeah look at it look away wow
wow it's just lost for black chat this
position is just lost or by and you can
see it ronak realizes it he rushed he
blundered and just out of the opening
the underrated player on board the bot 3
of China
is currently in a winning position it's
tactics James and let's just show it
with the arrows or maybe we can make
some moves Black's Queen can either fall
back on C8 which would have allowed a
falcon B6 and now that would be
completely lost actually James that
wasn't even a fork that was a queen trap
can we just back up for a moment yeah he
lost his whole Queen there after Bishop
B5 you're thinking oh wait I mean that's
cute you know I'm saying oh you hit your
tactics for breakfast lunch or dinner
I'll go back Queen C8 but then Knight V6
oh it's a fork right but then also your
queen is trapped I'll take that
appreciate it I don't care what you do
okay maybe I do but I am going to take
your queen no matter if you like it or
not that's mine Bishop E5 what a spot
from Julie here that's gonna be a big
game there it's a big game huge loss um
if he's not able to recover which means
I don't think he will to be honest but I
mean of course takes takes there's still
some chances because you have pieces but
I mean wow like what a blunder day
that's tough
this is absolutely shocking what we've
just seen and you could see it on ronak
he can't believe it himself and it all
came down to this natural Bishop
developing move James White is
completely winning here already Shanghai
Tigers this would be a huge point for
them if they're able to take down ranex
advani bought two of the Indian yogis we
need to do an action replay of what just
happened what was the Turning Point what
was the big blunder was it Bishop B7
absolutely in fact right here actually
after Bishop takes E4 I mean the better
move here is just get rid of the bishop
first he didn't want to take this which
is I mean you just take this because
it's a it's an issue you get the bishop
pair right you can open up Bishop B7
later right he just played Bishop B7
first which gave it the wrong idea
obviously it's just wrong immediately
and this should be five now we got both
the Bishops here and that is GG it was
supposed to be Knight takes E4 first get
rid of that very sharp Bishop that he
had and then we go from there but lost
the queen trying to still fight here but
it's very futile let's hit at least you
want to move to the other game
yeah I'm still getting over what we just
saw a blunder right out of the opening
and it's not a pawn blunder it's an
entire Queen blunder you've got no place
left and so easy to fall for that let's
move on to another game this one well it
looks like ronix advani will not be able
to come back from that position he's
down upon down a queen for just two
minor pieces he's gonna try and fight
James but it's not gonna it's gonna be
an uphill task we also have action on
with Prague sister vaishali who has been
such a star player for the Indian Yogi
is on board for she has defeated so many
strong Grand Masters in the protest
league so far including super including
Daniel Dubois she took down etian
bachrod yesterday it's been a phenomenal
performance by vaishali so far and she's
playing against juventure the current
reigning women world champions the
three-time women world champion James
this is going to be a big fight and I
love the position that we have on the
board already look at the pawns Tom that
venjin has created in this Center
absolutely there's a yeah definitely a
pawn Stone here but it can be breaking
broken breaking breaking and broken up
as much as you can you can do B4 right
you also have C3 Queen D3 was the move
from Vice shally here though in fact I
like to say like you know even the mom
is like 2300 right because some mom and
brother the whole family there is just a
very strong but queen of D3 hits B5 and
we also do want to double the Rooks
maybe play Rook F1 or F4 it's lots of
possibilities here this is a strong
Center but it can be broken up B4 is a
move possible at some point we do need
to watch for Pawn breaks from both sides
in fact here maybe C4 at some point a
timely C before could be annoying or
taking maybe trying to play C4 taking
would allow A6 to be weak we can also
take with our Rook here so they always
say keep the tension which is important
here there's some tension here and we do
want to maybe Again Play B4 and do
something with this position the time is
about even two as well so
this is going to be a fun fight and chat
we're getting an update that the other
two boards the other two games are yet
to start there are some technical issues
that we're just fixing so there are
these are the only two games that are
ongoing the action is on but it is hot
action we saw we saw Rana salmani with a
big blunder by the yogis and here we
also see where Charlie she's made the
move Queen D3 uh she wants to try to get
the other Rook into the game but you've
got to watch out now I'll move like
rookie one James that Queen B6 it's
Sneaky because the A4 Pawn would be
hanging there's an x-ray vision that
down the B file so a move like rookie
one could totally run into B takes A4
you cannot recapture the bishop on B2 is
on free wow gotta be careful there look
at Tanya with the tactics guys tactic
Tanya so of course after queen of these
six tactics Tanya right so uh here after
uh the queen V6 move yeah that's just
kind of annoying actually that's a very
strong move that's quite annoying
because you do want to keep the tension
if I take I mean then on the new
challenge the file I may have to go Rook
E1 very strong move there
what do we do hmm
James check this out there's just
another idea it's not just really taking
stopping white from developing that Rook
but at some point black can actually
make the move C4 once again I want to
open up that B file and if you take on
D4 it gives these counter attacking
ideas like the bishop coming on C5 a
battery along the A7 G1 diagonal and in
at the right moment this could be a
dangerous threat now white has to
constantly think about this wow yeah
this is actually a very good point here
as you do know that we can give up some
pawns here obviously for counter play
with Bishop C5 will be nice we also do
have again B takes A4 which is going to
be quite an annoying move uh to face if
we move the root we can't really move
the Rook here kind of tied down in the
meantime we do have other games so the
pranesh game has actually started with
way we're gonna actually pull that up
and go over there to see what these guys
are doing it just started let's see what
the opening is and we have pranesh with
the white pieces versus the very strong
and aggressive we
and I'll tell you one thing there is no
player in the protest league as hungry
to prove himself and for the win as
pranesh is we saw his performance for
the Indian yogis yesterday in the match
against Blitz and he took he's caught a
massive three out of four he was the MVP
for Blitz yesterday the board four he's
just 17 years old he's India's latest
Grand Master he's also his his play has
been so full of inspiration James it's
been amazing to watch his rise and if we
just go on and see how this one went he
doesn't fear where ye but we know where
he with the black pieces will try to win
this one it is an important one on board
one playing board four and now we have
ourselves a Carol Khan here very subtle
fasting moving here listen out all the
theories so far right 97 Knight D7 this
is the more topical stuff these days
playing H6 and A6 is what's like next
and stuff like that you talk to Bishop
you play Knight F5 right so it's very
important to understand this uh this
type of play 96 that one interesting
actually not familiar with this one yet
you play Carol Khan or no what are you
playing in C4
I I like to play the king spawn opening
so I play either E5 or Sicilian I'm not
a Carol player and I don't face it
either because I'm a D4 player but it's
always very interesting to see these
setups because it's kind of like the
French but the light squared Bishop is
outside the pawn structure which
definitely is a breather for black and
we do see an F6 break so where he James
he's making his intentions very clear he
wants to open up the game he wants to
try to build that attack we keep talking
about and it's already a very
asymmetrical middle game that we have
yeah you know what's funny actually
Carol Khan and middle games and French
ones as well can be very you can
actually steer I guess we've learned
this over time you can learn that every
opening can be played some type of
aggressive way and Carol Khan being a
very solid opening here can be played
very aggressively as you see with the
bishop diagonal I mean this is not the
regular Karo Khan solidity that you
actually have this is more of like a
fringe that you know again middle games
are very sharp there as we saw yesterday
with Origins middle game that French
game against Coast New York it's a very
similar here with the aggressive
intentions we may have with the bishop
bearing down we have a weakness here we
can also end up casting Queen side if
we're able to dislodge the Bishop from
G5 we already have an open file so like
what kind of character is this like here
icon with some spice to it and Flair for
sure
yeah it feels like a Carol French hybrid
with the F6 brake and the pawn structure
that we're seeing but James big big
update Julie did win that game ronak
sadvani has already resigned after that
opening blunder he was down a queen for
just two minor pieces no compensation at
all in that position and for the Tigers
that's a huge Point taking down board
two of the Indian yogis yeah that's
absolutely huge there that I mean
sonwani had that blunder that hurts and
you like ah come on this is for the team
like I'm so mad like and I can
understand you can see you could feel
all the emotion there because it was so
quick it feels like later in the game
and Etc we're like okay you can
understand you just had a bad game but
really I mean it was a bad game but very
quick he lost his Queen within like 15
moves right so it was a very very tough
uh loss there for for the yogis but of
course if they're able to bounce back
this round isn't over yet and there's
still another uh you know three matches
today three rounds there that is
yeah but now the other three boards
really have to step it up to counter
that loss and as you mentioned it's not
about the result but the way it happened
it was basically a free gift for the
Shanghai Tigers right out of the opening
no fight at all but now this game is
where the action is and we can't see a
lot is happening on the king side and
the queen side pranesh being ambitious
on both flanks of the Void he is trying
to trade off pieces on the king side so
that there isn't a possibility of a big
attack the more pieces that get traded
the easier it is for white to handle the
attack meanwhile he's trying to create
Pawn weaknesses on the queen Side by
gaining more space and I like that
approach Unstoppable a pawn it marches
down the board now after this move you
never want to recapture that you don't
want to capture that A6 pawn it leads to
a lot of weaknesses on the Queen's side
uh James maybe you can just have some
arrows on the board that if he takes A6
was to happen after Rook A6 C6 will be
weak A7 will be weak and the weaknesses
all around that's definitely not a move
you want to make on the other hand if
you push the beep on that A6 Pawn for
the rest of the game is a point of worry
for black any end games any time blight
is able to strike on the queen side it
could be the winning Pawn absolutely
this is gonna be super annoying of
course look at look at the space we've
created here and if you push it twice to
B5 at some point maybe we can get a
knight to B7 or some piece there but
eventually it's just annoying to have
obviously this Pawn on A6 so you're
gonna feel that a little bit later there
but actually I think this is what
happens this on the board actually this
is actually on the board now Tanya A6 B6
actually happened right now and uh let's
see we have it's right to move here this
is not the Carol con I'm actually
looking for like it was like Black's
totally fine but we do have this nice
Pawn on A6 and we need to still develop
our pieces on the other hand black is
fully developed and the Rooks are
connected
very interesting okay B6 happened
I agree with you Black's peace activity
is so powerful right now and you can
feel it there's only that Rook on it and
I have no doubt that we will bring the
final toy into the game as well either
try and bring it on the f file or bring
it to E8 and try and even break in the
center he's already eyeing White's King
side it's gonna be a big battle and chat
another update that we we still haven't
started on the Prague Louis ping board
still sorting out those tactical issues
we will get that game to you as soon as
it's underway but James what do you say
should we take this moment to shift to
the vaishali Vengeance board because
action is on there is definitely some
action You're Gonna Love vaishali's last
move oh I see it right now I'm looking
at it right now there it is
E6 talk to me nicely E6 is a strong move
very scary move there Bishop F6 now okay
yep takes takes correct correct and now
we look for some aggressive moves but it
looks like we have nothing it looks
looks great but I think there's actually
nothing correct Queen F3 has to pin The
Rook was hanging and now I think we just
do some trades maybe take take and like
it's just an equal position but Black's
King is a little weak that's about it
exactly and I think that's the point
vengeon just needs to make a few
accurate moves to make sure that there
is complete equality he can simply trade
on B2 and fall back with that we can put
it on a safe spot on G8 and everything
is under control and that move E6 James
if we just back up to that moment also
to show our chat that it really had a
direct threat you can't pick up that
pawn on E6 for those of you who might be
new to chess there is a big battery
along the diagonal and James we would
have seen a Checkmate Queen to G7 and
that would have been game over so this
was not a possibility which is why
Vengeance very accurately traded White's
most active Bishop on the board
so H6 actually happened here this is a
prophylactic move maybe we're going to
go around this way at some point uh a
Jew is actually saying yo hey you know
what are you gonna do with the Rook like
The Rook is not at okay it's active but
you can't do anything yet with your rook
and the queen actually is a well piece
by itself right you can't you have to do
it more than just with the queen so
Queen to C3 maybe Rook to C1 is some
type of possibility if a rook D5 there
might be some queen of three
possibilities so King G8 she steps back
maybe there's going to be a rook C1 and
this is actually much closer to a draw
than anything else but the time is quite
low for vishali hmm
but the good news for vaishali here is
that there's such few pieces and there's
very little margin to go wrong which is
the queen and the Rook on the board such
few pawns an open position the increment
that she has perhaps hopefully at least
will be enough for her to navigate
through it James as you said I think
draw is a very likely result so we will
zoom out of this one and go to The Other
Board the top board for the Shanghai
Tigers way against pranesh if we can
pull that one up because that is
anything but close to a draw we were
talking about a central E5 break I
mentioned that way he might bring his
Rook first he doesn't even wait for that
he's gone for it immediately we do see a
break in the center and now James where
he is bringing that knight from D7 to F6
closer to the attack the dream is to
land one day on G4 or on e4 and just
continues to build pressure even though
the eval Bar says equal James is it fair
to say that white is feeling the heat
then white is definitely feeling heat
here especially as hacking player myself
and like understanding black has a lot
of potential for Attack on this side of
the board I mean this Knight looks like
you're going the wrong way engine thinks
the same thing what are you where are
you going all the pieces on the other
side of the board and of course you're
hitting D4 but I'm never gonna take this
on D4 maybe I'll play E4 first before I
do anything else but I mean the Knight
is definitely misplaced here the engine
does not like to move by far here and we
have to figure out what we want to do if
we are away you here I mean H5 even
jumps out there H5 to put the Knight on
G4 as a possible E4 put a knight on F4
possibility there it is E4 right we can
move the Knight play G5 I mean there's
so many attacking ideas here one thing
about the Carroll Khan or the more solid
openings like we talked about the French
yesterday middle games are very very
like tactical and but the Carroll Khan
is actually very the same you can
actually have very tactical middle games
with this from either side usually it's
white to one doing things but if you're
an aggressive player playing in a
positional opening most times like this
like Carroll Khan aggressive player way
Yi playing in a very solid opening found
very aggressive and engines here and
he's he's now 81 attacking this looks
like this could have came from a
sicilian obviously there's no there's a
c Pawn here there's no C Pawn this would
be more sicilian-like but you chose a
sicilian type flavor as he likes Knight
or in this carol con very strong play
here from Wei Yi we're gonna have to
consolidate and stop this attack from
happening prevented Ernest does maybe an
H3 that's a scary move to make very
scary
I'm just amazing
at Ray's ability to just out of nowhere
out of thin air create these attacking
possibilities and these tactics we saw
against the Norway gnomes that
brilliancy he played with two minor
peace sacrifices and just checkmating
his opponent and right now pranesh with
white he has enabled he hasn't been able
to create his counter play on the
Queen's side he is suffocated on the
king side which explains his last move
he's trying to get some air but it just
feels as if black has more Firepower on
the king side to actually handle this
break with this move F3 which has been
played and James now black has got some
decisions to make does he jump with that
Knight to F4 the move that you were
talking about I really like it it poses
big questions to black to white after
Knight F4 there are some lines to be
calculated white can take on e4 but
perhaps black just simply recaptures
with the queen everything looks like it
is under control also the other way to
counter this is simply bring your last
piece into the game you can make the
move Rook to E8
continue building that pressure and
after F takes E4 we capture that pawn
with your own Queen really taking
advantage of those two Bishops on the
e-file that actually would be big
disaster for white that's a really
strong effect yay simple move just put
the Rook on EA very simple idea but if
you take Queen takes E4 and you lose
material I mean while it was simple I
also get another piece into the game use
every piece here I like knightage for me
it was he was spoiled for Choice Knight
F4 Knight H4 Rook 80 EA all these are
great moves here I do like this Knight
H4 move I'm actually curious we can't
sack yet or maybe you can hold on F4
Queen G6 hitting mates we have a lot of
Maiden ones yesterday yes remember that
wow that was like maiden ones like three
different games or some main ones here
so we'll see what happens yeah I never
missed yesterday by the very best
players in the world but I do expect
pranesh to make the move Rook F2 or G3
here just trying to fight this made in
one I don't see another way to do it by
the way James this round has been very
very crazy with that move blunder the
queen blunder that we saw by ironic but
things are just getting crazier we're
getting an update that Lou yipping has
forfeited his first round as he wasn't
able to connect to the server and
because of that frog gets a point
without playing
I saw that I mean you know he don't even
got to play like Prague is just I gotta
figure out what he's doing he didn't
even have to play he just needs to show
his game he just shows up and good
things happen well Lou Yin ping he was
just not able to connect and we saw him
earlier on the screen so that is kind of
annoying uh that's tough to lose like
that but of course now it's level it's
still an even match now to start over
it's one to one let's see what happens
at this point but man that was crazy
couldn't connect like the hotel Wi-Fi
what is that you know like fix it you
have to because this is a big match it
sucks that you know it happens hopefully
it doesn't happen anymore
and a connect for the remaining round
and we will get an update on that but
James we we know him you know exactly
his style you are the kind of player who
plays like where he is Knight G3 a
threat that he has in mind will we see
Knight g3 at some point absolutely I
mean Knight G3 takes right Queen takes
G3 King goes to H1 so of course A lot of
times I used to say drag and drop is
what I would tell uh students is how do
I get the Rook to H6 so I would have to
move the Knight so I'm already looking
at Knight G4S there unfortunately Bishop
takes G4 will be a thing and Rook F6
Rook H6 is going to be blocked by a
bishop H5 but it's there it's almost
there right very close so we just need
another move or two maybe E3 which is
what Rook E8 does Ricky it's very nice
so now after we sack on G3 takes Queen
takes we also could be able to put the
Knight on e4 right at this point and
then we can be able to realcleft and
have some some uh some aggressive
intentions here this is going to be a
win for black yeah well that's a hot
take but I think I agree with you and I
know where it's coming from do you even
draw cliff well pranesh does but it's
the wrong kind of realcleft it's the
defensive one and it's not going to hold
the position together the thing is that
there is a choice of Plenty for way but
he doesn't take that much time to make a
decision maybe not the most accurate but
still a lot of pressure this is
aggressive Suffocation for the white
pieces Pawn is on E3 Knight E4 well he
has his soccer
like I mean I think he blundered this
I'm not even I think this was a blunder
for some reason because I just feel this
does not I just feel like this is going
in the wrong direction of course black
definitely is her choice but I mean
after Queen E6 we do have to we have to
move away we have to take the material
back and it gives white tie and you have
initiative it's time so you got to be
quick with everything which he was but
he might have moved a little bit too
quick and allow some chances Bishop H5
hitting the Rook you gotta move the
queen which he does and then we go from
there
94 it looks like pronation is back in
the game he does pick up the exchange
but Black's position is so powerful that
the exchange doesn't give white the
advantage compare every piece that pawn
on E3 is worth way more than just upon
the knights on e4 F5 dominating the
position White's pieces Harmony is not
existent Wonder country to wonder can
anyone that Bishop on C1 hasn't seen the
light of day so far James the more I see
this the more I understand that you're
probably right that way you just rushed
a little bit and maybe a complete
oversight will he still be able and look
at him you can tell that yeah he
realizes it it it was a dream position
for black
wow after Queen F3 and you just go crazy
here yeah counter blunder right yeah I
was actually thinking the G5 at some
point but that hits the Knight so
um where do we go E2 no 94 no 56
Queen H3 okay you want Queen H3 and
Ricky too and it's back to even wow okay
not anymore all righty then what is
happening
I don't know maybe sacking on G3 is
possible guys are we going to do it or
not Tanya do we suck or not Tanya do we
sack tactics Tanya or not I know you
want it I know you want to see all of
that Niger E3 is a big threat on the
board but perhaps after taking it you
take back with the Knight there is a
move like Rook H2 it just gets crazy
Rook H2 you guys
right and then we should be two just
trying to keep things under control so
maybe black still needs to be a little
careful we do have a result on both
three that game has ended in a draw
vaishali Jew Vengeance as we had
predicted finishes with a draw currently
the score is one and a half one and a
half and it's been a crazy round so far
and this position continues to bring in
the crazy oh absolutely in fact I mean
look at the eval swing there but I mean
I we have to try to understand right
you've asked me is this just a pawn wait
a second Bishop takes E3 Knight G4 I
block oh okay I see what you're doing
Knight G4 Bishop takes Knight G4 double
up take on E3 takes Queen H2 King F1 I
mean it's like I guess it's fine yeah he
does he goes for it but it should be
three you just take it wow just taking
pissed me through wow that's right
tanisha's winning now all the attack has
gone out of the window and we saw that
eval Bar and James just back up for a
moment because I think you were
completely on point it had to be the
sacrifice on G3 and let's just go back
and move this move Knight F6 very well
could cost the Tigers this match you
were the one who spotted it first James
take on G3 Knight takes G3 let's start
with the E Knight and after H takes G3
the point is that if you take with the
Knight I think white just goes Rook H2
and everything is under control right
right maybe we have I don't know Queen
G3 is not it it's completely winning it
says Knight G3 rookies tonight here
and
on point boom James and we see the eval
bar it does approve because you can't
the queen can't stay in connect with the
G3 Pawn
you lose your defense the queen falls
back to H1 F1 H5 you simply pick up the
G3 pawn and that's winning
that's there Knight H4 is the hard spot
there that's what he didn't spot he
probably did look at Nigeria I'm sure he
did but he couldn't find Knight H4 which
is understandable like that's a hard
move to spot after you sack the night
like that especially in this time
control here so then he backed up to F6
which caused some problems after Bishop
takes or queen G4 wow he said trade them
boys
Serena I'm down an exchange I mean what
a game
what a game this is here wow
and white could do that the only thing
you have to be careful is if you take
Queen G4 the Knight jumps into G4 and
that Bishop on E3 is pin James that's
why white doesn't have the possibility
to trade quickly you've got to watch out
on that e-line because you could end up
losing that Bishop
oh yeah definitely you could well now
now he moves it out of the way here and
look at the time by the way way he might
go down here if that is the case Yogi's
are really ready they're ready you know
for anything I mean they already came
ready today even matched but hey if we
can do this in the first round and you
know our board fours they always say
that if you're bored fours can perform
you're gonna have a great day if your
bore fours are performing it finesse
right now is looking to close this one
out against Wei Yee right now
I'm James he can feel it he knows he's
so close to it and the way it started it
looked like where you was just
dominating this game we were talking
about bad luck for ronak sadhmani
blundering his Queen right out of the
opening but it looks like in this the
law of averages from a completely lost
position pranesh with some inaccuracies
by veggie has managed to turn it around
you make your luck on the chessboard and
right now pranesh is in control rookie
six played he's up on the clock he's up
in exchange the attack has fizzled out
James this is ending badly for the
Tigers this is this is definitely any
bad badly I mean of course he did have
his chances there now you can't blame
him it is he had to find a very nasty
sequence like Knight G3 Knight H4 like
but I think if he would have spent a
little bit of extra time there and he
actually and he also had the blender
with Bishop H5 which he plundered The
Exchange too so he's just moving a
little bit fast here which is uh quite
quite you know it just sucks that you
have to re-rebounce back after the next
round especially if he takes the L here
but five seconds on the clock is going
down all week
wow wow wow
it feels like it's a no way back here in
spanish now playing in the center he's
creating more weaknesses he is up on the
clock where he might just get flagged in
this position and we have seen drama
with lu yiping not being able to connect
with this game where he from a winning
position looks like he's going down but
that's still a little accuracy required
there is still a bit of work required
James do you think pranesh will pull
this off against Wei absolutely four
seconds on the clock too as well okay
yeah he's very strong he's 2700 but at
the same time time is definitely a
factor here also if you can't even take
because we have the two pawns we might
have a king G2 here at some point now
King G2 is going to be Queen H2 yeah but
you want to get this Rook over here
maybe Queen H1 what a move trade them
all get him off the board this is
clearly winning rookie eight whoa what a
move relax everywhere relax
disconnect The Rook from the bishop that
would be a fork and do not is he gonna
repeat no he has to find a way but
what's the defense here
I mean I think you just have to take it
and say I'm gonna grab maybe not here
but I have to take and grab one of these
pawns and try to Queen that's what it is
and the way you shaking his head he
knows this is all over even though this
position black has enough material but
where he resigns is the A7 Pawn would
have fallen bought for pranesh does it
once again for the Indian yogis taking
down board one of the Shanghai Tigers he
defeats a 2700 player this is such a
great start for this Indian young says
James pranesh he comes from such an
inspiring story he did not have a laptop
till he became an international master
and that's his story he his
determination his grit has taken him
places and he continues to shine he is
hungry for the wins and with this the
Indian yogis take the first round of the
semi-finals winning two and a half to
one and a half James this was a crazy
round all around absolutely crazy around
all around me had a disconnection there
we saw he was there in the hotel
everything was fine then didn't couldn't
connect right we had sarwani with the
early blunder like it was not even like
move 15 maybe around or loss of Queen
there lost that game Wei Yi was winning
had a Crossing attack loses the game I
mean you don't know what's gonna happen
so that's the first round wait till he
gets around three and four today let's
see what happens it's really up in the
air today crazy chess but that's what we
like right it's entertainment for the
chat as well
but James for right now we can just hope
that Lou yipping makes it to round two
because he was not able to make it for
his game against pragna Nanda there and
we see pragnaranda has left his chair
he's walked away he hasn't even started
playing yet he just showed up for game
one and his opponent unable to connect
got a very important point it's been a
difficult round for the Shanghai Tigers
a very unlucky one with the with the
inability to connect and then Wei from a
completely winning position lost to
pranesh round two will the Shanghai
Tigers make a comeback we'll find out
after this break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki androsh
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
foreign
you know we all have nicknames
Chicago is actually where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently they
don't make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up it don't matter
we're trying to do is to let them know
hey we playing down here in Houston
Texas
and if you come down here help step in
trust me we're going to beat you you
better bring your game
foreign
internally all right
uh six minutes breaks between each round
okay thank you
what just happened she takes it all
thank you
foreign
this is just crazy level of tactical
Vision Way Yi is Unstoppable in the Pro
chess League it's Checkmate she walked
right into it oh wow what a fine by way
oh we do Knight F2 check and you win the
game by oh man it's amazing I mean he
had a plus day on board four for the
Shanghai tigers
foreign
it's been a dramatic start to the
semi-finals match between the Shanghai
tigers and the Indian yogis and with all
the drama that we saw eventually it is
the yogis who have taken the lead after
round one with their four players a new
team that yogis have put forward for
this round and we've got a big game two
coming up James we had a lot of drama on
the board but a lot of drama of it as
well absolutely a lot of drama off the
board I mean hey like Lou has some some
technical issues he'll be back obviously
you know we're trying to get him back so
stay tuned for that but definitely that
was a problem there I mean Prague was
ready to play and something happened
with the connection there we also saw in
the games right crazy stuff with Wei I
mean this is already what exactly what
we wanted just action of course uh we
really want it all on the board a little
bit off the board but definitely here
it's a lot of action and we got round
two coming up uh in a minute here yeah
so it's amazing it's crazy right now
yeah I think James as chess fans we all
hope that the drama remains on the boat
so we're really trying to get Lou yiping
to be back for round two these are the
pairings that we do have the technical
issues do continue on that board with
ronak savani against Louis ping we also
see Prague who will be playing he did
not play his first round because of the
four feet he'll be taking on Julie where
Charlie will be against weigi and where
he he was on the brink of winning a
great attacking Masterpiece when it all
suddenly went absolutely wrong for the
Chinese Grandmaster
yeah that's very uh very disappointing I
mean as you know you have an attack like
that you're you're known for being
ferocious you're playing the board four
as well right you're like oh yeah this
is for this should work everything is in
my favor it was then it wasn't and look
at Lou here
on a screen getting it getting ready
right he seems like he's in his own
everything seems like it's working out
maybe you'll see him in round two yeah
and the one player I was trying to get
into the zone is international Master
Luigi thing we see them on the camera
that he is trying to connect to chascom
so that he can play his round two and
we're only hoping that does happen
because it would be very unfortunate and
nobody wants to win like that James
least of all these players there they're
known for their sportsmanship right now
this will be the game that we will be
focusing on with pragnananda taking on
Julie it is the first game for Prague he
starts with the white pieces and he
makes the move the king spawn opening
we're gonna have a sicilian an open
Sicilian
in fact uh this is actually uh we're
looking at uh Rana here we go we have a
Rana game here with his Runner versus
Lou Lou is ready he's here there we go
that's exactly what I was thinking
perfect oh okay here we go this is
actually something cool Bishop E3 come
on should be three A6 G4
love that line so much it should be 3a6
G4
excuse me three
A6
G4 running sadwani he has to bounce back
because he had a tough game in the armed
one and this is before immediately come
on bro
I know yourself
this is gonna be a fun one come on ronak
and Bishop E3 by transposition come on
young fella
uh
James this is exactly the opening that
ronak sadhwani faced with the black
pieces at least the structure we didn't
have a G4 then but you remember the
first game again Julie it was run up
with black Julie took on C6 and five
moves later Rana blundered the queen
this time he plays with the white pieces
and we see Louis ping we're so happy
that he is back and he is playing he
decides to take on C6 with the queen and
James the reason for that is you want to
take with the pawn but once G4 is
committed what you want is to make the
most of this diagonal with the light
Square as weakened you want your Bishop
on B7 you want that battery set up and
that's what black is looking for
absolutely that's that's where the
counter play usually goes is like B5 B4
Bishop B7 the bishop is on E3 we
literally are reaching a position by
transposition like that you would get
with Bishop E3 G4 usually the pawns on
B5 here in these situations this is a
very aggressive chest a very aggressive
style I actually won a nice game against
the strong and I am OTB with the same
line so this is a very strong strong
Nails gandalia slices too from the white
side so it's a very strong situation and
you can be in a lot of trouble from the
black side here if you don't know what
you're doing but it is very double-edged
look at Lou though Lou is on the iPad
you know I mean he's playing off the pad
playing off the pad you're not going to
stop me I might have had some issues but
now I got my iPad look at him right
there ready to go I'm sure he's uh here
for the uh the long run guys with the
iPad look at him you know one move at a
time ain't no mouse slip here no mouse
slips over here buddy
this is amazing to see I was gonna say
James you gotta address the elephant in
the room but in this case it's the iPad
in the room we don't see this often but
this time Lu yiping is doing what needs
to be done he has connected and he will
be playing from the iPad with James in
those time scrambles this could get
tricky handling the game from the iPad
yeah it can actually but you know what
well yeah in time scrambles that's not
gonna be good that is it's tough because
I don't even think you can even pre-move
I mean you can but like you can do
multiple pre-moves but I don't think you
can do that on the iPad and that is
difficult to do now you know who was the
the best on the iPad I'm talking about
super super GM that's not even a title
but that is what you're gonna give to
him it's Krista for you Christopher you
hits 50s easily on the iPad where that
man finger just is like yo man check it
is my wallet still there right like he
is very quick with the hands there that
is uh the young kid there Christopher
you it's extremely strong on the iPad
wow and this position it looks extremely
strong for black because the last move
was a double attack on The Rook on H1
and the pawn on E5 and yeah if we just
back up and see how this happened but
Queen D2 was played The Rook is already
on G1 but can't white just can't black
just pick up the E5 Pawn now Queenie
yeah you're hitting on H2 you're hitting
on B2 is there a tactics that we're
missing there's actually no tactic but
this is a common idea where you actually
do sacrifice upon many times in this
life it's just for initiative Black's
development is not there right so we I
exit Queen 185 Castle Queen side perfect
so it's here it's actually on the board
so the initiative here is with white
trying to get F4 F5 and ASAP so if we
see a D5 we may have an F4 immediately
right in many cases Queen has to go back
somewhere we have F5 we can start
pushing up on him and then of course now
engine you know saying oh it's like 0.1
for black right that's crazy it says
they're like black but you're up a pawn
right so it should be you know plus one
or something higher than that but
because of the initiative that I have
I'm Castle the Rooks are almost
connected I can move the bishop to like
D3 G2 I have H4 G5 I mean white is
always for choice in these positions if
black is able to consolidate there's
going to be some problems for white but
at the same time um we are you know
attacking 100 in this uh in this game
this is going to be a fun game you can
already tell black has gotten greedy
with that Central Pawn but it could be a
keep on Juan's Lou yipping is able to
consolidate and finish his development
so time is of the essence here for ronik
he needs to build that attack that
initiative going as soon as possible do
not give black just a couple of moves
with that Bishop developing to E7 the
pawn the D7 Pawn moving to D5 see how
the bishop coming out and Asha castle
and if that happens black is fine so not
a few moves ronak needs to build the
attack uh and LU yiping starts with the
developing Bishop C5 trying to trade
more pieces he's up and up up upon makes
a lot of sense James we will move we
will take this moment to zoom out for
just a moment and take a look at some of
the other games that are on because
action is on on all the boards which is
great to see and a huge shout out to the
chesscom team for making sure that Louis
ping is back in action and he gets a
game
yeah he gets a game and that's what we
want here like we want it to be
extremely Fair of course like the
connection issues I mean it happens as
part of the online chess uh era but the
problem is uh you know we have things
like that where it just kind of sucks so
now that he's back that's great we have
all games live Tanya where do you want
to go
I mean just look at the boards in front
of us it's hard to pick one on the top
right you have a Pawn on G4 and on the
top left you have a Pawn on H5 upon on
E5 and that looks like a position that's
come out of the king's Indian attack
pregnant on that definitely happy with
what he's gotten there are all these
attacking possibilities we see the
Knight advancing towards the king side a
potential sacrifice on eight six and on
the bottom left his sister vaishali
against weihi so far I can see that
white is the one who's putting the
pressure better pieces you've got this
battery on the diagonal watch out for
that tender spot F7 B7 things could get
tricky for vaishali James what do you
say should we go over to the top left
which against program because that looks
like a really fun one absolutely let's
go there first we haven't seen Prague in
action yet uh he was unable to play in
the first round because he of the
technical issues with loose and lose
back we see Prague now on the screen
ready to go him and his sister are just
very strong uh very strong Duo there
playing against Zoo Yi here I do like
this Kia that's going on Kia meaning Kia
King's Indian attack the reverse of the
king's Indian defense black has done
everything he's supposed to do hits C2
right play on The Queen side of the
board of the board even Bobby Fischer
says when it gets very close when the
pawn gets to B4 this is called the Bobby
Fischer A3 where Bobby Fischer many
times in the Kaa one of the
practitioners of the king's Indian
attack it's A3 correct there it is Bobby
Fischer A3 and he played it before B4
but usually Bobby would play it with a
promise on B4 the A3 does stop B4 anyway
and then we're gonna go with our Knight
G4 and just try to sack everything and
go for me I'm loving it here
and as you're mentioning for black the
play is all on the queen side right and
for white he's gonna start Prague is
going to start focusing on trying to get
a sack in on 86. now again with such
little time to make something happen on
the queen side it might be the moment
for Julie to still push for beasts
before he needs to get those weaknesses
that play in and I'm just wondering does
he start with the move Queen B6 or does
he get hyper aggressive and sacrifices
the pawn immediately on B4 so that if
you recapture I can put an attack on
that double Pawn with the move Queen B6
time to create time to play on the queen
side that's a q moved on him B4 but
actually I don't have to take it at all
in fact I'm just gonna sit there and let
it happen Queen B6 is the move that he
chose in fact with the B4 idea but again
I don't have to touch that pawn at all
ever in life now there's actually a gang
with karaoke and I think it was like I
don't remember who we played or where
but it was a king H1 Kia Bishop F3 and
Rook G1 and playing G4 G5 it was an idea
that I haven't seen in the king's Indian
attack almost ever which is really cool
that
right King H1 Rook G1 playing Bishop
moving moving the bishop and playing G4
G5 which is quite quite quite cool I
thought that was pretty pretty cool idea
that's something I haven't seen yet so
right he has to clarify Kia yeah exactly
right so what do you think Tanya though
well one thing's clear whatever is your
next move Black's move is simple
Hui wants to go before next that's right
and again we've been talking about these
ideas of trying to create a sacrifice on
86 so Knight G4 would be a move that I
would consider but it all comes down to
evaluating do the sacrifices actually
work on A6 yes you can take it with the
bishop you can get your queen in but
that combo of the bishop on E7 and the
Knight on D7 which can hop over to f8 it
does feel that black will be able to
keep things under control on the king
side especially because do you even drop
left and the answer for white in this
one would be no because there is no
rookie for Rook G4 correct correct and
of course yeah and this is why I I came
to mind of the kuryakin idea moving the
king over and Rook G1 because I mean
after we do sacrifice we do have to
think about the defense of our opponent
which could be bishop f8 and we don't
have the Rook lift the Knight is not
ideally placed yet maybe yeah even then
that doesn't work yeah because the
Knight on D7 that's crazy these are
plays well if Knight is on G4 right in
the sexy just make a move here Knight to
G4 just to show an idea let's go like B4
and you sack and pawn takes and queen
takes right and then we do queen takes
H6 and then Bishop f8 happens right with
the bishop f8 we did have a knight F6
here which we would like to play at some
point this is why the knights on G4 but
the problem is he just takes it after
Knight F6 then we take you have to take
with the queen because your Queen's
hanging right and then we don't have the
right material yet and we just kind of
sacrificed everything for something that
is not working calculation is required
and also on top of that the right piece
play we need more material on this side
of the board hence the idea again with
King H1 G4 G5 trying to play Rook G1 and
just really abandoning this side of the
board saying hey you can have an extra
Pawn over here but you got to be quick
and it has to be fast and it has to be
accurate
yeah and speaking of being fast well
Prague decided another route for the
Knight to F3 so still eyeing maybe that
G4 G5 break that you're talking about
but also putting pressure on D4 and UE
was super fast making the move B4 he
barely took seconds he knows his play
lies on the queen side now one thing is
one thing to notice here is that with
that last move Knight F3 if white was to
capture on B4 black can't retake with
the queen hitting on B2 asking for a
trade because then the D4 Pawn becomes a
weakness but it is a big moment for
Prague because black can recapture with
that Bishop on E7 to B4 is that the
structure that you want in this position
and Prague says yes it is he goes for he
takes B4 Bishop B4 on the board you
could not have taken with the queen and
now expecting the queen to fall back
what Square Queen C1 so that you can
still i86. absolutely on the board on
the board on the board here so this is
not exactly the king's Indian attack
that we want so this is kind of a win
for black to be honest but in that sense
but of course it's still a lot of play
left in fact plaque doesn't have the
ideal King's Indian attack setup you
would like to have usually your pawns
here and here and like pushing
everything this way but which you don't
actually have you also have the double
pawns here and as you pointed out the
weakness on D4 is pretty evident so you
do have this panel D4 this week the
bishop is actually blocked so I mean
it's quite level I think says the engine
two as well oh it's quite level quite
equal here white does have his chances
of sacrificing at the right moment so
really there's lots of moves that can be
play um for both sides here maybe even
starting with like a bishop of eight for
black that stops you know a bishop H6
threat and just trying to push um as
much as I can on this side of the board
so far so quite equal though I think
it's a dynamic equality though right
when we say equal it doesn't mean that
the game is going to end in a draw it
just means that both sides have their
own chances we see a play on different
flanks now one thing that black needs to
watch out for is that 86 sacrifice and
attempting move like Knight C5 James
because you know you're kind of have you
have your own Targets on the queen side
you're hitting that pawn on D3 you want
to jump with your knight on B3 if you Yi
wants to move that knight from D7 to C5
taking all his pieces on the queen side
notice how there's nothing around the
king to defend Bishop 86.
I'm not sure if it works or not but
Knight C5 Bishop 86 would be a scary
scary option for white correct
especially because yeah the time that
you need to get the bishop back which he
does move it back immediately and then
say all right you're right Tanya let me
put my Bishop back there first then put
the Knight on C5 and then we might have
something here now if we're playing
King's Indian attack you're supposed to
attack it's definitely a matter of time
before we start pushing this Pawn over
here we just I think practice probably
wants to maybe you know make a couple
moves over here I don't think there's
nothing that you worry about to be
honest though what is Black's the next
one okay it is Knight C5 for sure G4
there it is I understand I understand
Young fella D4 is time but brother it's
time Knight C5 and maybe we just put the
queen on D2
this is just amazing chess so much play
on the king side on the queen side with
James there's also so much play on the
other boards and I want to zoom out for
them for a moment because there is fire
on the board or should I say fire on the
iPad because take a look at what is
happening on the top right board ronak
savani against Liu ping F5 has been
played that's a pawn that can be taken
by two different pawns Louis yiping
decides not to go for either because if
you take if we just move one move back
instead of Rook C8 if he would have
taken gf5 Rook G8 comes in and that is
an absolute disaster on the board you
can't go in for this and if you take
with the e-pawn white has got so many
Pleasant choices you could think about a
trade but you could also just sidestep
with the queen I love that move Queen F4
hitting the Rook going in with the
temple and then Rook to E1 that would be
a mouse slip that would be a heartbreak
Queen F4 straight spot that right
therefore it's nice right Kelly's
refresh there and let's see how have a
side of the F5 move we got a few moves
after F5 was work to C8 hitting C2 C3
stops it and then Queen to C5 says trade
them but I don't think I'm gonna trade
these buddy Queen F4 wow oh Queen F4
Rook B two is that a thing that's a draw
Rippy two takes check check check check
wow it's a draw but where's your check
check oh yeah there is a check yeah
it's winning oh it's winning what how is
this winning I'm clearly
oh my goodness
okay let me actually see what this says
wow
it's checking them Rook C4 all right how
is that wait wait what no maybe Rook C4
before a check oh yeah that's what they
want that's curious what Rook C4 and
Rook B4 okay that makes sense all right
let me turn the engine off now wow yeah
that's interesting that's quite
interesting yeah oh my gosh she needs to
watch out then yeah
is probably a good move here it blocks
at least we don't have to worry about
working two anymore E5 I don't like it I
still like White's chances I mean you
have you have to be like you're
attacking the rookies lose G6 is a thing
Rook g g uh G8 is still a thing here so
I mean there's all kind of stuff can I
take on E6 now
wow that's crazy the engine just defends
everything
guys there's so many options and every
time I look at this
the unbelieve is the
thing yeah and he's just so calm right
now he's the one who's up on the clock
and that's an important factor he needs
to really try to keep the clock under
control in time scrambles this could
prove to be an absolute disaster because
it is something that the players are not
used to yeah this is a specifically
speaking of being used to like man
playing on the iPad look at him focused
on the pad like that's just insane focus
on the iPad there pretty nice now of
course if it does get down the pre-moves
yeah that is going to get tough because
you can only pre-boo like once on like
the iPad so he plays Bishop G2 to block
this for this uh Queen B2 idea he takes
on F5
I don't know this is looking Bleak for
white now uh man look at the setup I
don't have any pawn breaks this is not
looking good for Runner
yeah yeah he's just taking the Free Pawn
because that Bishop it blocked not only
the queen B2 idea but his own Rook James
from jumping on to G8 so Louis Bing
taking advantage of that picks up that
extra pawn and that's not one extra Pawn
he's up three Pawns in the position
Louis ping has three extra Pawns
if you thought one was good good try and
you thought two was good I mean three
pawns equal a piece at least right so
it's kind of uh ridiculous to be a three
or four bonds here it's pretty tough
right now white still has some chances
but they are looking quite Bleak now
they are not looking the greatest
anymore there were some errors somewhere
down the line but black is up if we
trade Queens if we do any type of Trades
here Black's gonna be for Choice all the
way King E7 what a move
whoa Queen H do you hang a rook when you
say you take my Rook I'll take your Rook
because the D4 Rook is hanging as well
James
C3 Pawn is pinned a tactics Galore
tactics everywhere yes calculation over
everything everything
come on tactics Tanya all right queen
king E7 that's a strong move I'm not
gonna lie I got hit with that I would be
like well this might be you know let's
let's think about the next game no but
you still have to like keep keep good a
good hit stay calm try to easier said
than done easier said and done try to
stay calm obviously this is a tough game
for for roundock once again
it really is and there are so many
there's so much geometry in this
position right because the D5 Pawn was
hanging but the Rook on D4 was pinned to
that Rook on G1 the Bishop from G2
couldn't move because there was a mate
on B2 there were all these ideas it was
insane it was just the geometry in the
position that was definitely insane
insane 100 here and now after this queen
to G7 move right it does uh defend the
bishop I wonder do we have any no we
don't we literally have nothing Rook D5
is nothing Bishop d55 is nothing I mean
like this this is just a move it's just
a move guys and this is going to be
tough minute 12 2 as well for Roanoke
not looking the greatest for the yogis
on this board
and we do see the three extra pawns also
keep a Black's King absolutely safe
there is a check on G5 and he gives it
but the king can just simply go back to
E8 and it's completely safe the big
difference is that that Rook on a James
which was not playing is now in the game
on h8 so he switched it around it's like
a rook castle that he's done if that
makes any sense that's funny he moved
into one side of the board with the King
back and my Rook is Castle Chad I have
to make sure I castle castle your Rooks
chat make sure you Castle your roads you
heard it here first
make sure you Castle your rips back so
Rook to E1 right and Rook takes D5 is
going to be okay we still got some play
like we literally do still have some
play Rook D5 is here he needs to be
accurate and you know ronak's hoping for
an inaccuracy from him
so Rook D5 as you mentioned is a thread
and black might want to make a move like
Queen to E7 offering a trade but that
allows white to step back with the queen
to G3 take control of this diagonal and
threaten checks on B8 so you really
don't want to make that move but then
how do you counter this threat with Rook
D5 because if Veronica is able to get
that in then we're talking about real
play for white in fact time is getting a
little bit more even here hit me if I'm
sure if I'm wrong here I'm feeling a
little bit better knowing that you're
Louis on an iPad so if time gets low you
are not able to pre-move more than one
time so I can it really will benefit me
right as well but C4 hey I like it you
know it's practical you know yes we see
the engine says minus four but as a
practical chance there is still chances
for white because there's uh you know we
King it's very we are attacking there's
obviously peace play activity so there's
Precision involved here really from both
sides because there could also be Rook
G2 stuff now the Rooks hanging look at
that in the aval bar goes all the way
down what is the move Tanya I don't know
what the move is here actually it's not
Bishop D5 because the B2 Pawn always
watch out for this Checkmate but maybe
you just and also the Evon Rook is
hanging right so you can't take on D5
with any of the pieces you still have to
spend some time defending that Rook he
sidesteps it Queen G3 was also not a
possibility because black could have
picked up that Bishop on G2 and now
renewing the threat on D5 chat this is
the moment you ignore the eval bar it
doesn't even matter what it says Wesley
said it he put it so beautifully that
often it gives an inhuman evaluation
with this position playing on seconds on
the clock on the iPad Lu yipping is
feeling the heat his King is in the
center he falls back with the queen
queen G3 the idea that we looked at
Queen B8 is a threat look this could go
either way it's 50 50. yes Eva Bar says
Oh Black seven P's but you got 30
seconds I'm on an iPad and I'm trying to
defend this position right I only can
pre-move one time cd5 is on tap we could
actually take with the bishop 2 as well
and take with this Rook Rook is still
covered in the back he plays F4 gives a
pawn back that is strong if Queen takes
there's E5 heat from Big Lou he
what else is that that was a great move
by the way
and ironic is on seconds he's playing on
18 seconds he does grab that F4 Pawn
With The Rook we see Lou yipping making
all the accurate moves the queen could
not have picked up the pawn F4 E5 also
G2 Bishop hanking don't forget Queen B8
is one check King D7 and the king is
safe for now but right now Rook F4
what's the follow-up he's down to Second
he's got seven seconds on the clock and
it's a bad move yeah it's definitely bad
because I mean I think he has to go back
F6
oh Pawn takes wife's back in the game
all the way Bishop D7 he moves The Rook
back wow okay and then five seconds he
doesn't have time gotta move the king
gonna be one all right one
all right and what do we have next all
right Rook g8s all right you gotta move
the queen connected to the bishop Queen
F3
F3 yeah definitely yeah
you're threatening Queen F6 at some
moment but watch out for that Bishop on
G2 okay Queen wait wait taste takes wait
oh but okay so it's a trade here five
seconds
is on the iPad let's not forget he's is
playing with five seconds on the clock
we see him how he's making a move he
does trade he picks up that Bishop on G2
black is out of danger black skin isn't
getting checkmated that's a good
practical decision by Lou I'm curious to
see how fast let me just I just want to
look at the cam to see you only get one
pre-move here man he don't even look
like he's moving that fast like he
doesn't seem panicked at all like and
James is winning right right now he's
got
bonds that can stop starting down the
Board and they'll be unstoppable but
will he be able to make the Moves In
Time
I mean he looks like it he's just so
calm he has seven seconds here he was
down to three at one point he was down
to three seconds at one point here oh
yeah yeah another crazy update we will
stick to this but pragnananda lost on
the top board he lost
oh wow he lost I can't believe that what
is happening in this match
wow yeah nothing look at that Earp on
anything
he's he's gonna play it now because Rook
B8 is a big threat now the other two
pawns the central pawns will just March
down the board assisted by the King
James but I see this has been a mistake
right was he supposed to just start
pushing the pawns probably but at the
same time here I mean yeah there's the
Evo bar like like this is I mean
practical sense you you're playing white
you know you're like bro I could lose
this so fast I mean look at this right
this seems like the right move King D4
put the king in the center is completely
wrong you gotta be kidding me right
Justice such a hard game especially in
games like in games are the hardest
thing if I think Rook d8 might do it
four
now Rook a seven is a threat check maybe
no that's rookie three watch out rookie
if you take on A7 rookie three check
picking up E2 with rookie three check
yeah oh but this is
yeah you go oh oh now he might have a
filler door though he might have a
feeling he missed rookie three
fill the door position oh my goodness
he got a Philly he got a feeling out of
nowhere and now he put the Rook on the
back rank when you push the pawn they
see you know you're in games devaretski
draw oh my goodness what a game oh my
gosh I knew you think he knows you can
see the frustration he did ever
ever with the black pieces but the
tension and the pressure of meeting that
time control of playing on seconds on
the iPad not able to be accurate there
what a Miss by him we have one more game
remaining in this match expect the
unexpected Chad Prague has lost on the
first ball Joo wanjun loses to pranesh
pranesh on two out of two so far let's
quickly dive into Wei and vaishali this
is the game that matters the most right
now where he has to win to equalize this
round wow yeah this is a win for for Wei
looking like a win looking like a win he
got to pass Pawn G2 is defended yeah
time I'm up time here this is all
looking good for waiting
James it's not over till it's over we
saw
we saw in that last game but I agree
with you that this is an end game there
aren't so many complications and Rook G3
check played Knight block said those
Queen side pawns will decide the game
they're absolutely Unstoppable two
connected past pawns and they're just
gonna roll down the board
yeah this is uh over here and last last
Stitch ever to do a weekend yeah and you
play it out you play it out for your
team right I mean many times you will
resign and also like you just play it
out for the team you have to you have to
until it's over because it's not over it
literally until it's over
yeah okay and it is over now as
fresh Ali does resign there's nothing
stopping the king from coming in the
pawn being assisted and a queening there
with that win
the Shanghai Tigers take round to
equalizing the match they lost around
one and they have managed to strike back
after an absolutely once again James
what is going on today this has been a
crazy round as well every round is is
very crazy I mean this is nice this is
great going into the finals this is
exactly what we wanted the chaos the
what is going on the oh my goodness did
you see that right you see a lot of that
this is only round two here as it's like
tied up that's crazy out of all this
chaos right I see it says in the chat
it's gonna be 4-4 at the end of this
chaos that's correct look at that on all
this chaos Tanya it's still evil
insane I feel like we're in an episode
of keeping up with the protest League
the kind of
reality show today
it's just insane we've had action on the
board action of it ronix advani they're
surviving against Louis ping he was down
three pawns Louis ping fighting it out
in the semi-finals on an iPad there
vaishali went down to Veggie way after a
tough round one does come back and
pranesh he's been the star once again
for the Indian yogis two back-to-back
wins this time taking down the women
world champion and Prague loses to juhi
James what's been more shocking for you
ah you know there's so many right here
like I don't mean the connection issue
and then like you know the win here and
a lot look at the Palm look how pumped
ah look he walking around here you know
what to do you know what to do flexing
he's flexing right now wow my guy that
is how that's how you know I felt that I
felt that I'm sure you felt that at home
I love that kind of pump and that energy
yeah Julie they're celebrating his win
against pragnananda definitely a big
moment not just for him but for the
whole team as well because that has
managed to now equalize the match and
this is where we stand after two super
dramatic rounds Chad at four each and
we've seen some great chess by these
players the top boards at 50 score and
then we see pranesh there with two out
of two and Zhu Yi is the star player for
China again with 100 score yeah that's
100 score man you know going crazy here
doing his thing right but also there's
uh these weird games and then tactics
and then misses and blunders and
everything that we actually really want
for entertainment of course now of
course they would want less of that as
players but definitely it's very
entertaining to watch and there's still
two rounds to go
yeah wow there hasn't been a single dull
moment so far or a positional game so
far every game has been full of fire and
Chad if you have been inspired by the
play of these great players we've got
some great news for you because if you
are a title player you are eligible to
compete in the 2023 Champions chess
store so don't miss your chance to
qualify for the tour's fourth event we
host qualifiers every Monday excluding
days when other CCT events are underway
and your next chance to join the action
is next Monday May 15th for details use
the command qualifiers in chat and with
that we are going to a break and when we
come back we have round three of this
exciting match between the yogis and the
Tigers
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples
under promotion as we said is the
process of promoting a pawn but not to
the most obvious or most powerful type
of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a night that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately chromic would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under voting to
a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the A4 EA diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent Checkmate on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
this year saw the return of the pro
chess league and thank goodness chat so
good to have you back PCL traded Queens
oh my gosh let's go
with the postseason upon us the only
getting higher which teams from around
the world
championship and also bite off a Lion's
Share of the fresh one hundred thousand
dollars up for grads the semi-finals of
the pro chess League playoffs have
finally arrived that's game he all wins
on the clock but also in the boredom
they've dominated this match from start
to finish the PCL is here to stay who
will be crowned its next champion
mgd1 takes it through to the semi-finals
the Indian water is strong around here
we are seeing one of the most dramatic
matches in protest League what action
we've had from the very start and after
all of it this is a close a super tight
fight between the Indian yogis and the
Shanghai Tigers the score is level there
have been hits and misses there have
been twists and turns we've seen
disconnections we've seen players
playing on the iPad just everything that
we want and more from the protest League
James the drama the action continues and
we see there that the top boards are at
50 and it's been the bottom the third
and the fourth word for these two teams
that have been doing the trick what's
funny is we've I've said this many times
and we see this since the the beginning
of the PCO is like if you can get your
third and fourth boards to perform it's
gonna be a great day but what happens
when both teams have that that's what's
happening today so maybe the top half of
course maybe they can get it together
and like try to get like their third and
fourth boards today but we got to see
what happens there's two more rounds to
go
two more rounds to go and we will be
starting we will be kicking off round
three very soon and of course we've got
exciting games all around as we're gonna
get closer to those Marquee matchups
which are going to be super even Well
for now we see pragna Nanda taking on
juvention that's Port one against board
two and a way he will be playing against
Ronald sadwani James ronak first round
disaster second round could have been
another loss for him he was down three
pawns he needs to switch it up he needs
to get back into form ASAP yeah of
course in fact uh Hikaru says uh I
remember he said this a long time ago
isn't it win losses like you know it's
not going your way you have to have
short-term memory loss because these you
have to forget about it real fast and
you got to go right into the game like
it's a brand new game which it is it's a
brand new game brand new day you have to
forget about the past here you have to
really just play your game here for the
team and play the best that I can right
now in this round because that could
help I mean this could be the round for
them or it could you know if you're
still in in the feelings or emotion
there the emotion can cause you to make
mistakes and lose a second game there
which is really gonna be tough for the
yogis
do it you need to do it fast because
game 3 is about to begin and of course
even for Prague we saw that celebration
that expression of emotion by Julie is
such a big moment for the Chinese player
taking down one of the biggest talents
in the world pregnant and Prague will be
taking on the women's world champion
juventon who engine has been a
Powerhouse for the Tigers she has taken
that Maxine washer she has taken down
several Grand Masters in this protest
league and we see Prague he's getting
ready for this one it was a tough game
the previous round James you said it the
players need to keep it behind them
absolutely I mean it looks like Prague
has already done that I mean you
actually see that he loses the same way
that he wins which is very nice when you
have a player that can do that I mean
they're Unstoppable which you see prag
as in these days since at this day and
time he definitely is very Unstoppable
in it so much potential and he's still
growing he's still getting better he's
very young so it's very you know it's
good to see that it feels like it looks
like as you can see from body language
he's just like ah next game let's get to
it I lost the last one it is what it is
let's get to this game and we have
ourselves a sort of counted on like or
maybe even ready like position so far
Knight of three G3 let's see how rag
responds usually goes D5 here
e65 E6 Queen's Indian
okay the bond might move to D4 then
we'll have and it's on the board so now
it is a proper Queen's Indian a Jew
ranjun loves to play the Catalan
positions but Prague isn't allowing that
right now as long as the pawn is on D7
Juve engine doesn't get the kind of
openings that she wants he strikes in
the center with C5 so taking the offbeat
path against the Catalan ready setup
that Vengeance started with Prague he's
playing with the black pieces but he
wants to create his chances in this game
absolutely in fact this is actually
you'll see this a lot from the grunfeld
type uh Petersfield under my accessible
courses Peter spitler actually has this
in his uh his ready chapter this is in
chapter this is in part two of his book
but he likes Bishop G7 and then you
actually by transposition it might reach
exactly from the book what he's talking
about but usually you go for this
literally same thing that white does
it's kind of symmetrical in a way you go
Bishop B7 Bishop G7 you go C5 and D5 and
you get a lot of activity in fact you
get a lot of activity despite the fact
that it's kind of symmetrical
all the Bishops on the boat have been
feather of course
the white to trade the dark Squad Bishop
meanwhile Prague wants to try to trade
the light Squad bishop and that would be
favorable Knight C3 played at some point
that Knight can land over to D5 to try
and force these trades
absolutely Knight D5 is going to be
quite annoying uh at the same time but I
mean hey you know what we can just make
some trades here I'll be fine with the
black pieces uh it looks like everything
is quite equal though it is Knight D7
ip6 is an idea too as well maybe move
the queen around curious to see how
Prague plays this position
um because it is quite symmetrical
and you want to create some chances
somewhere
if available if not given like you don't
want to take any risks it's not
necessary to take any risks especially a
strong Jew is you know you do want to
make sure the best of your position so
it's Knight C3 last move what do we play
what do you thinking Italian
our Prague is going to think in this
position and James I want to take that
moment he will show us the way as you
mentioned this is going to be a slow one
to heat up but we can expect action
later on in the middle game we will use
this moment to zoom out and take a look
on the other boards because we do see on
that top right Rana sadwani we have been
talking about his form today against
weiji you need to make sure that you are
on your a form well he started with a
marshall an anti-martial I think this
was with the move A4 where he goes into
an anti-martial we've been seeing this
in the world championship matches and so
far it looks like a level position but I
do like that white has managed to trade
on E5 last night is only five there is a
lot of pressure on that F3 Knight you
don't want to allow black to ruin the
pawn structure on the king side the last
move Bishop G4 threatens a capture on F3
Knight F3 is in the air now a big
decision do you go Knight D2 or do you
take the Knight on E5 with the bishop
that's a great question I I'm a big fan
of my Bishops yeah so 92 correct 92 and
I want to keep the tension I'm a big fan
of keeping tension as well Knight D7 I
do like this movie you might want to
reroute the bishop to F6 because it is a
terrible piece right now so Bishop of
six may be quite nice and put the other
night on C5 I like the reroute here H3
correct gotta kick him away but he might
just go Bishop Richmond
I just back that boy up
I wonder if you can play G4 there how do
we get oh this was a Roy or correct way
Lopez anti-marshall Dante Marshall Andy
Marshall yes A4 quick quick A4 for you
Roy Lopez players
very nice D4 takes takes Bishop 492 H3
takes takes and this is the live
position after Bishop to F6 yeah quite
equal very equal here B2 is obviously a
pawn you have to defend because you can
just you know pick and roll or uh stick
and move right take it and just get out
of there so Rook B1 is definitely uh
probably the move here
yeah talk with your Bishop to C1 Rook B1
makes a lot of sense but the fact that
Reggie has slowed down and we know just
he's so tricky and often his way of
defense is finding a way to counter
attack for counter offense the fact that
he's not made the move Rook B1 the only
move that stops Bishop B2 I would be
getting worried as ronak what is what
Wizardry will he show to actually create
something on the in this position yeah
it really makes you like think like you
know put your hands on here bro what are
you is there something I'm missing like
you really have to go into the think
tank here but then again like there's
nothing like there's no tactic E5
doesn't hit anything like that's
defended it doesn't do anything so C3
that's gonna weaken probably a little
bit of the B file especially after I
take first and then you're stuck with
these two Pawn Islands here C3 is kind
of weak like that's not a move you want
to actually make Rook a to B1 is
definitely looking like a move here but
he is in the think tank look at him just
he isn't look at him Flex him real quick
I need to hit the gym more my guys she's
way ER I see you but you know it's at
the same time here my man says he is in
the thing okay oh looks up does a
calculation like Hikaru does I don't
know what he's calculating but he is
calculating John is he gonna defend the
phone or will he come up with something
completely out of the box to create some
place sacrificing the pawn for the
initiative because there is literally
you don't want to make a move like C3
you block that diagonal but you create
so many weaknesses James after C3 black
would just trade on C3 the open B file
that pawn on C3 is a big weakness that's
not a move that's even on his radar
play that move
it's not even on the radar C3 played
immediately you know what Tanya I got
you C3 oh my gosh C3 what is this I
don't understand chess anymore yeah he
just didn't want to defend I guess you
know I get it in a practical sense he
doesn't want to defend this Pawn With
The Rook he wants to use it later for
something else he wants to probably move
it here and never have to because Rook
B1 keeps it there to defend for a long
time but you do have you know the error
the issues of these pawns being weak
James the last time this happened was
dangerous Rook G6 where I was like drook
G6 is never a move that you consider and
immediately it was played in that
tiebreaker we see C3 right now and as
you're pointing out see three Pawn is a
weakness The Rook on V8 takes control of
the open file what he's relying on is
the a pawn being a weakness for black
wheels yeah this one develops I was
really surprised by that decision James
we'll move across to the other board
we'll see how we handles that and take a
look on all across our four Birds top
left
two Vengeance Queen has arrived on 8-6
but for now it looks like there isn't an
assist that the queen has your knight
can jump to G5 but black snide on F6
keeps everything under control
pragnananda looking safe he's looking
for a counter play on The Queen side
Knight G5 has been played and now the
question is can black continue with the
idea of the a pawn March first place
Queen C8 a level game so far meanwhile
bottom left boat prague's sister is
playing against Louis ping and once
again yipping with some ambitious play
on The Queen side he is going for it in
this one right now I see that there is a
threat on the board Queen G6 do you want
to take a deep dive into that one
because that Knight on G6 is hanging
absolutely let's take a look at it V
Charlie let me click on okay here we go
perfect so it is why to move no can't be
Queen G6 is a thing okay so maybe A4 or
just move the Knight yeah that's
probably the best let's move the Knight
right let's move away 97.
hmm Tha maybe even let's move the king
away off of the diagonal so we can play
something like maybe F5
and can you start with a four instead I
thought the same thing A4 seems like um
wait is there a bishop F7 there
yeah there's got to be a bishop episode
let's discussed so that A4
Bishop F7 and after King takes we just
hit this man with a move what are you
doing with your life oh my goodness
right of course this is just a GG
starting your game puzzles everywhere
there and the idea here is after Rook
takes F7 we can take we can take the G6
so we just kind of still upon there so
A4 doesn't actually work but we do have
maybe King H7
or h8 Reason 14 H7 is to defend the
Knight so I can eventually play a five
what is Louis being doing it doesn't
look like he's putting in a move he's
typing a lot of stuff on it oh what is
he doing
he's trying to send emails he's texting
you're right like yo what time you want
to go out tonight bro nah bro hey I'm
playing right now bro hit me back later
dog okay all right cool oh let me make
my move sorry between G3 oh my gosh I
really hope that it's not another
disconnect for Louis ping because that
would be heartbreaking no honestly that
actually probably is exactly what's
going on right now he might be
reconnecting actually oh my goodness
that sucks bro that really hurts yeah
let's let's go somewhere else hopefully
uh yeah you can see he's has a he uh
yeah a little side there all right we're
gonna go somewhere else here let's go to
the birthday
we will try and get Louis pink back on
our camera soon and see how that
progresses but it's a big moment and a
big board for the Shanghai Tigers it is
going to be absolutely heartbreaking to
see him not being able to play because
of connection issues
yeah
whoa top right bottom right James bottom
right look at that game Tanya top right
bottom right top left anywhere pick your
poison I think it has to I mean that
bottom right game there's a bishop on F3
the Jeep on has vanished off the board
and what on Earth happened
is not even down he's down like a pawn
in that live position that we have for
all that compensation
whoa look at this bishop on C1 my guy
Queenie one night after he sacked a
piece here he played Knight F3 check wow
and it takes he's not down upon he's
down a piece I had to pawn
he's on a piece and a pawn I don't know
what's in that man you know look I need
to get some of that that Shanghai tiger
water like what is I mean the Indian
water is very strong but obviously it's
very aggressive over there in the Tigers
situation look at this can we do an
action replay of this Knight E5 Knight
D4 to Knight F3 move I mean I just want
to see it over and over again
so cool yeah
let's just go back to that moment when
he played Knight F3
yeah this isn't insane Bishop G4 only
moved with the queen and he clearly saw
this idea he gives a whole piece to
destroy White's King's protective shield
those pawns and now all he needs is the
queen to arrive on G5 James what's the
fastest way to get it there you gotta
move your knight to start with do you go
95. would you like chief for wow I'm
going here and then Queen H4 I'm going
here science
that's brutal going tactics over
everything maybe 95 too but 94 94 is is
definitely a good start you just yeah
hey you know what send the whole send
everything
Knight G4 Queen H4 I have made on H1 I'm
also hitting H3 how do you even like
what do you do after that Knight G4 the
only thing is that it's a great idea but
also to understand that you won't block
the G file from a human perspective like
UE has to find this you block the G file
voluntarily but the point is that white
can't take on G4 because that opens the
H file up and your queen is unstoppably
arriving on to G5 or H4 next Knight G4
the other key point of that move is
James it takes away the key defensive
resource of that King moving to H2 if we
just put Knight G4 it stops the king
coming from H2 and any other pieces
joining the defense this is a great spot
by you and it and the eval bar approves
of your idea you you finds this it could
be the end of the game at this moment I
think it's on the board this man played
oh wait I'm out of time are you on your
own
don't leave me
James I need you for all the tactics
Knight G4 on the board as you spotted
James has left the chat but the attack
has arrived on this what a guy he takes
down pregnant on the in the last game in
this game sacrifices one night on F3
sacrifices another Knight on G4 shui is
a nightmare to deal with today a
nightmare is for real I mean he sacked
two nights Knight F3 Knight G4 night
night have a good night oh it's not
gonna be a good night try another night
right Knight G4 is game over boy he's
like two nights yo we gotta get this off
the screen there might be some underage
kids watching this one boy this is a
family channel this is crazy 94 is sick
I don't even see a spot I don't even
know what you do like I don't even I'm
trying to really figure out what do I do
to stop Queen H4 Queen H3 this is the
whole thing maybe Knight F4 maybe this
might be the only move because like I'm
trying to just stop what you're doing I
think Queen G5 oh my goodness this is an
amazing move Knight G4 the main point
again James just to bring it home that
you take away the square King to H2 any
other night Moon without allowed that
defensive resource and as you're saying
the queen is arriving into the attack
look at all of white species tied down
on the queen side nothing arrives in
time to defend that King you that
sacrifice on F3 just an entire piece for
Knight G4 and James you know juhi I'm
sure he had this move in mind when he
played Knight F3 he found it in just a
few minutes he plays it and now pranesh
is thinking but no amount of time will
be enough Queen G5 is that just came
over queen queen G5 or queen H4 either
of these two moves this is so good I
mean I think you have I mean like what
else do you do like
exactly besides maybe trying to give up
the queen but like come on bro come on
really really that's what you want to do
queen E3 like that's not gonna be it but
Knight F4 is maybe some chances Queen G5
I can't even move the king no that ain't
gonna work it's not gonna work pg5 ended
on the spot I don't know you might have
to really sack the queen I'm not even
kidding Knight D oh wait oh
93.92 G3 but you can't go Queen H4
that's what I wanted
what do you have for this that's mate
it's just me the queen of Story Once
Knight F4 James the other night the
knight from D3 will jump to F4 because
you need to keep the G3 Square defended
so the idea oh you're right you're right
oh my God
look at that at least I'm not losing
immediately unless I'm missing a mate in
one oh no I gotta get ready tonight like
G5 or something where's where's the
finishing blow um
I don't care I don't even care that's
like two nights Tanya like I don't even
care at this point if I lose I lose
I just literally don't care literally
don't even care anymore just just send
everything oh my gosh okay this looks
like the attack is absolute fire James
we will use this and queen H4 on the
board maybe we don't even have time to
move because he's just finding one great
move after another now once again Queen
H3 is a big threat white can't move the
E2 Knight to F4 because Queen G3 comes
in and that would be Checkmate which is
why James and I were looking at the
other night jumping on to F4 but all you
got to do with black is Kick That Knight
out and it's on the board we might be
seeing a G5 if he plays G5 James would
this be an absolute Masterpiece
absolutely this is probably best game of
the pro chess league right it's one of
those you know what I mean like this is
you know posterize for people to watch
basketball and you get dunked on and
like it's like oh my goodness that was
the dunk of the Year this is exactly
what this feels like right here he
sacked one night on F3 and he's set
another on G4 I like just open up the
cane here and like this is insane this
is very aggressive I mean it feels like
we watching way you know I mean they
must be brothers or something I mean
they got to be related playing this kind
of just like this is really really good
oh my goodness
unbelievable stuff and Chad we've got
our eye on the other boards but I have
to tell you that that all the action
right now is on this one so we will
stick to this because this game deserves
all our attention any praise is not
enough James you have been on point
you've been calling out the attack G5 as
you mentioned black has that much time
to make a move like G5 just hitting and
getting out getting that Defender out D4
played so pranesh hanging on he's going
to pick that pawn up with his Knight now
because he's blocked that Bishop well
can he because after Knight F4 there's
also Bishop D4 and you just renew your
threat of Queen G3 yikes I mean really
finally get some pieces out though like
man finally I can breathe a little bit
but Bishop d47 how do you stop Queen G3
look at all these pieces around the King
this is so sick man I mean I learned so
much with this attack today this is very
strong very strong now do we just do
Bishop E3 no he has probably should be
three of those Queen E3
defense my guy I'm not even gonna lie
there should be three guys at V3 you
can't take yeah yeah correct
it should be five calm okay literally
playing the best moves on the board
Bishop F4 Queen H3 coming next and that
is it all he needs to do is get rid of
the Defenders he
plays G5 get rid gets rid of one night
and now Bishop E5 gets rid of the other
Knight this is a master class on how you
attack
yeah I'm probably gonna watch this game
back probably two three times today
I am going to watch this game back two
or three times you get you know when you
want some inspiration of attacking chess
this is one of the games you look at
here right it's a smile in the chat
there's Chinese Michael tal right shout
out to grandfather towel there right I
mean that's crazy this game was very
sick very impressive from Zooey this is
just amazing stuff and I don't see a
move now you know pranesh has been
making the only defensive moves and his
position has collapsed now there are no
more resources left to defend and then
we have to go back and really think
James where did it all go wrong to wrong
for pernish that black has come with
this spectacular attack and it's hard to
point out the moment that it all went
wrong Bishop G4 and it felt like it was
Game or yeah this was this was rough in
fact actually right around here I mean
first off look at this move D5 like he
just really steamrolled this game and
Knight takes E5 was actually a move
right Queen E7 he moved it back to D3
sort of the carlson-esque
um in the Petrov that we saw with uh
Fabiano back in the day with the Knight
D3 move cool then he plays D5 first off
already a cool move takes Bishop B6 he
just wanted to open up the game he moved
the bishop back look at the development
now this is nice but it does block the
bishop the queen and everything's
blocked right E4 and Black's active so
this is sort of a Gambit in a way when
gambits can be very aggressive gamuts
are about rapid development what did
Black do Castle after Castle Bishop G4
rapid development I mean he got this
everything's out and then Knight F3 and
that was GG
oh super GG and now if you go to the
live position that we have every move
after this James getting that Queen to
H4 Nike for a great find then getting
rid of the first Defender now Bishop E5
pranesh thinks he's got two minutes on
the clock but it's not gonna help black
has a simple idea to pick up that H3
Pawn once that pawn Falls it's game over
white can't take the Knight on G4 you
can pick your Checkmate the easiest one
is Queen H1 that's a mating one if not
Bishop F4 is the big threat and I don't
even see a way for white to continue
this game for more than three moves
this was honestly the sickest game of
protesting for me I mean this is the
sickest game the tactics here of course
I love aggressive trust myself he's like
two pieces and a pawn in the beginning
and like willing to sack more like it's
just I mean this was a great attacking
play I really did feel like you watched
Tau played his game like he just
tactically did everything here beautiful
play absolutely beautiful he plays Queen
A5 okay so what's the idea here what's
the idea he wants to get he wants to get
that Queen to Chief oh my God oh my God
somebody
I'm Out Boy I'm out of here though I
didn't pull my head I
can't even hear nothing I can't even
hear you all right now Chad I can't hear
anything should I take a photo of this
of this position
I'm gonna hang it on the wall
you get my phone hold on let me call my
mom okay Mom hey Ma yeah they doing it
over here bro yeah Ma all right hold on
let me take a picture wow I can't look
at this it's unreal this is just
incredible stuff Todd sacrifices at
peace sacrifices a queen white picks up
the Queen James we gotta show the
Checkmate look at the walk away
is Checkmate he's got reasons to be
proud look at this sacrificing a queen
and checkmating with the minor pieces
pronation also somewhere in his heart
has to know that his opponent just
played the most brilliant game what a
game by Julie taking that point and wow
there's action on the other birds but
Chad as we said that was the most
exciting one and take a look at the top
right board where he's playing on
seconds I think that's the game that
we've got to rush to
yeah that I'm still six I mean queen H3
guys that's the game of the year that
could be Game of the Year Chad that
could be game of the year I'm just
telling you right there that could be
Game of the Year Queen H3 there was
disgusting he sacked two nights and the
queen come on
come on bro what a nasty I'm still
thinking about it it's unbelievable
Queen A5 was tricky because if you take
that Knight there were checks on G5 and
queen H3 you gotta be so proud of
finding that and right now where he
needs to win this so that he can be
proud of taking his team he does have
the advantage right now we see that on
the eval bar it's an extra Pawn James
it's more activity of the pieces but
there's work to be done to convert this
position absolutely still work to be
done here we do have three pawns versus
two of course I mean even whoa Bishop
that's a nice move okay I am a fan takes
takes and we have some seventh rank
issues we still have the past Pawn I
mean White's definitely for Tradesman
ironic's having a tough day tough day
for Runner very dark and he's been one
of the rotation players today he has uh
he substituted for nehal he's taken
nihal's place and Bishop E7 it was a
forcing trade takes away a key Defender
once again andronic's position that G7
Pawn now is tender but for black you
need to find play on C3 does he start
with already putting pressure on C3 so
that Queen C3 will defend G7
I think uh he went Queen C4 but I
actually did works yeah that was a good
move rookie was really nice
James a week rooksy yet Queen G4 Queen
C3 that was rookie eight
oh that's crazy yeah that's some crazy
stuff okay what happens here it was
they're moving on seconds I'm assuming
oh wait wait Yi is has four seconds here
and actually pay attention to that till
now but he has no time really two second
increment is not out of time when you
have only four seconds so you have to
move very fast here almost instantly
wow and James you're getting some
amazing update uh that you were
mentioning that the game we saw with
Julie Game of the Year literally game of
the year the accuracy in that one 94.5
is one for the ages we have five
brilliant moves I had one I can Flex
like I have a flex of like three
brilliant moves in an OTB game I have
never had five in one game I don't know
how many what's the most can we get a
chess com like uh what's the most in the
game
let's see if deduction can get that for
us but this one had five brilliances
chat
I don't ever want to play that man I
don't ever want to play him I'd rather
play Magnus Carlson before I play way he
I mean it's the Yi family okay I don't
want to play either one of them boys you
know what I mean either one okay
wow wow so now we're gonna see is that a
repetition that really he's not gonna
repeat he's up upon yeah he doesn't he
goes Rook D4 it makes absolutely no
sense but right now how does he improve
this position he goes Queen F4 he's got
to start targeting G7 somehow
metal
that is super committal definitely Rook
86 James Rook 86 is coming
oh but it's probably draw it's probably
draw I mean like what do you do next
there's a lot of checks and like yeah
it's probably draw
but he doesn't go into the Rook Bond
ending immediately so ronak savani will
have to earn that draw he's down to 12
seconds on the clock both players barely
any time but this with two versus one
it's just all about if he can get any
attack on the king if the Queens are
traded off this is an easy draw in The
Rook Pawn ending right James do you
think this is a moment that we zoom out
and take a look on the other or do you
want to stick to this because I think
now the dust has settled correct
let's get the bird's eye view up because
just as we were moving Jew Vengeance
cause a big result for the Shanghai
tiger us she takes down pregnant it's
been a disastrous start for Prague after
winning that first game it was not even
a game that was a four feet he's lost
two games in a row we have the vaishali
action on let's jump over to that it's a
king spawn ending and vaishali wins
immediately no time to jump that let's
go to veggie and ronak sagani the only
game remaining and if ronak wins this it
will be a level level round but Veronica
isn't winning this if anyone is it's
white so oh and as I said it yeah G5 you
can't take on F5 that's King G6 you hit
the rook and you're threatening a check
on B8 Rook F5 runs into King G6 yeah and
you check and you take wait wait a
second you can't take yet though it's
kind of but there's check and then you
go
GH
oh Ricky yeah Ricky yeah appreciate it
and now you pick it up with your rook
and this is a technical win technically
winning game Wei knows his end games he
knows the dwaretsky manual he starts
with rookie but I'm sure he's gonna pick
that pawn up with The Rook gives another
check I'm surprised he hasn't gone with
G8 review
okay hey he's gonna try to play this boy
or G8 correct he's got to pick up that
pawn but then King have fish see what
you're saying yeah King f8 but this is
winning James this is winning this
position is Emanuel
and that will tell you how
no you want to go rookate drive the king
away first so he stops it he goes yes
beautiful and push through that's it
don't push immediately
you give me six King comes back to G7
and that's the chronic doesn't even play
it out what a match by by the Shanghai
tigers where he takes down runx that
money it has been a nightmare for the
top two boards of the Indian yogis and
with that when the Tigers take a
two-point lead James 3-1 Victory but
again it all comes down to that game
with Julie the game of the tournament
the game of the year that is Game of the
Year 100 game of the year that means the
best actor Queen he's like both the
knights he's cycle Pawn what didn't he
sacrifice there and 94.5 five
brilliances I mean he gets he should sit
out the last round I think like it's
like you know hey guys you know that
game that should count for two games to
be honest it was such a great game there
it was amazing he definitely showed up
right so that was a great time
she's amazing she has all three out
let's take a look at how the players
have been performing so far these are
the overall scores and going into that
final round the Indian yogis have five
points the Shanghai tigers have seven
points and James we can see there look
at that m to the V to the P there with
Julie three out of three the guy has
been on fire today he took down
pragnananda he took down pranesh it's
not just about the result but the kind
of Chess he's played attacking style
he's Unstoppable meanwhile the top two
boards of the Indian yogis have been
struggling from the start and James
going into that final round they need to
win by 3-1 to force the playoff
honestly the Indian yogis I mean both
the Indian teams are 100 super strong I
mean like whatever they doing over there
whatever they eating right the Indians
are very very very strong they pop out
GM's every week you see another Indian
GM right so it's really strong here but
today is just not their day right now
they're gonna have to pick it up in the
fourth round it's still a close match
you still have two points it can be
doable we saw that yesterday actually
making it to a tie break it's very
possible but they're gonna have to do it
now
oh wow they really do it all comes down
to this the Shanghai tigers can in fact
afford to lose but only with a margin of
Two and a Half one and a half they need
only one and a half points the Tigers
will make their way into the finals if
they score one and a half in this final
run it's been a fantastic performance
and it all comes down to this man on
three out of three Zhu Yi with a huge
win over pranish but this match is still
very close we'll take a quick break when
we come back we'll see which team can be
the first to punch their ticket to the
PCL finals
good
unless you want to talk
okay when I say chess the first word
that pops into your mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile is
that swipe left or swipe right
is good right yeah then yeah instant
swipe right okay super into that right
I'm into it you're ready that's probably
whatever the swipe is I don't not
interested you're not interested in
chess players I'm not into chess players
are on Tinder oh I get that I in fact
that checks out if I ask you to name one
chess player in the world can you name a
chess player
yeah no not gonna Anna Taylor Joy
capable
wow name another one oh kasporov Casper
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm Gonna Give
You fifty dollars
spaski holgar
Carlson and
on holy you get 50 bucks dude oh my
God we just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
the message I really want to send to
people is that
you know men
the adults have to do better you know to
create a better culture because there
were so many accounts that I I've heard
that were mentioned in the article where
people's
very young at the time would say like
well you know I everybody else around me
acted like it was normal so I didn't say
anything I didn't do anything it just
was very normalized and yeah that just
needs to stop and we need to step up and
make sure that our game is like safe and
and fun for everyone
2100 wow that's amazing puzzles
[Music]
72 000 84 different possible positions
after two moves nine million different
possible positions after three moves
318 billion different possible positions
after four moves I'm gonna play the
London seriously I'm sorry foreign
[Music]
thank you
one she wants queen H6 what are you
doing I'm out I'm out
that was brilliant a comeback huge win
for the Indian yogis what a crazy game
oh my gosh he got it with this question
that's game vinegar is running about to
win with the black against Magnus
Carlson this is
knitting pattern this is going to be the
classic Queenie for Rook C2 by Charlie
defeats dubov that is a big win for the
yogis
welcome back everyone to the final game
of the rapid between the Shanghai tigers
and the Indian yogis it's time to go big
or go home for the yogis they need to
win this round for on demand and that to
buy at least a 3-1 margin to force a
playoff let's bring up our scores and
this is where we stand going into this
final game of the semi-finals and there
we see James a big round coming up with
the yogis this is their time or it is
time to go back prognananda takes on way
with the white pieces it's been a shaky
start but if he makes this one count all
will be forgiven absolutely I mean of
course we've seen that yesterday tie
breaks are very possible yeah I'm up two
points here's the Tigers but it's not
over things can happen and you guys can
go through a tie break it is very very
possible because that is possible they
need to stay very stoic and play the
best game that they can because
especially from prags from Roanoke here
I got white here in this last round I am
actually going to play my best game I've
ever played right just like we saw
Julian play Game of the Year in the last
round here so it's gonna have to be one
of those maybe we'll have Game of the
Year again in this round right here
because they're gonna have to bring it
to the Tigers
hey this has been an amazing match James
we've seen
we've supported
in fantastic play there so far by the
Tigers and we also see Julie will be
taking on vaishali these are the
matchups for the final round of the
rapid and James juhi do you think he can
have a hundred percent score today he's
on three out of three and not just a
scarf he's played phenomenal chess no
he's trying to in fact he's trying to do
four out of four I mean he's pumped you
see him every time he wins he like walks
around and like you know he doesn't walk
around with the flex but you can tell
he's like in his head like ah I did that
let's go fist pump he's amped walking in
circles in his room the man is pumped
out of his mind after playing that last
game too as well he feels almost
Invincible that's a scary Zoo Yi to face
right now but there's still one more
round left
those tactical masterpieces definitely
games that will go down in the history
book and you get a hundred percent score
when it matters the most you punch the
ticket for the tigers into the finals
he'll be playing against vaishali and
vaishali's brother who has been shaky
today pragnananda after two back-to-back
losses faces the top Board of the Tigers
he will be playing against where he and
this is not the first time the two have
played against each other in fact
pragnananda is the one who leads in
their head to head with a point where
James this is going to be a close battle
for them Prague is white where he is a
rating favorite what's your prediction
for this one yeah Prague is definitely
gonna bring his best he has the white
pieces too as well Prague especially
when he's on form he can be unstoppable
you've seen that before he's beat Magnus
multiple times to say the least right
that says a statement in itself right he
looks very calm and that's a very good
way to be even his sister has that same
thing and I was like bro what's going on
like you just had a quick something he's
looking at caught his attention there
but at the same time practice and look
like oh this is we gotta win type thing
like oh man like he just feels like he
looks like he wants to play he's ready
to play right he got way over here it
looks the same I mean that's just
something you see around the board with
these top players here you know you have
to control that emotion
where you right now doesn't look like a
Believer as we saw on prague's t-shirt
they always does say believer away
looking super calm and confident himself
he's ready to go he's played some
fantastic chess today even the game that
he lost to pranesh James with the black
pieces he was completely winning in that
one just a little bit of rashness there
saw that one slip out of his hand and
now it all comes down to this once again
the Tigers lead with a two-point margin
this is the final round frog has to do
what has to be done for his team with
white he's going to start with the King
spawn opening absolutely and Prague is
actually in the think tank he's like
thinking Hmm how do I hit this man what
do I hit him with oh something's
happening interesting I see some words
there
yeah we will try and get an update on
that because we see that his clock his
timer has started but we see Prague is
going through some technical uh stuff on
this one and James once again I think I
speak for all of us that we don't want
any off-board drama especially on the
first board in this video game yeah we
hopefully we have everything on board in
this last round here we don't want
anything out of the ordinary of course
the first round happen whatever it is
it's done everything's been fine to this
point so hopefully pranks uh
um whatever's going on there is fine
this is the last round guys I mean look
two points as you see it there at the
bottom of the screen there Tiger's up
too it's the last round and the yogis do
have a very good chance as we saw
yesterday to make this to a tie break
but it all comes down to this match
right
and we are fixing that and I'm sure we
will have the games underwear soon and
the clock
the clocks did so
students what do you think will this
match go down to the wire we have seen
the Indian yogis make a huge comeback
earlier in the season when they took
down the chess bras in the last round
with a 4-0 victory so they have done it
in the past can they do it again uh
James I keep thinking about the rotation
that they've had with it nehal gone
replaced by Prague and ronak and it
hasn't worked out well for them so far
yeah and but the thing is like
everyone's strong everyone's very strong
on a team and it's good to have a very
you know good depth like we talked about
before but they they switched out and it
just didn't work and that that's just
you know it could go the other way
around too as well like with me Hall and
hit it maybe it could have went really
bad there like who knows right at the
same time the Indian teams are extremely
strong there's two of them in the
playoffs here but of course uh Indian
Yogi's not gonna have to show up right
now there is no other way than right now
you have to show up or you go home win
or go home it's a very simple and of
course easier said than done Tanya but
that's it it's very simple you have to
win or you go home then you can play
some spiritual level chess right now to
come back against the Tigers that we've
been seeing it's been an amazing show so
far by the tigers with their fans out
with their closet but once again I think
the top two boards is going to matter so
so much in this round James Prague and
ronak need to find their form really
quickly it is really now the time for
them to shine and as you mentioned in
hindsight everything makes sense but
once again coming from that quarterfinal
Victory where they did have the winning
team and right now taking this risk of
placing very two very strong players to
exceptional players well right now it
hasn't paid out but it all comes down to
what happens in this Final Round And of
course pragnananda is not even a risk
when you place him on the top board he
is the fifth youngest Grandmaster in
history James he became a Grandmaster
when he was 12 years old how do you even
do that chat how do you become a GM at
12 right I think I was I was going into
high school I was 2 000 right and that's
like 13. I was 2 000. that's like 500
way less right it's a different caliber
the boy is so wing and Swinging okay
very very strong the guy here lifts a
very heavy weight as you can tell you
can see on the screen the man be in the
gym the chess gym that is every single
day right okay prag is is a household
name we already know that and his sister
he's beat Magnus I mean accolades speak
for us so and he's from India you
already know it's a Powerhouse over
there you got this one to the nine you
got cram Nick helping the kids over
there it's really amazing how strong he
is at this level where he is in the age
that he said I think he's 18 now so very
strong you know two years like he did
all two years later like he's very very
you know stronger than what he was uh
even then he's only getting stronger has
so much potential to be you know greater
than what he is so big shout out to
Prague everybody knows Prague and he's a
lovable by everyone
he undoubtedly has all the potential and
right ingredients to make it to the
world top 10. we'll see if that happens
or not but right now the big question
for Prague will be can he take down the
top Board of the Shanghai Tigers it's an
uphill battle for him he plays against a
very inform where he who's got accolades
off his own it is unbelievable what he
achieved in the early part of his career
James he was just 15 when he crossed the
2700 barrier can you believe that at 15
2700 yeah 15 2700 absolutely super
strong you know what's funny I actually
clicked and I I look I looked through
his file and I was like you know what
openings does he play and I looked at
the black pieces and I'm like oh he
working oh he does nidor grunfel and I
look at his grunfels games just briefly
to see where the wins were what was he
doing he's an E4 player like a Jedi is
as a Jedi would because a Jedi could I
mean the man is a very very strong tiger
here and you can see he's ready to go
right now
what about the rest of us James who do
you just completely excluded us
aggressively you can you can play D4
aggressively Tanya like the Jar Jar
Binks London AKA The Joe Baba London
it's the same thing it's very aggressive
but that's the only way we play D4
aggressively is with Patrol problem
that one hard
massive is Wiggy and James he's got to
be one of the Front Runners for also our
MVP award which chat will be real will
be revealed on Sunday the big hit us the
top three hitters of the season the MVPs
of the season and where he is with a
massive score of 15 out of 19 games so
far that is an incredible performance
and that has seen the Shanghai Tigers
get this far in the league can they make
it to the finals absolutely that's
that's the question can he make it I
mean the Yogi's here and uh the Tigers
guys what do you think Chad we got to
give it back to the chat what do you
think Chad who is going to win there's
only one round left
right five and seven we've seen tie
breaks yesterday what do you think is
going to happen Chad I'm gonna put this
on you guys it's up to you now you're
gonna call it Chad what is it
what is it we need shot predictions will
this go down to the wire like the
levitor of mgd1 match that we saw and
that was also an epic comeback by
levitov in the final round the levitar
visits
will the yogis be able to pull this off
today they need to win with a minimum
margin of three three one to take it to
the playoffs Shanghai tigers look like
they're Unstoppable uncatchable
currently so can they do it chapter last
but James one thing is for sure while we
get the games going and they will start
very soon chat is that the Tigers so far
have really bought in the fire today
it's been one of the best matches that
we've commentated that we've witnessed
in the protest League yeah and
especially with the game of the year
from Zooey there like that's uh insane
the Tigers actually every single round
like you said have been using the same
lineup what does that tell you there's
something with them four players that
has made them get this far every single
time four players make it this far in
the Pro chess League they do it every
single time they don't change anything
they keep them the same and they've been
winning they made it this far they're on
the brink of beating the yogis I don't
know what's you know the tigers are
really really strong and people are not
talking about them enough and it's
actually showing right now yogis
obviously I mean I'm not gonna lie look
on paper I am a yogis all day Yogi's fan
I love Indian chess because of how
strong it is and like they always
popping out GMS but right now the tigers
are like hey I don't care who I'm
playing we're winning the match that's
what's going on right now hopefully
yogis can bounce back
they need one and a half points in this
final game and as you were talking about
yogis I mean they're the top seeds in
the event Magnus pitched them as the
favorite to actually win it that's how
strong they are they are the first team
to have actually made it to the playoffs
winning three back-to-back matches in
the regular season but James what you
mentioned about the Tigers right from
week one they've stuck to the exact same
Squad it's the only team that hasn't
rotated a single player that's crazy and
that has been a great approach that's
paid off but few teams would have done
that would have taken that risk you're
right like that's great everyone else
has changed their lineup which is like
just really insane and is inspiring and
it shows how strong the tigers are like
you know you figure who who is even on
the Tigers team besides them four like
you don't even know at this point now
it's really really uh amazing how far
they made it with the four that they
have look at product Focus you're like
nah ain't about to do me like this I
don't like this I need to perform you
know you can it's lots of emotions you
can tell from his face right now
um and hopefully he's able to bounce
back for the yogis in this last round
he really needs to it has been a tough
day for ronic in this match starting
from that game one and then game two
could have been a big loss for him he
managed to survive that it's been
difficult so far but will he be able to
come back into form the one player who
has been in form for the Indian yogis is
vaishali she has been an amazing
performer scoring seven out of 15 before
this match started for the yogis we've
seen her take down top Grand Masters in
the league including Daniel dubov
including soupy and she's been amazing
so far she needs to do that in this
final game as well and of course the
youngest player on the squad pranesh he
is all of 17 he became a Grandmaster
when he was just 16 years old prunesh is
a story of grit and determination
overcoming hardships James you know he
got his International masternam I think
it was back in 2020 and he made his
first Grand masternam in 21. and then
the community the Indian Community came
together to actually sponsor his trip to
go play in Citrus where he's got his
final Norm wow I mean what a strong kid
there and you also mentioned he didn't
get a laptop until later which is insane
it tells you of course guys you don't
need you know chess online has changed
things so you can do it much faster but
the books are never played out you know
ever okay so it's good it's good to
understand it
and the one player who has been playing
her heart are in the protest league for
the Tigers has been juven Jin at 10 and
a half out of 19 she's played all the
matches well just like all the other
Tigers she's been a Mainstay she's a
three times woman world champion she
will be defending her title for the
fourth time in July but right now that's
not what's on juventions mind that's not
what she's thinking about she's only
thinking about his fourth game instead
James which if she does well will push
her team over to the finals very strong
of course defending for the fourth time
like whoa that's insane you know four
times three times one time all you did
it second okay all right you Dice three
times yo what's going on like fourth
time is like insane right so she's
definitely legendary right now look at
this guy right here look at this guy
Tanya game of the year that's what they
call me
let me get my name changed is that
legendary that was some legendary play
by Julie that we've been seeing so far
every single game chat has been an
attacking Masterpiece every single game
has been a Firepower and especially that
last one against pranish what a game
that was sacrificing ending with a queen
sacrifice to checkmate with three minor
pieces with the black pieces right out
of the opening it was a big struggle for
pranesh by the one player who has been
overcoming the struggles today has been
International Master Liu yiping we saw
him four feet that first game against
Prague as he failed to connect to the
servers he has been playing on his iPad
which we see in front of him and James
he's been putting on quite the show
doesn't matter if it's a phone iPad text
message mail however you want to do it
I'm gonna get it done it says Lou as
he's sitting here right here the
technical issues and now the team is on
the verge of making it to the finals
here even after giving a game up in the
first game because I couldn't get my my
connection right now my connection's
right and I'm waiting for you to get
right look at him look at the camera I
see you I see you big dog I see you Luke
he's ready he's pumped he's ready to go
he's relaxed right that's the best way
to play is when you're relaxed like that
very nice from Luke I saw some good
chefs from him and also of course
contributing to his Tigers team today
rounds and this big wrongful coming up
that I can't wait for because I know the
yogis are going to play their hot shot
but the tigers are unstoppable so it's
gonna be a big big battle and all I can
think about is that for this match I was
here that we witnessed a chat chat you
were here to see some of the best
moments in online chats that have
happened you
chat you did you see game of the year
you were here for Game of the Year
that's it you were oh my gosh you were
how does that feel bring it in bring it
everybody bring it in one time I know
that's love right there you feel that
that's love that's love I understand
I understand you gotta say nothing
understand
it's all love for all these players shot
we are getting ready to get the games
going in just a few moments we will
start with this final run let's just
reset the table James for anyone who's
joining us right now Tigers the Shanghai
tigers are at seven points the Indian
yogis at Five Points going into this
final round of the semi-finals the
Tigers need one and a half out of four
to qualify for the finals it will be the
end of the road for the yogis the yogis
need to win by a margin of at least 3-1
to go into a playoff which will mean
more Blitz action uh chat I want to hear
it from you guys do you think this will
go down to the wire or will it be
decided in this one James what's your
prediction make a prediction right now
will the Tigers go through to the finals
or will we have a playoff what do you
think is going to happen you know what I
think the Tigers I'm gonna be completely
honest the Tigers are in a great form
this is a form that you don't see this
is like a Super Saiyan form of a tiger
like a evolved tiger a liger in a way
like come but something's on something's
up with these Tigers today and it's
going to be very hard to stop them right
now it's gonna be very hard did you say
something about a London earlier
something about D4 and how the London is
the only way to go James check out what
is happening all right we do have a
London we do have a London here we do
have a London and of course it's very
strong even uh Magnus is a fan of the
London I'm a fan of the Jar Jar Binks
London but at the same time here this is
a London you can go very nice we saw
this in a world championship right who
won that London game dinged it so the
London for all the like oh you play the
London system well ding won the World
Championship right that's the response
now so it's uh it's definitely a move
it's definitely a game and it's
something I am a little of a fan of just
a lot of system what about you Tanya you
like London yeah
I've got some really bad memories from
the London I I think it was I am not a
GM tournament where Eric Rosen he
destroyed me playing the London so it's
an opening that I don't understand how
white gets an advantage but it's also so
unpleasant to face especially in shorter
time controls oh it's not enough James
it still hurts I'm sorry okay I
apologize oh man and you know what's
funny I made it to the finals to play
Eric Rosen in I am not a GM speed test
Championship with the job of London I
beat shuvalova I'd be costia and I beat
Lord strength to make it to fights Eric
Rosen lost by like a few games two two
three games in the end but Joe Boba
loved it yeah I mean we both played the
same stuff in a way which is kind of
cool so yeah the London is annoying and
we've seen it in a world championship
firsthand but the London is not one that
you do and that you just off it's a
London system well hey hey we got a
world champion it has played it now so
it is important to understand here this
is a different kind of London I actually
do like black because of the
possibilities of the pawn breaks like E5
looks good maybe even some like G5 five
I know that's crazy but I'm talking okay
well okay so can you sign up but that's
like with that's what a castle Queen
side type idea I think is dynamic to say
the least
yeah definitely traditionally London was
a was expected to be a more positional
approach C3 E3 Knight D2 but we do see
which of our London and these kind of
openings as well what we're seeing with
Prague employee taking on C5 he's won
that extra Pawn that that's definitely a
lot of dynamic power in the London
currently white has an extra Pawn black
still needs to spend some tempos and
some time to win that pawn back but the
drawback has been that white also has
two double pawns one on the C file one
on the f file and a lead in development
James we will zoom out of this one we
know where he loves to play for the
initiative we will come back to this and
see how this develops but let's get a
bird's eye view on all the action that
is going on in this very crucial round
what catches your eye uh in fact let's
take a look let me see
okay that one that one that one okay
let's go to bottom left that's zoo Yi
and vishali that game is important I
think because exactly Knight B5 just
happened it looks like some type of
Cecilia let's see which one it was and
in fact it was a sicilian it was a Roz
or Sicilian there so E4 yep C5 let's
just see how we got to this position
takes Knight F6 Knight C3 Bishop G5 fan
I'm a fan of this too as well very
aggressive G6 that was not played a lot
that one is not played a lot looking
through the files for sure G6 is a rare
ER move it's not like it's not a move
but it's a rarer move so of course we do
have Bishop takes sorry let's go back
two six takes takes and then Bishop B5
this is all Theory Bishop A4 I'm not
familiar with the Knight B5 he hits D6
and then he takes on D6 and I'm curious
to know you know I'm just it might just
have a pawn three six three six seven
I'm gonna put Pawn here Tanya
yeah you're up a pond but again it is
about that initiated white hasn't
castled yet there is a lead in
development but you're totally right it
is about timing and black needs to start
playing forcefully to get that
initiative now Queen D6 the first build
that comes to mind is pushing that
Knight out of B5 you want to go A6 you
potentially want to try to get B5 the
other move that black really wants in
these structures is the move F6 to F5 it
needs to be timed well the reason for
that is James you want to open up your
bishop and G7 you want to dissolve the
problem of these doubled pawns the F6
and F7 but once again that's an idea
that needs to be timed perfectly Queen
D6 my first question to you is where do
you go with your knight after A6 you
know what I was actually considering
Knight C7 and didn't go back go to
Knight D5 I'm a big fan of the tempo I
worked with a coaster says like he
always will say I just love the tempo so
like of course when you hear it you know
we all know what the tempo is or like
you can gain time I'm always a fan of
looking at the tempo first because of
that just working with a Russian chess
coach so Knight C7 hitting the rubric CA
Knight D5 it's not a Tempo here but I do
reroute so A6 Knight C7 right I don't
see anything maybe is there any weird
Night Moves I don't see anything so okay
Rook C8 and I go back to D5 and I get
this Knight to D5 and then I can end up
casting Queen side as well I may have a
knight F6 on tap tactics now start to
arise here from this position so it's
very nice I actually do think they play
A6 in the game is that we might see this
being played out because 97 I really
like it
and I see something's really nice it's
on the board and it works here 1985
1955. you get out of there and you just
castle and you just have a good day I'm
up a pond says white I'm just up a clean
one right and it's going to be difficult
here to really make this happen you do
have the bishop pair and the bishop pair
they actually say is equal to upon if
you study chess here it does say like
okay in a way the bishop pair if you use
it correctly can be equal to the
conversation of the pawn that you might
be down so okay right whites have a pawn
but we do have the bishop pair versus
not having the bishop pair honestly I
still take white though I do like the
pawn by it activity Castle Queen side
Max pieces aren't Super Active yet
either Bishop James there's a threat on
the board after Knight D5 when you
mentioned with the Knight jumping onto
the center Bishop C6 Knight to E7 is in
there
Tanya would look tactics Tanya today
tactics time inspired you're rubbing off
on me right now James so white black
needs to fight this do you play rookie
eight right B5 another way to fight it
you hit that Bishop it still feels like
white has that extra pawn and now with
the knights in the center the bishop
eyeing this diagonal wait also seems to
have compensation and just one move away
from Clear Advantage he just needs to
get the king to safety correct in fact
the engine says right now
0.828 so like closer to a pawn now it
does say that black has conversation
because we're up a pawn but it doesn't
say like plus one point something right
like it would say when you're really up
a clean pawn it says but I got some
compensation but you are a human and
human here in fact I even saw something
from Wesley today actually uh in the uh
super after the game with the draw with
farrugia I think it was something like
that but it was the he was saying like
yeah you know the engine line is like no
humans kind of finding this thing it's
inhumane is the word he used there
that's kind of like you know here as a
human I'm up a pawn like I see it I'm up
upon it is what it is and here's your F5
move by the way the bishop actually
opens up so I can feel a little bit of
conversation for black after this move
it had to be played right James because
we were talking about how white is one
move away from castling and getting all
the initiative and the extra Pawn so you
want to aim at trying to open up the
e-file white could not have taken e
takes F5 because of a check an intern as
a check on E8 which would just disrupt
White's development completely so juhi
quickly takes the decision to bring the
king to safety uh goes for the queen
side Castle but James again this is one
of those moments where we take Wesley's
advice do not look at the eval bar with
the c Line open with that Bishop on G7
firing down on that diagonal there is
still so much activity for black that
one can feel the compensation in the
position and the eval bar doesn't matter
oh 100 you can feel the compensation
from black here you do have in fact
Sicilian conversation which just came
from a sicilian what does that mean The
Rook on CA very aggressive right now
what's weird is this Knight usually is
on F3 so reason why I do like white is
because only that if this Knight was on
any other other Square I would actually
take black in like every situation and
she probably Bishop five here which
attacks the queen what's a strong move
I'm not even gonna lie well we got only
two moves 97 to like take on D7 or queen
C5 and put your team right into that
right there I don't even care what the
computer says about Queen C5 that move
just looks like something that you don't
want to make even if it's the best to
move Queen C5 just placing it in front
of the Rook
I would be amazed if that actually
happens James on the other hand the
other tactic that you're pointing out of
sacrificing the D5 Knight simply to get
it out of the way but of course yui does
it in Julie's style Queen D7 we first go
for 97. he doesn't care he has to
sacrifice the queen because this is
Julie we are talking about he had Game
of the Year by sacking his Queens like I
mean why not do it again when do you get
a chance to sacrifice your queen two
games in a row actually in a day in a
great match like this and a huge match
where it actually works I mean of course
I'm taking you all day here this is
definitely fun but okay okay now black
uh so we uh be obvious here black does
have again serious compensation white
has some annoying things on the seventh
rank even my system right it's a strange
book Aaron nimsovich talks about right
the pigs on the seventh so here you want
to be able to put the Rooks and double
the Rooks and stuff like that right
taste takes so yeah okay black now has
some comments station gets double pawns
here we got the C file I still slightly
take white because again that pawn right
yeah so Sarah willing you know I get the
pun yes
you get one Pawn here and like are you
around yeah I thought I heard him well
back in 1987 I was a pawn and I took
that and I played it for seven hours
very nice that sounds like therapy right
now
that's exactly what's about to happen
here though like he's uh you're gonna
play this boy out for a long time you
can't get the pawn back and maybe Ricky
one after that you won but uh this might
be positive B takes C3 James it might be
but also as we were mentioning that Rook
on D7 and that Bishop on B3 F7 is a weak
spot so white still has the trumps gives
back that E4 Pawn but the point is that
how are you going to defend this you
can't move that Rook from f8 to E8
because F7 Falls if you bring the other
Rook to E8 that's super passive white
can start targeting the queen side now
moves like Rook D6 come to mind you
simply go after the A6 pawn and with all
these ideas it's going to be super
difficult for black to keep all the
pawns under control so rookie 4 is
coming up next I still think it's an
uphill task for vaishali to defend it I
think she makes a really good choice she
wants to get rid of that strong Bishop
Knights versus Bishops while in this
case the Knight wants to trade the
bishop yeah this is actually really uh
draw like I think I think Vishal is
playing really good even being down upon
the Knight takes B3 being in the next
move here and just obviously uh let me
get the pawn back so cool good stuff
that one it looks like it might be
headed to a job but the other games are
far from it James look at that top right
board that pawn structure that you've
engine has looks super nice for black
but it has created a lot of weaknesses
on the light squares that is going to be
an interesting fight it's level material
but it's far for being a level game we
see Louis ping is back with the
advantage on his iPad on that bottom
right board James and once again it
comes down to the pawn structure two
double pawns for pranesh one on the king
side one on the queen side white with
the control of the open C line the only
open file in the game all the Strategic
advantages are with Lou yiping meanwhile
on the top left board the big battle The
Clash of away against pragnananda James
this one to me it looks level although I
see the eval bar prefers White's
position where do you want to jump to
great question in fact let's actually go
to I'm looking for some action here and
it looks like they all look you know
what I'm actually surprised at how solid
everything is I actually thought it
would be more like Risk taking
especially from the yogis here because
you you have to win like you have to win
and which may require some time taking
some risk but here everything seems
extremely solid on every board let's
take a look at Prague let's go there we
haven't been there in a minute there so
we'll go check that game out probably
and it feels like there's some chances
and in fact that's who I am up a pawn
Prague is prags up a pawn and a clay
okay like on doesn't say games over
obviously but you do have a pawn and if
we can make some trades and obviously
you know put some pressure on our
opponent maybe even take one another
Pawn things could be different you know
especially as time gets lower things
happen so white is up a pawn I am always
a fan of being up a little bit of
material so let's see what happens
hmm I'm surprised to hear that James I
thought you were a man for the
initiative you loved the attack who
cares about material success think later
but James I also I also like what where
he's doing this is the minority attack
in chess he is down upon but his aim is
that that two verses three against the
queen side he wants to break with B4 if
he's given the opportunity which is
exactly what Prague stops with that last
move Rook to E4 a move like before the
minority attack would open up that
Bishop on G7 the C3 B2 wall that is
stopping the activity you want to get
rid of that so that is a threat that
white needs to watch out for but rookie
for make sure that that didn't happen
and rookie 4 Queen F5 here I mean I can
just I have simple moves very easy chess
simple chess right simple chest work 80
E1 sometimes I mean I had to work on
that myself in fact because I just love
aggressive chess but simple chest right
Rook a to E1 is going to set you up for
more tactics later you may be able to
even there it is Rook a to E1 it doesn't
even do anything it just gets another
piece into the game improving the
position is what we call it how do you
improve by usually moving pieces or
pawns to better squares than what they
on before improving improving sometimes
is difficult to understand so Rook 80e1
it just improves the position we double
the Rooks not even threading anything
but just the fact that we double the
Rooks here gives us a more of an
advantage now we are up upon still
Knight D4 and if we do have a trade at
some point we may be able to run the
pawn it is isolated but you have some
problems too as well White's definitely
for choice in this position
James huge up wow I was just gonna give
you a huge update that where Charlie and
Julie have in fact drawn their game and
I think for vaishali that's a great
result with the black pieces stopping
the Unstoppable juhi and with that jaw
now it means that the tigers are one
point away from being into the finals
and look at what way he has done on the
top board we were talking about the
attack we were talking about B4 and this
looks like a pawn sacrifice he gives B4
and the more I look at it the more I
understand because after C takes before
I think he simply wants to pick up the
B2 Pawn immediately so in fact you just
end up trading and what's the end
purpose of a minority attack is that the
side with the extra Pawn is left with a
weakness so we see this being played out
and now in the live board if the A5 Pawn
is picked up black will pick it up with
the queen and the A2 Pawn becomes a
Target in the position so B4 really
nicely timed there bye bye let's take
this moment James to just zoom out into
our bird's eye view because for the
yogis they need to find a way to to
score two and a half points in these on
these three boards where do you see that
happening
ronak with an advantage yes tough that's
tough yeah let's maybe move over there
to the run-up game because that's tough
to find two and a half out of these
three games that's gonna be very
difficult which is what I'm saying is
more solid as an approach which is nice
for a style and as a team but I mean for
this round it may have been necessary to
take a few risks in a certain a few
games maybe
um or where where is available here but
it's very difficult to uh say where
we're gonna get these points from for
the yogis
all right but this board is looking good
for the yogis and Rana finding his farm
in this one against Vengeance the idea
is clear right with white you want to
push that pawn to G4 you want to start
advancing these Central Pawn meanwhile
what White's King and Knight have done
is make sure that the B4 C5 D4 Pawn
structure it's got no movement they've
been perfectly blocked by White's pieces
so all the mobility in Pawn structure
lies with white you want to start
pushing those King side pawns and that's
what I'm expecting the only thing you
need to calculate James is that after G4
the trades happen black will perhaps
trade the rook and then take control of
the H file looking for a counter play
and that's what you need to time well
that if black does get the Rook to h8 it
could mean trouble which is why ronak
doesn't Rush with G4 he's controlling
the position completely plays the movie
five A5 is really strong too as well
because the king is now going to be able
to walk to the center of the board we
can play G4 and F5 as well this is like
I mean I think I mentioned this
yesterday actually we're doing
commentary about this King activity it's
very important to have that King
activity like lots of times even if I'm
down a pawn as white having this King
activity is actually really strong and
it's better than almost anything else
even material sometimes
really nicely pointed out there James
and I don't know if you have a little
bit of time to actually pull out that
analysis board because I really want to
show the resources that we were talking
about instead of E5 had to move G4
happen in this moment where we are
getting moves in King E6 G4 the problem
is that black white takes and we see
that eval bar still gives some Advantage
but why give this counter play to your
opponent Now The Rook slides to itching
and there are these problems that you
can start thinking about so definitely
like ronic's approach of keeping
everything under control he goes for E5
and after the king moved to E6 he
advances his own King to E4 taking
opposition and rookie that's a
preemptive move that's a preemptive move
that if you play G4 I have my Rook where
I wanted G4 on the board regardless
anyway yeah it takes takes that's
probably gonna be a rook f8 to stop F5
but you can't even do that wow and then
now I have this wait oh he's gonna I was
like why didn't he you control it yeah
he wants to play he's he's considering
which was better and five where Rook
takes which probably doesn't matter
James it's an important decision because
you end up keeping the H pawns alive
which could matter a lot you know the
more pawns on the board the better for
white
he would have allowed hg4 hg4 then one
more set of Pawns would have been traded
so this is a nice move and black
couldn't have taken on F5 that's why he
moved back with the King finally trades
on G4 so gets that final outcome that we
were talking about and now once again
you've got to take on F5 or do you keep
the pressure with G5 it's starting to
look very bad for wenjun absolutely of
course especially with uh King coming in
F6 I mean Rook check is it possible
everywhere at some point well Penny of
course uh because there is going to be a
check on this file here with E6 and I
even a B6 King in yeah this is I mean
look at this look at this guys this is
winning every single time F6 King F7
yeah so maybe you're okay
King F7 is E6 so you have to maybe think
about giving up that night already
he goes King d8 you can't push E6 now
because F6 is hanging so does he give
he could also just make the move I was
gonna say push that pawn to F7 but that
allows King E7 he starts with King C6
threatening a mate with Rook to A8
amazing idea very strong can you stop it
how do you stop this without giving
material that's true king C8 but this is
prolonging the inevitable
yeah King C8 you give a check on it you
give a check on D6 you give a mate on B8
's check you know a nice little check
you can give a check and white can just
get super greedy and grab the the queen
side bond with him
James this is exactly the result that
the yogis need from ronak he's going for
the kill he doesn't care about the pawns
he goes King B7 moved 97 rookie check
his game over that is how this will end
and I think vengeance is gonna throw in
the towel and resign at this point yeah
at some point yeah it's just definitely
getting very close to that want to play
on obviously as we go to boards bird's
eye view here let's see where do you
want to go whoa that prag game preg has
five seconds I don't know what's going
on the board but I just know he has five
seconds and I think that's a great idea
to go there so we see top right
score one point they need to keep that
those games under control and we see
Prague they're in a level position
playing on mere seconds Knight E5 and
James this is not easy for white it's
not just the seconds but that A3 A2 Pawn
structure on the queen side it is a lot
of pressure
absolutely I mean you have to like you
have to be precise against Wei and you
have to not flag I mean what a task that
Frank has here I mean it really is
difficult to another level here I mean
it's very understandable If he if he
blunders in the next few moves here he
has no time when Wei Yi has literally
like almost a minute more which okay now
he's under a minute now two second
increment it's not a lot of time so
there are some now okay I'm feeling
better if I'm proud here like you're
under a minute I could try to make some
moves here I have to survive he goes
King F7 and Rook F1 is always in the air
Rook F1 would actually just pick up the
F2 Pawn I don't see a way for white to
actually defend that pawn it's on the
board now Prague plays Knight D4 alright
that's a move that does still keep
things under control you block the
bishop Rook before coming in Rook B2
coming in before yeah
Rigby too
take take yeah I'm queening that's it
wow you have the mood King back yeah he
does
he does
and how do you want to trade do you want
to trade and start advancing with the
King that is a big decision and where he
needs to take it in seconds does he go
into a king and minor piece ending I
think he can also afford to just keep
the pressure all the rookie seven is a
threat on the board absolutely rookie
seven threat okay moves back moves back
no check
Ninja
Five yeah
yeah you kind of see coming now he has
no time he's living off four seconds
here James it all comes down to this
Rana sadwani has won his
on the other two boards it is all this
it's all that matters Tigers need to
hold this all where he needs to do is
draw this game to go into the finals wow
oh just don't lose this download easier
said than done six seconds to hit the
same amount of time here Bishop versus
knight Tanya what's gonna happen
this this just looks better or for black
right now with the King advancing all
these weaknesses on the board Prague
needs a miracle to win this one but the
knights can be super tricky James it's
not over till it's over Prague knows
that he has to just keep playing it
doesn't matter what happens he can't
give up the good news for Prague is that
all his pawns are on the lights quest
which means Way's Bishop cannot attack
them the Knight needs to find its way to
get active Knight is going to F5 he'll
pick up the 86 Pawn but Waze King is
super fast
yeah he gets two pawns there ah that
might be it well it might be a draw but
then that the Tigers advance
looks like a draw thing
Anything Can Happen Knights are
extremely tricky we do know this nice
are so tricky obviously
is a bishop where you would have to
blunder a bishop to lose this game James
yeah there's no way around it Endeavor
recipes in-game manual says that the
Knight needs to be somewhere else in
fact it's too far away yeah ec6 okay
wait a second he's still got some play
oh that's a lovely move he just stops
the night from returning into play he's
gonna trap the night oh my God G6 wins
the night Knight 886 was the only move
he plays King G5 and next king G6 would
win the night yeah that is it program on
the resigns and with that Wei has done
it the Shanghai Tigers move on to the
finals the Indian yogis are knocked out
what a mess the Tigers move on the
tigers are not extinct at least not
these ones says the Shanghai Tigers very
strong stuff they made it they took down
the Indian yogis the yogis are you
kidding me the Indian yogis right that
is very very very strong performance the
tigers are forced to be recommended for
sure
insane
Shanghai Tigers took this match 9-7
James they started with a four feet in
the first game unable to connect on that
first board Lou yiping there had such a
tough start he managed to recover won
some important points but it's clear
that it was Yu Yi who was the MVP for
the Tigers today three and a half out of
four he said I trust the team I'll take
a draw in the last round probably me
looking at the game two as well like it
was just draw like but yeah hey I'll
take it I'll take it three and a half
out of four had the game of the year I
can't be mad we're moving to the finals
as the Tigers here I am not mad at all
Julie MVP for sure especially today
oh my gosh and there it is the Tigers
the team to have made it the first India
made it to the finals and now the big
question James will be who will they
face in the protest League 2023 season
final will it be the Gotham nights or
will it be the MGD one team meanwhile
Indian yogis have been knocked down to a
third place fight this has been a
magnificent day of Chess James
this has been great guys we still have
another match who's going who is it
gonna be the knights or in or MDG mgd1
who do you think Chad was on you of
course right we need that energy we want
to know it's going to be so exciting we
saw an epic match today we saw a game of
the year we saw all kind of things just
connections on and off the board energy
everywhere great fist pumps you saw the
hikeness from juhi you saw the games
there it was pretty tough Indian yogis
were not able to take it today but still
a very very strong team as tigers are
going to the finals Tanya is crazy
amazing stuff in chat James you and I we
were all here witnessing one of the best
matches of the protest league but the
action doesn't stop as the fight goes on
with the MGD one the other the second
Indian team with Arjun in the front
taking on Hikaru Nakamura LED got a
knight to have been Unstoppable can the
MGD one stop them there's big action
coming up with Robert and Dani chat stay
on we'll be back with the protest League
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to the second semi-finals matchup in
this 2023 protest League playoff season
alongside me Danny wrench Grand Master
Robert Hess with the best is what we are
this weekend Robert are you ready
oh I am certainly ready if semi-final
one was any indication we are in for an
epic match here in the second semifinal
of the day on that note let's quickly
take a look at our bracket where yes in
thrilling fashion the Shanghai Tigers
take the spot in the final match of
course the India yogis will have a third
place match against the loser of the
match on the right side the Gotham
Knights and mdg-1 are the call that
Robert and I are about to have and just
like that we take a look at the lineups
the boards they brought to the table I
think the biggest storyline here Robert
is these are the same two teams that got
them into the semis just a couple days
ago
yeah no these are the same exact lineups
and they're super strong and I think the
thing we must note is that board four
well the Gotham Knights Hikaru Nakamura
ferrosev and probably volcanum all have
a slight Edge in the top three but board
four Eureka's 400 points higher than her
opponent
yeah I think that's that's gonna be a
huge storyline because if the knights
don't have a lead heading into that
round four that is a matchup that is a
mismatch and there's no other way around
it with John avali being such a favorite
over normanova so all right let's talk
about the board pairings because
speaking of harika dronavali before she
gets to that last round where she will
be the favorite against normanova she's
got the big dog right there at the top
Hikaru Nakamura she does get the white
pieces we're probably going to start
focused on that matchup right there
Robert yeah it makes sense I mean you
look at these mismatches let's call them
in the opening round of actions board
one versus Board four and when I look at
these messages I assume that board one
wins most of the time but the middle two
that's what it comes down to Danny can
aboard three take down on board two for
the opposition can you get one half out
of two for one side that'll give you the
upper hand
yeah and those board two versus Board
three matchups are are nothing to turn
away from you've got the Beast adibon
bhaskaran taking on vakidov who in many
ways was the star for the knights on
Thursday right Hikaru struggled on that
day finished with four draws but kedoff
was a big part of helping the knights
punch their ticket and proving that
Knights are better than Bishops and then
you have the big fish fetal say have
taken on gauche there uh and uh I I
don't know who I have favored in those I
think I'd lean the Knights Way in both
the board two versus Board three
matchups but your thought Robert no I
have to agree with you there I just
think the knights have such a powerful
punch on those two boards and hikara did
not show his best stuff on Thursday he
drew four games if Alice Lee Drew
against akaro that means that harika
maybe she feels she can do the same
well let's take a quick look again at
Hikaru and the Gotham Knights their
entire their entire uh Team obviously
you can see it before your eyes and then
the four players highlighted at the top
are their lineup as we put it out these
were the four players that sent Fabiano
caruana and the St Louis archbishop's
home the same lineup is throwing down
today but as you said Robert uh alua
normanova very much the underdog even
more so than she was against Alice Lee
yeah now she is going to have tough task
ahead but I you know know that over the
board in Rapid chess she did quite well
when the Kazakhstan took on the rest of
the world so she's had some good
successes she can't take down high rated
opposition but look at team mgd1 they
are strong from board one through board
four it's going to be a really long day
for her
yeah all right well it's fun to see you
know the uh the yogis and the Tigers had
slightly different lineups than they did
uh when it when it comes to comparing
the teams that played in the
quarterfinals to get them to the semis
but uh the the knights and mgd1 are
bringing the exact same players and
we'll see we'll see if that pays off
maybe a little bit of experience right
you've worked out some of your nerves
that you had when the playoffs started
Robert I wonder if that that might help
both teams play their best chess as we
kick things off yeah we don't expect to
see Hikaru Nakamura draw four games
again he had not drawn a single game all
pro chess League season so it was an
aberration it was an abnormality but
what we know from Hikaru what we see
from him time and time again is winning
chess
I thought you were going to say what we
see from him time and time again is a
pineapple neon light in the background
because that's what we see from hikar
time and time again along with that U.S
championship ring on his finger right
there so uh yeah no that's the streaming
setup you know and love it well hey Kara
Nakamura is eagerly waiting for a chess
board to explode on here he wants these
games to start you can tell that he's uh
that he's poised and uh and yeah well
just like that we are rolling in harika
dronavali at her seat Hikaru Nakamura as
well the scoreboard flies in everyone
working super hard welcome to the
weekend we've got a bunch of star boys
here including Robert Hess take it away
well I can feel my face even though I am
with you Danny and I love it but we're
looking at this matchup where Hikaru I
mean is he streaming right now he's
yawning that's for sure but he needs to
focus I know that some players they do
play better while streaming but he
cannot have a repeat of Thursday Danny
that's unacceptable for this team he
needs to score more than two points that
is a given
I think that's the that's the biggest
thing right it's not to say that the
other players on the team don't matter
just as much as Hikaru everyone's score
counts uh counts toward the total but I
think for sure Hikaru would say the same
thing right he wants to have his
absolute best chess uh to kick things
off for the knights and here we see a a
Scandinavian on the board
um regardless of the move order that got
us there we see a knight C3 Knight F6
kind of decline Scandinavian take that
John Bartholomew
well you're always poking fun at John
this is the second show in a row where
his name has come up and he does like
cramped positions and black as you can
see in the top left lacks space where
white pushes all the pawns forward
yeah and it's a it's a big it's a big
Center a lot of space with the pawns on
the dark squares but it's it's one of
those awkward centers too because it
blocks your own dark squared Bishop
black is going to go for one of these
grips on the light squares with E6 and
G6 and you just you try to say look I
know I'm a little worse with black and
the eval Bar says so but I'm going to
shut down the studio and you're gonna
have a hard time breaking through
yeah it's not the easiest position to
play for either side but Hikaru he's
choosing these aggressive kind of
questionable openings because he wants
to win we saw video Gujarati do that
with success yesterday he yeah was on
the verge of losing it seemed at points
but he in fact won his board one versus
board for match of it well there's a
knight on the side of the board here
Danny attacking this bishop 105. Knights
In The Rim typically seen as dim but if
Vikings start throwing all the pawns for
it oh it's gonna work
I I like that you pointed out obviously
the fundamentals always matter kids
don't overlook them but the night on the
rim here shows that herika Robert is
ready to play right she didn't go
against hikaru's kind of dubious opening
and say I'm gonna passively develop
she's like no if you're gonna you're
gonna do this like let's go right Knight
H4 I'm gonna get rid of that light
Square Bishop I'm gonna punch through F5
and maybe break open the king side
before you get the king out of the
center yeah but she had backed that pony
up after the E6 if that Knight was under
attack with check which is why I came
back to F3 and the evil bar suddenly
saying that Hikaru maybe decide for
choice I won't be surprised if slash
when and now is the answer to when he
plays C5 Knight C6 to follow Danny you
say this often right the Knight goes
behind a pawn while attacking the center
but let if if it's okay can we can we
back up quickly and just see what was
better besides Knight F3 because there
had to be
a move there for harika why not just
play G3 I guess to support it after
Bishop G4 I I don't know
if that was the idea perhaps I'm wrong
maybe this is already trickier than I
realized and that's why Hikaru uh makes
a lot of these openings work for him
well it looks like Bishop E2 was
actually the mistake so maybe just Queen
up to D3 something like that was better
it's an odd move to play putting your
queen in front of your Bishop but we see
that the the position is just messy and
as we get back to the live position it's
getting Messier it looks like a French
defense gone completely wrong for whites
what where's that Bishop it's outside of
its Pawn chain I was gonna say this is
like a bunch of people waking up who
play the French and they're like how
does Hikaru do it that's not legal the
bishop is gone for those who don't who
don't speak French uh both the language
or the uh the opening that everyone
knows I'm not a huge fan of the uh the
bishop is normally the Achilles heel for
black right black gets this super strong
Pawn chain F7 E6 and D5 black gets the
space on the queen side but all of that
is supposed to come in exchange for a
blocked Bishop but not not so much for
Hikaru apparently no and actually hikara
can bring his Knight up to C4 attacking
Bishop attacking Pawn there's already
danger in the center for harika she's
you see minus 1.8 Hikaru knows that he
is on the verge of winning this game he
just needs to be careful because I think
a lot of players would be tempted to go
Knight C4 and take this B2 Pawn but
there could be a situation where this
queen slides over to B1 and let's not
forget that Black's King is in the
center so if you start giving up your
queen side that can backfire I don't
think he'll take on B2 unless he sees a
tactic that pans out for him no he ain't
said takes on D4 that seems much more
practical
yeah and he might just eliminate uh
White's dark Square Bishop even though
the uh the Knight is good there but if
you put a rook on C8 you threaten to
take D4 the bishop is coming to C5 it's
it's almost impossible for white to play
B3 without other problems occurring on
the C file starting with that tender
Knight so that Knight on C4 doesn't need
to be in a hurry to take B2 this is this
is the start Hikaru Nakamura was looking
for and with all due respect to MGD won
the start that they did not want to see
it might mean Hikaru has corrected his
form that may not have been on cue on
Thursday and he's ready to play today he
is but you know in this position he
needs to be careful because look at this
Denny just note in the long term
presence of obstacle Bishops that means
some end games if we get that far could
have some equalish Tendencies but also
for an attack the white king looks very
safe on G1 where exactly is that black
king gong if you go Queen side I don't
think so I just pushed my palm to B4 and
Castle kingside excuse me your Pawn H5
that should probably be back on H7 so I
just want to note that clearly is in the
driver's seat he has some things he
needs to work out
yeah Fair all right well speaking of
things we need to work out it's time for
us to check out the other three games in
progress we head back to our bird's eye
view remind everybody that you are on
the right corner is not just for show
you can check it out the games are on a
slight delay uh due to fair play
concerns as usual but so is this
broadcast and you didn't even know it
that's the magic of Hollywood boys and
girls Robert where do you want to go
next well I'm just going to look across
the boards in the top right we see a
dipped on Ghost with the yps against
Federal save that's two early stages for
me so I'm going to take us to the bottom
left because she didn't was the hero for
the knights in the match on Thursday in
the quarterfinals he gets the white
piece against the beast in adivan
baskaran but Denny if we dive into this
position uh isn't black playing some
kind of modern where the pieces are all
over the place white should be better in
some of these lines but you see the eval
bar saying Black's doing A-Okay and this
E5 Pawn can stick out like a sore thumb
yeah and and if if blackhead makes sure
E6 doesn't happen right that's the move
I tactically go to right away you look
at E6 you also look at moves like I mean
even Bishop takes F7 with Knight G5
coming right there's all kinds of
threats on the table which is why uh
adibon is being careful those are
tactics he'd love to play himself being
the the the very aggressive uh feisty
player he is so double checking things
because if you play E6 Robert we can
highlight that yes that makes the pawn
on E5 stay stay put and kills those
tactics but now you've got long-term
dark Square problems right and you got
to worry about that so there's there's
some trade-offs here that he's double
checking that's why we see him with
thinkers pose number nine the head in
double fingers he didn't go full Birdman
where you clasp him at the top some say
that harnesses the energy better but
we'll take it
well he went full Rodan he is the
Thinker right now and well you couldn't
sculpt I think a better looking position
for white I love the look of this look
at these pieces on very natural squares
Black's night on G4 at some point you
can even play H3 to boot that pony back
over there to H6 so there must be
something in this position tactically
speaking that allows black to stay afoot
I wouldn't be surprised if there's some
kind of Bishop F5 and like a knight D4
to get that Queen activated sometimes
you need tactical measures to solve some
positional issues and that is what's
coming to mind but he castles and you
see the eval bar go all the way up and
Danny you were mentioning E6 dude that
looks like a possibility as well it's
gotta be it's Gotta Be E6 I mean if we
want to bring up the analysis board to
check it out the only thing you're
spying of course is that ninja Bishop on
G7 hitting the B2 Pawn with some x-ray
goggles but I'm gonna guess that E6 can
be played anyway I just got a feeling
that that's the idea maybe I'm wrong
let's see if the B2 is classic okay so
show everybody why I was wrong Bishop
takes B2 and the point is there isn't
enough there isn't enough here The Rook
actually is a problem so what is the
move then that adibon and myself missed
you know it happens to the best of us
very strong chess players well Knight C3
played in B5 quickly from Audible and
maybe it was just simple chest that
black has long-term issues this Knight
is going to be offside hunched or pushed
back I should say to H6 at the right
moment and I've been doing the right
thing he is trying his very best to
create some chaos to say to White your
pieces aren't going to be on harmonious
squares but this King can Castle
queenside this Knight can slide into C5
I just think that the long-term
positional Avengers are when White's
favor as well so adibon we know how
creative he is he is going to have to
find all of that creativity and more to
stay in this game
and we see vaquita sitting up there I
still don't know exactly uh what vaquita
looks like because he was born of the
darkness and he stays there Batman
um he lives in the darkness that light
is uh is interesting um any Hooters
we've got castles along with the Rook
coming to D1 the night on C5 I love that
you highlighted that the Knight on G4
it's just the thing is this you could
play H3 you could also just leave it
there right it's tender while it's there
there's always potential tactics that
then I don't have three can move with
the discovery and again if that pawn on
E5 stays put everybody white has
long-term attacking chances because
opponent E5 means no 9 on F6 which means
by definition the king lacks minor peace
defense if you can coordinate a knight
G5 okay he goes for H3 not a bad idea
maybe E6 is even following there's so
many potential tactics here this looks
very dangerous for for audibon but you
made a good point that H3 it wasn't
completely necessary and it's a
time-consuming move look what just
happened it should be five you're not
casting kingside and guess what you're
not casting Queen side either you can't
Castle through check this Knight on A4
is also almost trapped we're talking
about the Knight on G4 the Knight on A4
that could be targeted as well so all of
a sudden Black's pieces have come to
life in a way that is not easy for white
to deal with where is this queen even
going at the moment if you go up to E4
it could be Bishop C6 take F3 give me
your E5 Pawn at the right moment yeah
you're gonna do it though because A5 is
hanging I was looking at a funny line
where queen queen takes B4 Bishop takes
F3 I can take G4 first in both the
Knight and the bishop are Under Fire you
do have Knight C6 but what a weird world
oh and Knight takes B3 okay yeah yeah
but yeah but you're right like all of a
sudden they're gonna be a million
captures and who's calculating better I
actually think adibun is the upper hand
here I don't like this King in the
center I don't like the threaded Bishop
takes F3 and this Knight as we're
talking about can get get rid of itself
by taking this bishop on B3 and it feels
like the game is just going in black
circle by the way it should be five we
could see a draw
it's amazing of one tempo we were just
highlighting that H3 wasn't necessary
and then white does it I the more I look
at the position why in the world did he
not just play Rook D1 or castles long
both those moves felt so much more
natural than the unnecessary H3 clearly
he missed something about this bishop B5
Tempo adibon wants more man he doesn't
wanna he doesn't want to repeat yeah but
sometimes wanting more means you're
gonna get less because Pawn takes F3 the
oh is there Queen D4 I mentioned that
idea earlier and this bishop and this
Pawn are all under attack this is
getting really wild he quickly brings
that back to H6 but but didn't white has
bad pawns on the f file and the E5 Pawn
can be a Target as well but black has
this a pawn that's weak the B4 Pawn also
sticks out so both sides have their
pluses
it's interesting I start looking at
lines Robert like Rook D1 Queen C8 I
can't Castle short because H3 but I can
take H6 and play like King F1 King G2
and with my knight coming in like who's
better in that transition I I kind of
feel like white has the upper hand there
such an essential question what peace
trades are acceptable what peace trades
are advisable Bishop takes H6 at some
moment as Danny as you're mentioning
here it's something to consider I don't
like the queen trade because this pawn
and these pawns are going to be worse
without queens of the board look at
Black's activity finally this Knight
hops were sent or watch out night on the
rim can actually be grim and Grim for
white because the F3 Pawn is targeted
yeah okay
I I'm with you on on Queen D2 not being
ideal um because here comes that Knight
but let's let's also back this thing up
and check in with the other games
because speaking of not ideal as we look
at the bird's eye view you can see
Hikaru Nakamura has put a ricadron of
ali uh in a not ideal position to start
things off Hikaru has uh has shown up he
is ready to roll no draws to start uh
his uh his campaign here in the semis I
don't even know that we need to check in
on that there's probably other games
that are more worthy of our of our
attention Robert
um I could head over to gauchevinosev if
you're into that
um but but you're in charge all right
let's do it no no yeah I'm super into it
his car is he's completely winning I
always see him up uh some past Pawns in
the center and opposite colored Bishops
don't mean to draw on the end game
especially when black is pastors that
are running so let's go to dipty and
gauche against Vladimir ferrosev because
Danny we have a material imbalance here
I had to do a quick count but white has
two Rooks black has one that was the
easy part but white is down in Pawn so
black has in this position a knight and
a pawn for a rook and look at the
activity of these pieces a knight is
going to hop into the D3 square if
you're not looking out for it but said
he takes on D5 with the bishop because
there are too many tactics in the
position with his Queen on A8 so what do
you make of this Danny would you prefer
to have the Rook or the minor piece and
Pawn
it's funny because the engine likes
white but I'm kind of liking photos save
I I like the minor piece and pawn here I
think it's a little awkward because in
this position when that Bishop on G2 is
traded it's not one of those vegan
candle positions Robert where let's say
you still have a Pawn on E2 and the
light scores are kind of okay I think
there's real potential that those light
scores get tender right I see you nod
your head of approval you know that
makes this lonely International Master
feel so good would you give me that GM
not hi Robert
hey buddy I'm actually completely with
you because I asked you the question to
build confidence in myself I was like I
actually like Black's position it's one
of these situations where if white isn't
accurate a queen trade for example of
course is going to be good for white but
Knight takes F4 is on tap Knight takes
A2 is also hanging don't forget about
the lonely Rook pawn it is hanging and
it can be captured so I'm looking at
this position and I'm not seeing the
easiest opportunity for white Bishop D2
well thank you my knight hops into D3
and B2 is loose and you see the eval bar
immediately after Bishop says black is
doing not just fine but maybe even
better and queen C4 comes to mind as
well yep
this is one of those funny positions
where again obviously there was a best
computer move there but Robert and I
both with no engine lines in front of us
both openly questioned the eval bar
which I think can be instructed for the
viewers because you look at the
compensation and maybe if you find the
one top line over and over again you can
handle Black's compensation here but you
looked at the clock right gosh was
getting down right you looked at the
pressure for black and you just had a
feeling this was going to be much
trickier for white even now if the
Queens come off in A2 Falls I don't
think black loses this game like maybe
it's you know with if everything on the
queen side gets eliminated you've got
four versus three so again I I like
Federal saves chances I think he will
keep the Queens on just seems like the
right practical thing to do but um in
general I think it's instructive to see
where compensation lies yeah I actually
think this was a brilliant response
though by the time ghost Queen D4 you're
threatening G7 and the queen is what
we're talking about the queen trade is
what white wants and if you take on A2
at the end after a swap of Queens Knight
takes a two there's Rook A1 chops A7 and
that's why he slides the queen back
watch out Knight C2 G7 is hanging but
black has some tactics of his own A2 is
also loose a couple of times Knight C6
Danny balls this is really complicated
you shut your mouth when you're talking
about Forks to me don't you use that f
word fourth town on C2 watch out I like
it double Forks double problems I
obviously Knight C2 would be preferred
if it's allowed but even Knight C6
getting rid of that dark sport Bishop
Robert I put my Bishop on F6 oh I feel
good even down the exchange Black's
doing okay no I think just from uh
looking at the time looking at how this
position develops I do think that
Federal save has good chances but let's
not count go shot either he is up in
exchange he's playing confidently he's
playing well so we'll see how this one
continues but maybe we should hop on to
another game what do you think
let's do it let's do it let's do it we
head back to the bird's eye view the
board 4 versus Board One matchup we've
talked a lot about Hikaru getting the
job done for the knights but similarly
Arjun irigaissey also with the black
pieces looks to be headed toward a
victory against alua normanova uh also
maybe not quite as clear as the result
we see on the board you can never be
quite as clear as a result that's in the
books but here are geissy doing well uh
do we want to peek at that or head back
to the kid off boscarron your call
by the way look in the top right of our
screens Pono G7 was captured and that
seems to be a mistake
all right back to to go Federal save I
know we just left it but hey that's
where the fire is Bishop takes G7 what
happens and why is Knight C2 not a move
that could have been played he went
Knight C6 which is the best move and
queen G4 the only way to stay contact
with the bishop is there F5 there's
Queen G6 after so H5 H5
where is Canty when you need him H5 and
we live and the queen cannot hold on to
defending the bishop you can move that
Bishop for discover check you know my
daughter just recently discovered just
over check at seven years old she's very
into discovered checks right now but
this would be a good lesson for her not
every discover check Works no this queen
is in a light Square so there's no way
to attack it and this queen is
distracted you take H5 black takes G7 we
have two minor pieces for rook and upon
extra material for black all of a sudden
and Denny we called it from as soon as
it happened we did feel like Black's
position was a little bit easier to play
there were some immediate threats at
taking on G7 taking a pawn in front of
your opponent's king that typically does
not backfire but here it does
yep no this is uh this is dangerous we
felt the pressure again yes best play
probably the exchange worked but that
was a position that humans many humans
do not handle that well and and uh I
think Federal save gets that Bishop you
look at the clock he doesn't have much
to worry about there I'm expecting two
victories for the top two boards of the
knights after this first round of play
yeah so this one looking really good for
FedEx but let's go back into our bird's
eye view because we we're gonna check on
some other games and I think there are
some critical things happening and good
news for team mtd1
yeah good news because bhaskaron has
flipped the script against vaquita a lot
of Victories for black looking like
they're in store riding car already won
fedo save on the prowl our Junior geisie
getting the job done and if boscarron
wins it's all black all day let's head
over to that lower left board and check
out the key to boscarun and what's so
important about this matchup is I know
adibani is bore two and vokido's board
three you think board two should be
higher rated they're about the same
rating they are quite evil evil even
excuse me they're quite evil I mean
they're quite even in strength so if I
could take this game with black that
would be huge for MGD one but Danny no
we just talked about how evil bar can be
misleading white is down two pawns here
two pawns but this doesn't look that
easy for black because this Knight on D3
holds everything together and White's
Rooks are very active yeah how do you
stop Rook dc5 here like just ask the
question the next move is Rook dc5 what
are you doing I'm winning at least one
Pawn back and who's better if I win the
C pawn and the C3 Pawn is passed you can
have your four on two on the king side I
know the H3 and F2 pawns look ugly but
end games with past pawns it tends to be
who Queens first not how many you have
I have an idea and I was about to say F6
Ed feingles has never play it but Knight
E5 is the threat distracting this Knight
on D3 away so you could take on B2 with
check Intermezzo and then blood keeps
the material Edge so I think F6 is a
great move inducing F4 should be
something that black wants because you
want pawns to be extended and now 95 for
sure interesting stuff there super
instructive to highlight that white
didn't want to play a four because it
the reason you want your pawns extended
when you have a majority of everybody is
it increases the time to trade and get a
pass pawn it it makes it faster right so
that was a really interesting thing for
white to avoid we are in a rook ending
now where I think White's okay so
um I mean
I feel like vaquito can hold this E5 is
weak C7 is weak I know Rook f8's a move
but I'm liking but keto's chances for a
peaceful result here
yeah Rook Cafe is a really good idea I
think you're playing to win you make
that move but I'm with you that black
especially after king of seven seems
like is not much better so you're right
it looks like the trouble is not over
but it feels diminished so why don't we
hop on over to the games you know
there's still two others let's go back
to our bird's eye view here Danny
because the action does not stop in the
protest League Eric icy is uh is is
still rolling look at those two pass
pawns I mean we should probably check in
on it just to make sure we got all all
of our eight players on camera at some
point in the first round let's quickly
take a look at Norma Nova irigaisi also
it's a beautiful position when you've
got two past pawns marching up the board
like that I mean hey Halo
and white has passed Pawn but
unfortunately Checkmate wins the game
and E2 E1 check makes this King on G1
the Knight on G4 takes away any Escape
squares it's just forcing you could take
on D2 but then you're down a full Rook
yeah
two pawns on the second rank
that's how you start your day right
crab cakes and football that's what
Maryland does
two pass pawns and uh and queens Queens
coming to the board that's what you're a
guy see does although now you got to
deal with the a pawn and those peskinets
okay that's nice queen of five a double
attack although that's a simple way
simple way to get the job done too just
threaten Checkmate on the first rank you
know I'd like to say when you see
Checkmate look for better he says no
Checkmate ends this game so Queen E1 you
have to be careful though because do you
really want to trade Queens I don't
think so there are some Knight C7 ideas
so you have to be just on top of things
I guess the Knight can't move because
the bishop D4 check but there's a little
bit to work out for Arjun he is going to
win this game yeah it's funny I think
Queen E4 probably feels the best because
you guardiate and we threatened Bishop
D4 that was my idea and once you get
Bishop D4 things do full I know when it
walks into the fork town on D6 but I I
guess I made the lazy assumption the
bishop D4 check would probably be enough
maybe I shouldn't do that I know it is
yeah yeah yeah you're correct the white
king is going to be checkmated as soon
as the white king gets pushed to the
corner then you play Queen E1 and
there's gonna be a background Checkmate
so this looks like Arjun has this one in
the bag and that's great news for mgd1
especially because oh wait I hold on it
could be wrong let's head back to the
bird's eye view I was about to say
especially because we think the kid off
is going to hold that position although
not so fast says the Beast known as
adibon bhaskaron again Eric is he's
going to get the dub looks like Fido
save follows suit so three victories for
the black pieces will it be four or will
we have peace let's head over there
baked off boss can run it's coming down
to that whether we're going to have a
tied match after four games or not
I'm looking the clock Danny and look at
the lead on time for ariban that's huge
and that might be the reason he wins
this game the Eva Bar says minus 1.5 and
you and I could translate computer terms
considering black is up one Pawn that
could actually be closer to a draw than
a win but we look at the Practical
elements White's pawns are all split
that's not fun a black can create a pass
Pawn at some point in an outside pass
spawn an H Pawn those are always really
dangerous and then the clock that plays
such an essential role as James Kennedy
likes to say a the clock is the 17th
piece yeah the 17th piece like the 11th
man
um or the 12th man sorry I forgot
um you know
um
that was an American football reference
for our International
um audience apologies it'll never happen
again all right
um we've got rookie five rookie one I
like this again you keep the king split
now you got to figure out how to make
progress
you like King E5 no no I'm wondering
okay you going all in King of five Rook
takes C6 King might as well analyze it I
don't think we're going anywhere else
Fisher uh not Fisher the big fish is
gonna get it done so I think we're gonna
be here
um you said Fisher I was like wait what
is happening now Bobby Fischer again is
Bobby Fisher no that was uh that was an
SNL skit R.I.P to the world champion
um okay
King D6
can white move like if you go over F7
you drop H4 if you go King F2 I'm
already sliding my Rook back this way so
he's looking forward you see the
evaluation bar it's kind of going up a
little bit every turn for black
yeah you're shuffling to hold but if
black can find some way to make King E3
King D3 untenable and again it would
make sense if somehow you just had your
King on E5 also hitting the Rook but
then white has rookie four check at any
time that occurs so I'm I'm with you
this looks good for black but I'm not
seeing the Breakthrough either you got
to give Akita of credit that he is he is
holding here
I'm wondering if at some point you
played G5 to Spring free this passer the
H Pawn could do some damage but you
don't want to give up the pawn for free
so that's one difficulty so volcano
playing this really well I think the
king is slide back well and every time
you try to get to the king side to play
your G5 idea white pokes at the C6 bonus
we saw the kid off too just now so
again I think audibon pushes this one
for a minute don't be surprised if we're
living off the increment I'm gonna make
a prediction this game doesn't end for
another three whole minutes
um that's that's sounds bold cotton but
I see that uh White number 15 seconds
he's playing on that increment so he
could make a mistake at any moment but
he's playing great defense right now
yeah agreed
playing great defense don't get too
impressive yeah because now rookie was
rookie
the King on D4 was misplaced yeah the
King on D4 is misses don't go King D4
this rookie one now
rookie one
because if rookie won Rook C6 you can
play King F7 I think you're still gonna
win the pawn
um
it's so difficult to assess You Gotta
Give the kid off credit though he's just
holding the fort despite living off the
increment
Danny E5 though you can't play King E4
because Rook F4 check and this king gets
up to D5 I just feel like black is
making some progress there
he goes for it
chat says audibon's slowly gonna grind
this we got some people rooting for MDG
one let us know who you're cheering for
the knights
or MDG one
I I would go for this you get a pass
Pawn that is what adibon has been
lacking in this end game if he just can
take on C4 you have a seat Pawn this
pass and whites loyalties are split and
that was apparently a mistake maybe some
of them F oh what a move if Rook takes
it takes E5 and white wins oh my gosh
what a move King E4 now when The Rook
slides over and white white can win this
dude what a turn around look at butkidov
is like he's like what he's like like
I'm I'm broken up here like what's going
on here comes dude it's not about oh my
goodness it's not about Punk it's about
quality here comes the epon such a good
lesson because the H4 Pawn is worth both
the H5 and G6 Plus on that side of the
board that's why backward pawns are bad
white is wait white blue oh no
wait I I don't know what's happening
with the Evo it's scary no one knows
least of all the email bar
high blood pressure oh wait is the does
the black can get back and draw up with
a corner pond
no way no it's too far
I told you that you spring this Pawn
free
oh because it comes with Tempo H2 comes
to the tempo that's how it holds gosh
and both sides Queen at the same time
that was the drama we were looking for
Welcome to the pro chess League playoffs
boys and girls we have a weekend ahead
this is nice
because
there was a discover check and now his
work is safe The Rook is not on a
checkable square so you get to promote
safe it lights up a queen or a vaquita
wipes off the sweat he might as well
brush off his shoulders while he's at it
get the job done son oh my gosh
King G6 squeegee three so don't play
Kingdom G6 you gotta go king of eight no
but then Queen d8 oh king of six was the
only winning move and he found it with
no time King F6 was the only move there
what geometry was that
this is unbelievable he can run it run
anywhere now now he's got it
that was the most ridiculous game ever
that was so insane
how often is white down upon in a rook
ending starts playing for the win oh my
gosh
it's over Queen D5 Rook G5 resigns and
the and so he just he just gives him the
towel
oh man baked off Makita
brush your shoulder off young man you
are helping lead the Gotham Knights will
will this be looked back on as a game
that ultimately helped punch their
ticket to the finals he's a happy he's a
happy guy
and he's probably analyzing it but he
was jousting that's what Knights do and
he wins in the end Heath Ledger R.I.P it
was A Knight's Tale and the Knights are
up three to one what a great film by the
way knightsdale underrated made me want
to learn how to joust I'm not gonna lie
three to have won the Knights tank the
lead after the first round not what we
saw coming it was victories for black
besides on that keyboard with vakidov
taking down baskaran in a rook ending
a rook ending for the ages Robert but
this might end up being a match for the
ages if that is a sign of things to come
so don't go anywhere ladies and
gentlemen the weekend is here the pro
chess League playoffs are rolling on and
we will be right back
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiana carwana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James we're gonna see who recognizes
these guys out of the out of the random
passerbys and we're gonna ask them some
fun questions about Chess for five bucks
do you know who this is
no okay active an actor well you see
this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right it goes by
75. you want to play chess okay so what
is he a player or something or chess
he is a chess player I'm not but he is
yeah I play on the side yeah I've been
taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster Canty over here recently
over here calculation over everything
what's your name again sir my name is
Jamie what's your name
I already know it it's
Daniel yeah Daniel nerdinsky okay
there it is
on the attack baby on the attack if he
wins I know the guys at chess.com we'll
get him a diamond membership okay do you
know what that is yes okay is that
something you want yes yeah okay look at
you look is this a London yo we got a
pro here with the London London how'd it
go
okay one that's great hey good game all
right I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL just YouTube I
actually don't remember okay
look at the pot
thank you
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
whoa
Hikaru does it again it's like that's
how it's done and here we go
that was nasty
oh my gosh what a turnaround Levy super
team look at that trophy case this match
is over
it's official round three ends in a 4-0
victory I don't think anybody is even
remotely looking forward to the task of
facing the Gotham knights in the
playoffs
those are the knights you know them and
love them they are led by that guy right
there been led by him all season what an
impressive regular season he had by the
way uh Robert when you think of Hikaru
you think of how he just played in game
one you got to be nervous if you're MGD
won
you need to be nervous for many reasons
but Hikaru is the number one reason to
top that list he is so dangerous we see
him winning title Tuesday all the time
he's the world Fisher random Champion
he's won the speed Chess Championship
five times in a row rapid chest speed
chess classical chess doesn't matter
Fisher random variance Galore he wins
them so yeah I think we understand why
mgd1 must be nervous
it's funny because I think people
Overlook that he is the world Fisher
random Champion I know it's Fisher
random not traditional chess uh but
winning that event is not easy and what
a what a field he had to face so kind of
a funny thing we forget to talk about
sometimes but all right let's not forget
to talk about where we sit in terms of
the overall score in this match as we
set the table for round two they're down
3-1 if you're team mgd1 what is your
advice to them Robert how do you think
they start to turn things around well
they were an unfortunate break away from
tying that first round two to two but
the scoreboard tells the tale it's all
that matters at this point it doesn't
matter how it happened but I think mg1
shouldn't be two out of place they
shouldn't feel like things have gone
wrong they just need to do what Gotham
Knight said get a little bit luck on
their side and take this second match
two and a half one F just slow steps
they can catch up later
well let's take a look at the lineups
like you said a bad Breakaway uh from
maybe being tied to two so as we look at
the lineup now uh they might be a good
break away from getting a 3-1 score
right you look at Arjun ERA geisey with
the white pieces hoping he can write the
ship against the key dot that's a
matchup I have circled of course you see
Hikaru Nakamura versus gauche there and
obviously we're watching Hikaru all the
time at the top but your thoughts on
maybe the mashup to keep your eyes on
well vokidov has been an absolute star
for the Gotham Knight so I actually
think that's a great matchup to look at
against our generic geiste but I'll say
Federal save versus harika arika has
been so good throughout the entire Pro
chess League season she has upset many
stronger Grandmasters so she can take
down
thatosev we know how capable he is he
beats the best in the world the
Champions chest door but there are some
times where he gets a little bit too
adventurous
yeah it's true it's true and Eureka
obviously she just lost her first game
to Hikaru but it happens to a lot of
people so we'll see what she can do in
that matchup all right we are off to see
the wizard this is a weekend of pro
chess League playoff chess if you just
tuned in the first round was a thriller
you're going to want to back up and see
some of the clips of those games but we
are here in round two Knight F3 E3 from
Mr Nakamura his patented awkward B3
ready move order I don't even know what
to call it uh at this point in his
career Robert yeah but now he's spending
time so he plays C4 he doesn't go for
his B3 nimso Larson systems and he said
goes for C4 Knights they're more
standard stuff he can transpose this
right back to main line Queen spawns
games with D4 but this bishop is on C1
so that's one of the downsides of
playing this move order so it's more
likely that it'll go B3 and Bishop B2
since the pawn is already in its path
yeah I was just going to say that's one
of the reasons you you stay flexible in
the center is to right the wrong to that
dark squared Bishop you still have B3 on
the agenda you can maintain tension
although if black plays C5 sometimes
that can kind of force your hand a
little bit because at that point if D4
is coming exactly you highlight I speak
it this relationship is working for me I
am not gonna lie hey you're highlighting
all of the successful elements of our
relationship so thank you for that Danny
but you're right C5 is on the agenda C
takes D5 feels quite automatic or you
could play D4 but the point is you're
not allowing black to punch through with
D4 that gains too much space in the
center and then we'll get like a reverse
benoni structure if that were to happen
so now black is on the clock Danny some
slow movement from these two yeah in the
opening
it's interesting because I think people
are so worried about move orders against
Hikaru because he plays these systems so
often that you don't get the black side
of this as often Robert as hecaro gets
the white side right and a lot of people
know that so they're just double
checking I actually I respect the move
order he does end up going with this
sort of tart decal or queen side fee and
Kettle you see in a qgd but it's it's
not the most ideal place for the light
Square Bishop although as you can see
computer says black is fine here you've
got an orthodox structure you're going
to play Bishop D6 Knight bd7 get castled
and and we have a middle game although
what white does is a knight E5 Pawn F4
Castle Kingson go for an attack so I
think it's important for black not to
rush the development of this Knight on
B8 because if you play C5 and then get
Knight C6 in you put pressure on the D4
Point whereas a knight on D7 that
actually is misplaced because when this
Knight gets C5 upon that four C5 doesn't
actually carry the same threat there
actually is no threat there White's Pawn
base is too solid
that's nice I like that and again I
think that's a move order that uh gauche
is going to be careful and you see
Hikaru quickly played A3 even if the
engine said not the most accurate or
aggressive move Hikaru plays these
positions for the flexibility they give
right because at this point everyone
you're looking at micro opinions even by
the computer and what matters at this
level is less about the micro opinion
but the position being comfortable for
you to play a position where you're
familiar with the structural positional
ideas the tactics so that's what hicardo
does here he gets positions he knows
well and that's why that's why he can
play so fast but I don't really love
playing B4 that much I'm I'm with you
I'm kind of justifying the the fact that
Hikaru isn't playing the sharpest or
most accurate opening but he is playing
it quickly but I I like black spot here
no doubt yeah and I'm wondering if this
Knight is going to hop around into C4
once you push this Pawn to B5 you
control the square completely this is
carry a threat the Knight C4 just kind
of sits there and white can operate
around it but yeah this is a game where
what will happen in it is not based on
the first 13 moves it's what's going to
continue from here on out
all right well let's Zoom this thing out
as they get set for their middle game
and Peak at all four of the games in
action at once we often call it the
bird's eye view you can go to chess.com
events you're round by round reminder
that that's not just there to look good
it's a URL you can check out if you want
to choose your own adventure Robert you
choose where we're taking the next part
of this beautiful program
what I see some really interesting
openings in the bottom left between
Arjun Eric icy and Jefferson volkidov
and Argent both won their first game and
that I think we have to go there because
it's looking spicy and vokito's showing
no fear against his higher rated
opponent and Arjun he's saying I can
handle your immediate night jumps and
threats you've overextended on the king
side so Danny it's very double-edged
position and yeah I don't know who I
like it for but I'm gonna I'm not gonna
lie I'm gonna I'm gonna make you I'm
gonna make you very quickly bring up the
analysis board once we get this one
going because as someone who kind of
plays this system as black this is like
an awkward nimzo nimzo and rigos and had
a baby so let's as soon as we can let's
bring up the analysis board and back
this thing up through the opening and
show how we got here because a lot of
tactics happen the bishop on G3 can be
taken but if white gets a big Center and
black has extended those kingside pawns
show me show me how we got here sir if
you don't mind I'll show you the opening
I'll show you what we're working with
I'll back it up yeah and we see that
Bishop G5 oh I knew something was weird
I literally I kept saying show me how
you got it because I played musicians
I'm like but what what happened here go
ahead the bishop developed first and
then the Knight came to D2 this is very
unusual stuff normally the Knight is out
on C3 in these positions you don't
develop Bishop before the night but
Arjun he's coming up with tricks up his
sleeve C5 challenging the center why not
D5 your knight is pinned you can't go
and win the pawn if you are gonna win it
you have to play move a G5 but this is
risky you could take on D5 but you're
King it's in the center your king is not
really going to Castle this way with
your Pawn on G5 so I don't know the ins
and outs I'm just going along with the
players here this is novel to me but
Bishop goes to A5 he slides it back here
Danny and there is a nasty pin
and there's also weird Queen G5 ideas
coming there's H5 H4 coming this is this
is one of those traps that
okay obviously Arjun taking his taking
his time to kind of make sure he
navigates the tactics but uh I don't
know what to make of this this is a
position that is almost similar to a lot
of other traps you see as I said in
weird variations of the nimzo or the
rogozin but it is neither and don't be
surprised if somebody blunders in the
first 15 moves here and when you say
somebody I think white is going to win
this game and I feel like it's quite
High likelihood look at these pieces
they're not doing anything and white
even though it might cost a pawn has
developed both nights and yeah this King
on E8 I don't know where it's going this
H file is opened you mentioned how that
would be important here so I just look
at the clock I look at the position and
I don't like it for black but vokita he
says eval bar check oh zeros he doesn't
see that he doesn't know it but he has
assessed it properly that black is doing
objectively okay even though I really
like White's position I would sacrifice
two pawns to keep his King in the center
and make sure that it's not going to
safely Castle in either direction
I I don't disagree especially on a
practical Level Playing positions where
you've overextended your pawns your king
in the center we are still humans at the
end of the day not computers those are
positions everyone where people blunder
right Robert especially in Rapid chess
when you increase the dynamic problems
you face even if the computer is saying
equal eval weak pawns King in the center
those are not easy positions to play so
from a practical point of view I'm with
you although I will counter play Devil's
Advocate to both of our opinion I expect
we might see 95 here by the way for
white but okay that black has the bishop
pair Robert right and if I can catch up
in development you've got some dark
Square things long term to figure out as
well so if I can solve that problem
that's that's where the engine says they
can play this position as black but
but very dangerous it is thanks Yoda
you like this bishop the darksword
bishop in particular it can cause some
problems there are some pawns that can
be targeted later it's already on a nice
diagonal but I'm looking at some of
these dark squares in Black's position
and this Knight is already ready to hop
to a square like B5 you push this E Pawn
G4 is loose I just think that black has
way too much to deal with and if vokidov
can handle this the guy is just an
absolute star we already know that he
won an Olympic gold medal with Team
Uzbekistan he went three out of four on
Thursday but Danny this is looking
really sharp and Arjun aragysius his
opponent
it's funny the part of the reason I like
Knight E5 is because I thought the tempo
on G4 was important okay I thought black
might have played Queen F6 there instead
to hit the Knight get developed but this
also obviously makes sense I thought
Queen F6 first E3 then 9a6 but this also
looks okay and it's weird because
you look at the king you look at those
pawns but the kid off says scoreboard
scoreboard boys computer's all right
here black is all right all right let's
take that moment to back this thing up
once again and head on over to the
bird's eye view because there are three
other games in action to start this
round two if you just tuned in the
Gotham Knights took a 3-1 lead after
that first set of games concluded and uh
Robert
let's go to there you choose no hands
I'm driving I'm in shotgun here I'm like
I'm a back street driver judging your
directions like oh you're really gonna
turn that fast wait so you're going to
take that route
okay Dad will I see that in this in
these four boards in the top left Hikaru
Nakamura he's in good shape he has just
planted his Knight on C6 it's Paul
enough to B5 looking very nice for the
board number one for the Gotham Knights
but on the right side of our screen the
games that we haven't looked at I'm
looking at the top right game between
Federal save and harika jonavali some
dark Square control for harika white has
more Pawns in the center but black has
some control of key squares and the
bottom right that just looks early
stages to me where we're still just in
the opening phase
I'm with you let's let's head to Federal
save uh drawn a volley as you pointed
out of the of the two games we haven't
looked at it is moving a little further
along and after that move Rook C8
computer said milaikia white a little
more I didn't say it with that accent
but you know you get it
wow okay I haven't seen the new Super
Mario movie but I wasn't planning to you
know if you're looking for butchered
Italian accents look no further than
Chris Pratt what a what a bad movie that
was I'm sorry Super Mario not a fan of
what happened there well I don't think
that White's a fan of what's Happening
down the sea file because look at this
there's there are many pieces there and
I'm actually wondering if that last move
we can bring up an analysis board really
quickly I think Queen E7 played quickly
is there not some kind of B5 maybe I
guess I have to part with my Bishop
first but in this position don't I have
B5 and when your knight moves I grab
this E4 Pawn
I like it let's keep analyzing it so if
the okay so this line just already looks
clear but I can't take D6 because Knight
takes E4
and you're hitting my queen with two
pieces the Knight and the Rook which
makes it impossible to deal with both so
yeah the
the tactics there for harika it's funny
Robert talk about how counterintuitive
it is to spot a move like Bishop takes
C3 right parting ways with the key
defender of your king side all of your
dark squares will become a long-term
problem even the best human players in
the world miss things like that which is
why we have the eval bar kind of saying
hey tap you on the shoulder there was
something here but it's really natural
to miss Bishop take C3 yeah you do not
want to give up usually this bishop in
front of your king unless you get
something in return that's at such an
important piece covering all of these
dark squares around your king keeping it
safe but Fabiana karwana had this game
against Voit it was years ago where he
took this Knight on C3 in a position
where it was more closed than this and
he won that game very nicely by securing
some extra material in the long run he
just had better placement for his pieces
so Bishop takes a C3 is something you
need to keep an eye on even if typically
you don't play in here with the C file
being open and the queen being in line
with the Rook Rooks win that Showdown
along the open file
yeah well shout out for that car wanna
avoid toxic reference you think I'm not
going to notice that shout out to
radislav my boy there holding it down in
Poland that was a that was a you think
you're just gonna say that and get away
with it I know that game
um
okay G4 has been played
and at this point I don't think harika
has a choice but to back the pony up she
missed her chance of tactics
um
you know
yeah Knight F6 looks
quite natural she could be looking at
some kind of B5 that's of course a
tempting move when you can try to
exploit an open line but yeah I don't
think that uh her time management is
helping her at all she was down a couple
minutes against one of the fastest
players on the planet
yeah I feel you all right let's feel the
bird's eye view here back this thing up
again
take a look around we probably can
complete our circling of the wagons to
head to the only game we haven't really
checked out yet and that is baskaran
versus nurmanova because something
happened there on just the last move and
baskaron has the potential for a big
Advantage now
um trying to spy it there on the midi
board Queen to d8 was not enjoyed by the
computer and I think that's C5 Knight is
going to have to feel the tenderness
here soon yeah there's something
happening here and what it is is exactly
clear I think Knight D5 the bishop on D4
is overloaded it's trying to defend this
Knight but now it's under attack from
the bishop on B2 so Knight D5 E7 will be
loose in these positions B7 will be
loose in others with the bishop and
Brook teaming up here I think just the
simple Knight D5 I know black is up a
pawn but you lack coordination and
development and your pieces are quite
loose
gonna say I mean my first thought was a
move like Rook D1 just to pin the bishop
and then create more problems because
suddenly Knight B5 and 92 are both on
the agenda as well when you have a pin
like that but you're right maybe it's
Knight D5 Bishop B2 and queen C5
um that would force Bishop F6 no okay
Rook D1 played also looks pretty good
just simple simple chess
so many ways to put pressure on that pin
piece go ahead yeah no what you said is
right and he's playing your line that
eval Barr says yep good idea Danny
that's exactly what it said I don't know
if you heard that yourself but can we
get a sound effect where it goes ding
ding ding good job
I feel like you could make that happen
you do have that sort of I should
actually there there is there is a voice
extension for those who don't know it
that originally a member of our
community made we're like uh it's super
creepy my voice says every move on the
board but we're working on some really
cool email bar technology for those who
want to know where uh eventually you
know being able to do those things that
we do as commentators where we talk
about how critical the moment is with
time pressure and all the stuff so
anyway so many cool things to come down
the road
remember what your nickname was in high
school nobody asked Dan so uh yeah hey
as my 17 year old would say who asked
well I mean we've been asking for
audible to play Knight B5 this is a pin
Bishop there are loose pieces like the
C5 nice so if you can go Knight B5 and
successfully take this bishop with your
knight you're just gonna Crush down this
open diagonal and I'm not really sure if
Knight E6 is the way that Black's gonna
go here maybe it keeps her in the game
but if Knight if Knight B5 Bishop B2
you're you're taking C5 first even right
and then you're maintaining the threat
on both the queen and the bishop so
there's just I feel like baskaran has
taken a taking a beat here to just make
sure he he cashes in but uh
there's got to be a tactical sequence
that that delivers a knockout so
um
I'm looking at all four boards on the
bird's eye view if we wanna
if we want to bring that back for
everybody watching and take a look at
all four games Hikaru continuing to push
forward
managed to grab that pawn on D6 that
spells bad news if there's no tactical
shot anytime that pawn falls falls in
those structures and there's no tactics
on the C file uh you did wrong
and uh but the other two games look good
for MGD one right Eric icy looks in
control and baskaron also as we were
just looking probably moments away from
a knockout is there look at the federal
Sav game in the top right harika
sacrificed a piece so maybe we should go
over there and hikara by the way it
looks like he is just cruising right now
he's not even up any material but black
has no space in the top left but if we
go to the game in the top right for a
moment the Pharisee of game against
harika she gave away a piece just a
little while ago like Bishop F4
Bishop takes G4 was played because of
all the tactics everywhere across this
board and federal save takes on D6 and
takes in C5 and in this live position
I'm already looking is there a way to
take advantage of this bishop on E2
being a bit overloaded this Knight on C3
is also loose in some lines so the eval
bar doesn't hate Black's position
despite the fact that black has given up
a piece
totally great call out I was looking at
the the the common tactics where the D6
Pawn vaults completely failed to realize
that we had had a sacrifice on G4
because even simple moves like Rook e to
C8 are possible right that's one of
those positions where yeah White's
better but there's a lot of problems
here and we talked about the Practical
aspects of having an open King in Rapid
chess it's not a fun position for
fedosafe and what are you speaking of
easy moves can you just take this Pawn
because then there will be Knight E3
ideas Bishop D4 check ideas some kind of
Rook C8 left she does take with the
Knight on G4 and the eval bar is getting
a workout and it's going up and it's
like wait a second black actually has
some good counter player and I actually
don't care about the eval bar because I
could see white dropping pieces in the
next few turns there's already threats
down the C file you have this Knight on
C4 is kicked out of the way maybe 93 is
a tactic you really have to look out for
or simply Knight to E5 let's just trade
Knights because the end of this my
Bishop is on E5 in great shape and
there's a pin down this line
agree totally man and B5 right away
might not be a threat but Bishop takes
C3 and B5 is also yet another threat you
highlighted Bishop D4 check you
highlighted the forks there but that's a
concrete problem to solve from what I
can see you'd be happy to be have a have
a pawn or something for the exchange if
White's king is not open at the end of a
big a big combo in the C file there so
with the time situation favoring Federal
save luckily he can he can use a few
seconds to to try to solve it but don't
be surprised if this is a mutual time
scramble where as you said the eval bar
continues to get a workout here and my
blood pressure continues to go up and
down luckily I'm seeing a doctor for
that
I hope so we want you to be in good
shape Danny and I think that you know
your tactics have been in good form so
now it's just about the physical health
and there's one idea I want to add I
hear it Danny is that at some point if
you're not looking out for it there
could be something
oh yeah like there's so much happening
so so much happening right now in
federal saves why is it using time but
Danny should we zoom out because it
looks like Hikaru he really is doing
well I really love that Queen C7 idea
because it's actually a threat there on
Bishop G4 Rook C4 and C3 Falls but okay
we move on uh let's go check out the
final moments potentially of Nakamura
versus gauche because Hikaru has has
shown up today uh and again not to say
that he doesn't most the time do that
but for those who watched on Thursday
Hikaru uh was was not on his best form
through all four games today he's
probably about to start out 2-0 let's
take a look
looking really nice for the legendary
Hikaru Nakamura but he still has some
work to do that game that we're looking
at is in the top left we'll bring it up
on screen shortly and we see that white
has every piece in like a perfect place
but his own King is a little bit exposed
he could hide on H3 at the right moment
but dang let's not let's call this game
over until it's actually over this Rook
on A4 takes away this queen G4 check
which is very important because
otherwise rookie 8 would be game over if
you could give this check to kick the
king away but the Rook will then slide
to D4 and attack this bishop so look at
Hikaru what a move I was not considered
a queen retreat
it gains a Tempo on The Rook but what's
the follow-up I'm wondering the eval bar
loved it it's obviously a strong idea
but I still don't see how white improves
next that's that's kind of th at the
time sorry sound effects
um King H3
uh if the Rook moves from the fourth
rank remember Robert already highlighted
Queen G4 check is coming followed by
rookie eight and and it's Rover okay
that's a good move 56 it's funny because
even moves like Bishop B3 are possible
given that if the Queens are traded the
C7 Pawn or the pawn coming to C7 is a
real issue and that Knight on f8 is not
playing chess I don't know what he's
doing he's looking around but highlight
how that Knight can't get out it's not
just G6 e67 even if you get to H7 Robert
G5 has taken that night much more of a
donkey and I feel like an ass sometimes
well I think you are correct even if
it's a little mean sounding you're right
in your assessment here that that means
white connection that I act like one
sometimes no I was just saying white can
trade all the pieces if the Queens yeah
okay giving up the Bishops
is there Knight D7 now because the pawn
takes then I take your Bishop
that would be a trick that would be a
trick but you know what there is on
Knight D7 is it just C7 and here comes
the lady
I was desperately trying to get my
knight around here to B6 to try to stop
your Pawn
and queen C7 Play Look where's the
progress for white
yeah
hey Carlos trying to figure out he's
doing it it's out it's out 97 now
because the Rook is loose
yeah but I get a queen on oh no I don't
get a queen on d8 oh he misses it you're
right I think that Knight could have if
that Knight gets out to E5 suddenly
we're talking about a three result game
yep
the car is frustrated he's like how am I
not winning
and he's getting down on the clock to go
with it right he's like uh where's the
win
come on
Danny Black's moves or just Rook Shuffle
back and forth okay now the rook's under
attack you can't play Queen D6 so then
the pawn goes up so where if you move
the Rook is there Queen E8 threading to
take F7 and then oh I think that might
be the idea nasty Rook d8 play Queen
yeah so The Rook had to go to d8 and
look at that move queen of four man that
just highlights that that do you have
Rook C8 maybe it was Queen G4 check that
was the key Square we were talking
earlier
yeah Queen G4 checking for C8 and if you
take F4 that donkey is not playing chess
or watch out you have to be super
careful when your King's on H3 and
that's why it goes rookie three Queen C5
going after this Pawn Yeah it's It's Not
Over
it's not over it's not a tuba it's not
over but F7 is also loosier
and then there's mate problems Bishop
takes F7 Queen G8 is mate
just oh it is that's that plot it says
it just ends yeah so Bishop takes F7 and
just like that the drama is over okay
well good talk everybody let's head back
to the bird's eye view Hikaru gets it
done
the uh
oh we had another result come in right
as we say that Federal save does take
down John avali the peace sack on G4
doesn't doesn't prove out
not looking great for mgd1 man both of
those other two games between Eric icy
and baskaron they were better when we
left them now now the knights are
holding yeah adivan he's the one down
under 10 seconds you see the red on the
screen there Arjun also down a minute
but so is his opponent volkidov Danny I
think that this could go really wrong
for mgd1 if they do not score a
miraculous two points from those two
games
oh man a great town remember coming in
the knights had a 3-1 lead in this round
you can already see the updated
scoreboard it is now five to one in
favor of Gotham and uh and I don't know
which game to go to we can head over to
irigaisi versus Makita because it looks
like Arjun might be pushing for a win
now there yeah the time pressure
notwithstanding that black black king on
E8 is in trouble yeah and it moves it to
f8 after the check yes this taking on D6
you would have been an eternal pin and a
king would suck in the center this King
on G1 super safe right now black is
actually up a pawn and maybe this Pawn
can come in handy as a decoy but it
looks like your king is on the verge of
getting checkmated
yeah but where's the knockout
Knight D6 king of Fate is it's going to
be a draw but keto's like yeah sign me
up for a Perpetual you kidding if Knight
B7 Rook C8 well oh Knight takes of seven
where did that come from he wants D7 D7
Bishop is hanging
wow this should help but what a move
Queen C5 queen of these Goods watch live
Queen h72
the a port is running if the kid off
swindles himself another Victory I it
might be I might pull a candy and just
walk on out of here this guy
well that's why he's in the nights he's
pulling a Hikaru Hikaru is amazing at
defending when it looks like he has a
lost position and this bishop at some
moment can reroute the score like B6 or
to C5 watch out for Queen H7 check
yeah Queen H7 would be a skewer problem
not to be confused with a forking
problem Bishop to B4 that 994 is sort of
dominated by the dark Square Bishop here
come the pawns though and the black king
is going to feel the heat
Queen C7 don't take A7 don't get greedy
here that pawn is irrelevant so it goes
back he brings King up to F2 that's a
good decision dating both sides are in
time trouble
and they're playing fantastic chess in
time trouble like you said a very good
decision oh and here comes E4 do we got
more pawns push him baby
let's go baby push up five this Knight
and you have to watch out for checks
against this King so you can bring his
light back to B2 and maybe it will go up
to E5 at some point to help deliver a
checkmate
with both players under time pressure
this is a fully three result position
anybody could win A4 you can't take
it is overworked
oh the Queen's coming over the Pawn's
gonna run oh my God
what the world with this guy he had
Bishop D2 first and the Knight couldn't
get back so that was an imprecise move
order from vokidov he still is doing
just fine because this Knight is tied
down but he had a chance there oh but
Bishop D2 was Rover you're right that
was it he's still dominating the night
the bishop on D2 takes all the squares
away from the A2 Pony
okay but two pass pawns are gonna be a
problem dude both sides could still win
this game again this is like this can't
go try to get this Pawn I don't think
it's time
doesn't have time and that Bishop is
gonna have to let the Knight out now
with the King attacking it King E4 I
think we might just see nope whoa no
what is happening here these pawns are
scary
dude who wants to win I don't even know
what's going on by the way the other
game in this round has ended in a draw
so a huge hole for Norma Nova what is
going on Bishop takes E5
and then Bishop G7 after F7 you just
bring your Bishop back take F7 and now
black is winning
dude the knights are gonna wrap this
thing up in two rounds that's literally
what we're looking at nurmanova board
four draws baskaron
and vaquita the wizard The Magician
known as vakidov
it's unbelievable the dude I'm just like
I'm Blown Away with this guy
Denny from the early stages we were like
oh I think that Black's in trouble the
king is not going to find safety that
King is one king of the hill and it's
also winning a chess game go King F4
King G3 scoop up G2 and win
highly underrated variant King of the
Hill
just game over Queen he wins it again
and he loves his Gotham Knight swag he
loves to flex it when he's winning chess
games his name is sham seeden vaquid off
I I I I I can't even speak the words
Robert this guy is leading the knights
into the finals right now he's been
unbelievable he now is 2-0 today on
Thursday he scored three out of four
points he has been an absolute star for
the Gotham Knights but everyone has
contributed in this round look at this
three and a half to half their board
four who was outrated by 450 points she
gets a draw with black and the rest of
the three boards beat their gym
opponents didn't he what is showing from
the knights
I I'm I'm uh
breath is taken away
shout out to Berlin great song
I was not a fan of the second Top Gun
movie I'm absolutely just impressed
right now with what's happening from the
Gotham Knights they are playing dominant
chess if you miss it on Thursday the kid
off was the star he's he's right there
with a car today leading them this
youngster is uh is he's already won a
gold medal and maybe he's gonna win
himself a pro Chesley Championship if he
continues to play like this Robert they
lead six and a half one and a half and
three of their players have a perfect
two out of two you see boys one through
three just dominating the opposition and
so Gotham Knights have jumped all over
team mgd1 it started when vokita won
that game against arima down a pawn in
The Rook end game but since then they
have just completely obliterated their
opponents it's crazy What's Happening
Here
we came into the day with two teams from
India with a chance to punch their
ticket to the finals we may have neither
if things continue this way but all
right before we head to a break let's
remind everybody that there's another
event happening Mañana it's going to be
an exciting one and it is the return of
our chess kid stars versus streamers the
event is back the first event had the
chess kid stars taken on Anna kramling
and Eric Rosen uh Jessica Stars won but
now now the streamers are joined by Levy
Rosman and archers Nixon it's going to
be an impressive lineup the chess kid
team brings Alice Lee Brewington
Hardaway Tani adawami and Megan paragua
this is going to be a thriller mark your
calendars don't miss it it is tomorrow
the chess kit Stars versus streamers
rematch on Sunday May 14th at 1 pm
Pacific time don't go anywhere we will
be right back with more of the pro chess
League playoffs
good
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now right here almost there and you did
it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
goodness chat so good to have you back
PCL traded Queens
oh my gosh let's go with the postseason
upon us the stakes are only getting
higher which teams from around the world
can survive to claim the next PCO
championship and also bite off a Lion's
Share of the fresh 100 000 up for grads
the semi-finals of the protest League
playoffs have finally arrived that's
game the odd wins on the clock but also
on the board end they've dominated this
match from start to finish the PCL is
here to stay who will be crowned its
next Champion whoa
the Indian water is strong around here
the pro chess League playoffs continue
this weekend we are in our second
semi-final matchup of the day alongside
me Grand Master Robert Hess we head to
the back half of this matchup Robert but
it might not be a back half it might
just be one more round if mgd1 doesn't
get it right yeah it might be the final
third of this match because there's a
three-headed monster coming from the
Gotham Knights they have all won their
two games thus far Hikaru Nakamura
Vladimir fedosam and last but certainly
not least Trump seeden volkidov he has
been dumming his playoff opposition he
deserves a gold star a pay raise from
the knights I don't know what you can
give him but he deserves all that and
more
in both those games if you're just
tuning in we're kind of comeback
victories he was down a pawn in a rook
ending that he won against adibon
baskaran he was worse against Arjun
irigaisi managed to Swindle himself and
dominate a knight ironically given that
he plays for the Gotham knights with
that powerful dark Square Bishop let's
not Overlook normanova as well right she
held it to Raw in that game and which
was also huge for the knights it's part
of their six and a half one and a half
lead if I look at the matchups coming up
here Robert how do I paint a comeback
it's got to start at the top someone has
to slow down Hikaru and perusev between
those two and then where do they get a
dub on those other two boards well the
Gotham Knights need two points to take
this match two out of eight total
remaining games
so you need to win all of them that's
what you have to do if you're audibon if
you're Arjun you go for it and I just I
don't know where it's gonna come from
I'm looking at Jump scene and volcano
with a white piece against harika are
you guys struggle today losing both of
refers to Norma Nova as you said she's
been playing well she gets the white
pieces because dip time ghost ghost
needs to win that goes without saying
and then for Arjun and adibon they need
to win with the white pieces so you need
three wins on those boards and then for
harika you have to hope that she can
survive okira who seems to be having his
way and having luck on the side
it's just all nights right now it is and
that's all Hikaru Nakamura that's all he
does most days is stream and provide
commentary while he's playing he's 2-0
right now I guess again to answer my own
question that I asked how does the
comeback start if you're if you're MGD
one at least you're thinking we get
white against those two guys we saw
Hikaru we see phariseev if you're
boscarron and irigaisy you do get white
you are an aggressive very well prepared
Grand Master who plays at a pretty high
level this is your opportunity right you
get the first move you gotta go all in
and uh and there you go so if your MGD
one fans don't lose hope yet it has to
start right here a 2-0 sweep I'm with
Robert has to happen for these top two
boards and adibon here's the white
pieces no B3 Cowboy business not against
the car Nakamura and look at this Knight
D2 in this position after the check he
didn't block the bishop he didn't bring
his Knight to C3 you know he's trying to
play for some offbeat or less Mainline
stuff taken with the queen 92 and maybe
feed Kettering his Bishop on B2 later
no
I won't make a B3 Cowboy reference uh
you know to make sure I don't get called
out by by the entire hashtag chess punks
movement on Twitter but I'm just saying
you didn't play B3 that's all I'm saying
all right we've got we've got E3 and B4
he goes all in right he reminds
everybody oppon's move twice on their
first move we don't need the cowboy
system
no but you also need your dark Square
Bishop to shine because guess what black
does not have one so if this bishop were
on D6 we'd already be saying well Nate
not now with 94 Forks but you get the
point if this bishop can plan itself on
a key dark Square the game would be
really problematic for black so what a
car needs to do is figure out a way to
tame this bishop long term this bishop
on B7 is clearly a very strong piece and
Denny big question do you take this
Knight on F3 shattering White's Pawn
structure but handing him the pair of
Bishops
uh I don't if I'm if I'm black there
because again I think it's exactly the
double-edged position that white wants
you put Bishops on D3 and B2 you open
the G file exactly and you're you're all
in now at the same time you're all in
anyway right because you know as Hikaru
your opponent is coming for you in this
game because they have no choice so he's
obviously taking his time for good
measure certainly considering whether he
takes F3 and then tries to shut down the
studio with the Knights keep it keep it
as close as he can
uh I I could I will say this again
you're going up against Hikaru you're
down Big Time six and a half one and a
half as everyone can see I liked I like
audubon's chances this is going to be a
double-edged game right at the very
least this is going to be spicy you're
gonna have some chances ooh now you will
have D5 and then Bishop on B2 will be
stuck behind the d-pawn ah muscle
thrilled about that okay
it's one of these big decisions for a
car and we usually see him with a big
lead on the clock but he's correctly
spending his time as Danny is just
matching D5 seems to be a movie you play
on Instinct but then after C5 you're
starting to get worried about these past
pawns just running up the board so you
shut down a bishop okay but you hand
your opponents and passers and it's a
trade-off that's what chess is you you
know you give and take you get something
for yourself but maybe your opponent
gets something in return and I'm looking
at this position Danny I don't want to
see D5 in the future going for an attack
yeah but black plays it I am worried
about the passers that's fair that's
fair so Hikaru again taking his time
maybe he'll find a way to have his cake
and eat it too put a knight on e4 and
maybe play D6 first you maintain the
tension a little bit so that D5 the idea
behind D6 Robert we can show everyone is
if if D5 by white you have E5 right so
that's kind of the point you're playing
a little bit of game of a tickle tickle
there to keep that Bishop at Bay I kind
of like this D6 idea potentially for
Hikaru so all right we'll see what he
does we should probably
probably see what's going on the other
boards as we said the the knights have a
six and a half one and a half lead that
means that uh it can't just be a win for
Boss can run over Hikaru gotta come from
other places too should we check out
irigaisi in federal save
let's look at it so and by the way look
at the top left Hikaru did take on F3
and push D5 but let's go to uh the game
between Arjun Eric icy and federal save
we haven't tuned into that one early
stages uh in the top right where Arjun
he needs to right the ship he needs to
win this game uh he's you know had some
topsy-turvy moments it's been a roller
coaster for mgd1 unfortunately it's been
all downhill thus far but he needs to
shoot up and his team needs to help out
as well but Danny in this position we
cut the board in half on this side of
the board where I'm drawing my arrows
white has an extra pawn and on the other
side where I'm drawing these arrows now
black has an extra Pawn so it's four on
three Pawn advantages from Queen side
for black king side for white who do you
take
I mean from a practical perspective I'll
give your guy see this shout out right
because he has the majority on the king
side I always say opponent E5 means no
Knight on F6 which means less minor
pieces over there so you see the
mounting coming right two nights F3 and
G3 if you could play like C3 and Bishop
D3 right my hands gestures are kind of
showing that I'm hoping for something
here in case in case you're a visual
learner but again I like that from a
practical point of view because you have
to get a win if you're irigaissey but
the eval bar speaks to Black's majority
look at the pawns on C5 and D5 the
knights well placed behind them
so um so we'll see all right Knight F5
going for the bishop here right we'll
take it we'll take it the issue though
is in many Sicilians you get a knight to
F5 you just win the game in this
position it's a lone piece it's not
really threatening anything as you point
out the knights are so good for well the
Gotham Knights are so good but I'm done
with the Knights here for federal save
the ninth and C6 and E6 G7 is covered
you're never worried about some
Checkmate on that square and this queen
it needs to get out to H5 to help in the
attack yeah they're too many pieces in
this path too many pieces in the way
yeah no well said and also note that I
said C3 in a fantasy world that I could
route my Bishop from D3 to C2 but C3
invites as we always say the anchor
right you invite D4 the lever that
Robert's highlighting The Rook on d8 is
preparing for exactly that Federal save
is 100 ready to prevent white from
coordinating and uh
and yeah this is
a very solid position for the big fish
we see uruguisi lean up for the first
time
um he's been lean back kind of chillaxed
in that chair but getting a little more
into it now Federal say of
focused focused as ever he's 2-0 2-0 on
the day let's head back to the bird's
eye view Robert we do have two other
games going on that we haven't looked at
remember the knights only need two
points to clinch their spot in the
protest League finals uh we've got the
kid off against Toronto volley
what a what a weird position down there
again right King Side open what happened
there
shoust we we shall we shall we
definitely shout and we we oh we shout
you're telling me that we shout because
I'm telling you that we shall you tell
me we shall we'll joust after this if
you keep that up well all right I don't
want to adjust those nights those nights
are scary and for vokidov he may be the
scariest amongst the bunch and he may
not have the highest rating on the team
that belongs to karunakamura second to
Federal save but volkidov as an Olympic
gold medalist for the Uzbek team they
won the chess Olympiad you see him just
thriving and if we dive into the
position where volcano is he is playing
in the darkness it's his old friend and
he is saying a friendly hello to the
black king eventually because look at
this Pawn Black's best move is to push
that pawn backwards but that's not
allowed yep I've said it many times when
is chess.com gonna fix the bug
let the pawns go backwards
um
Bishop C2 looks good
just build up on that tension obviously
black never really wants to take D3 the
queen will take D3 plus the D5 Plum
becomes isolated
so to drawing of all his credit the
position is on right there's some
there's some cloudiness here which means
maybe an opportunity to go wrong but but
the eat all bar speaks volumes here
I think that white has an easy position
to play put the bishop on C2
build on that tension I wonder if you
can I know this is crazy Robert but at
some point I could even play F3 right if
I really want to make sure that E4 Pawn
has to has to choose
you definitely can play F through in you
know conjunction with Bishop C2 take on
e4 F3 is something that you have to
consider and look at vokito he takes on
e4 right away saying that I'm just going
to play around this Pawn your Rook can't
get to E8 to defend it watch out for a
Time the H4 and black on the other hand
could think about Queen F4 trying to
trade Queens here to bring another Pawn
closer to the E4 Pawn but that's very
dangerous you get into a territory where
your end game may just be losing yeah
and it's not the traditional definition
of an outpost Square because normally we
think of that as in our enemies camp on
the fifth Rank and Beyond everyone but
that night on D4 is outposted for sure
and what that means is there are no
black pawns that can attack it and this
is critical because if you evaluate the
long-term features of a position that
pony will dominate for a long time there
is no Pawn coming to C5 or E5 so that
Knight on D4 just a bit of an octopus
right in the middle of the board just
controlling everything
and this bishop has to control the F5
Square because if that bishop ever goes
to B7 looks like a really good move
protecting your Pawn the Knight hops
into F5 and goes after this King side
look what are you gonna do Bishop D7
that looks very sad and you invited the
bishop to B3 trying to go after this
black king I just I can't imagine in a
rapid time control that black can do
well in this position it seems yeah very
one-sided and I'd like your idea at some
point F3 is going to hurt especially
with the bishop on B3 in vaquita just
letting those moves play themselves
right like you could argue H4 could have
been considered there but he just plays
quickly the position is simple because
black has more problems than white right
and it's good to remind your opponent of
that the bishop can't move to to a
square without consequences as Robert
pointed out right F5 is weak there are
all kinds of other ways to tactically go
wrong the Knight on F6 can't move the E4
Pawn hangs so H4 is uh is going nowhere
right grab a Snickers and again I just I
like the confidence as far as like what
to learn from these players Rook D1
played don't overthink the position
because you know what you can do Robert
you can think on your opponent's clock
right so he just plays the move he's
going to keep working hard while drone
of all he thinks about it and uh the
knights what can you say about these
these players from Gotham right now this
is this is another
uh unbelievable I do want to point out
that H4 has a huge drawback of Knight G4
which I'm only noticing now that you're
inviting Black's pieces into the attack
as Queen on C7 Knight on G4 that could
have been dangerous so look at these
moves every move has a purpose getting
out of this pin over here white is in
charge so vokito he's doing everything
correct and for harika she needs to win
the game she knows that it's not a
situation that's fun for Grandmasters to
be in where you need to win from move
one with black it's so difficult but
anyway I was looking at the bird's eye
view uh off screen and I was looking at
some of the other games because while
this one is advantageous for vokidov it
looks like board four nurmanova look in
the bottom right
I was just going to say that we have to
go to there again Norma Nova not someone
who's gotten as much of attention as her
as her three teammates uh I mean partly
for good reason they've been performing
so well but she got a draw in the last
round versus audibon Boston run if
you're just tuning in and she is
squeezing right now against go she is
better here for sure
you mean you don't like these pieces all
in the first two ranks over here they're
not my favorite also you know what's
coming F4 F5 Pawn storm sign me up
oh this just looks incredibly one-sided
I'm wondering you just take on B6 after
it takes back the C file being open
doesn't scare white yeah then play F4
yeah this is unpleasant yep
yep yep yep yep
yeah very well-built team with the
Gotham Knights Hikaru fedo save you also
you also have uh Bortnick if I'm not
mistaken even though he's not playing
here today
um this is a very good team Nicola
portnick all right they got the
international Master board Nick who's
super strong always a 3000 Blitz on
chess.com whoa okay Bishop where's that
fish we're going
she's trying to provoke B5 yeah because
it flows down the queen side come right
back and play F4 F5 normally the knights
prefer a closed position versus the
Bishops but not when your opponent has
this big of a space advantage and it's
just ready to roll I don't really like
that move again I'm just looking for F4
because if if you miss your chance to
play it and somehow black squeezes in a
G5 pawn move with a knight E6 Robert you
get what I'm saying that's the one way
this goes wrong is it black okay if
black gets 96 and G5 I really don't like
how Norma Nova has played this I hate
that I foreshadowed that for the knights
but but here come mgd1
I'm with you and there's also C5 in D4
because you'll have Rook d8 with a pin
so suddenly it's white who needs to be
very careful what does it just plant
your knight on F4 C7 is loose that's the
one thing keeping that night at Bay but
I'm also looking at C5 jettisoning upon
to play D4 next forcing the bishop back
and black takes control of some much
needed space in the position wow a new
lease on life for blacks pieces 100 and
it's one of those positions where you
can be too cute a bit of a lesson for
fans watching right Bishop A4 Rook C1
the truth is your advantage was on the
king side after B6 I think Robert's
instincts to just take B6 and push him
baby right F4 and let's go probably what
the doctor ordered there again it's not
the normanova has blown the advantage
computer still likes white but from a
practical perspective to me a blackheads
G5 Knight F4 is coming that King on G1
is also potentially open this game is
not over
not over at all and I think that if C5
comes I'm already thinking about just
playing F4 anthroponic just letting my
Bishop back to D2 that's how important
the space is in this position who cares
about one extra double Pawn in the
center I would go for aggression I would
take control of space but I like for
ghost that he had out his channel so
that's good for MGD one maybe we should
check out how the other boards are going
Danny because they need to say
Unfortunately they need it right because
we back up to the bird's eye view but
keedoff is uh is going off right now
this guy
going full Lonnie Walker Lakers
Lakers I am disappointed in my Phoenix
Suns sorry we did that yesterday let's
move on but look at top left by the way
adibon is cool okay okay in that
position let's go to there audibon
baskaron playing like the Beast the
chest that earned him his nickname is
the type you see on the board right now
aggressive All In
and we said it look I said I didn't know
how this one was going to go but I said
at least at the start before we left I
liked baskaron's chances right if you
were looking for a chance against Hikaru
it started with a lot of weirdness a
double-edged affair with a couple of
Bishops and he looks like he might get
the job done
and look at this queen chilling on G5
you can't capture it because the king is
on h8 and if the queen had captured a
turn ago black is gonna face more
problems Pawn takes G5 excuse me hello
past Pawn C5 speaking of foreshadowing
Danny we mentioned a long time ago if
black plays D5 there will be a passer
and white has a very healthily protected
pass Bond and in end games A4 will
happen the bishop will take this the
pawns will start running up the board I
think that a queen trade still very much
favors aliban and there's a reason the
position says plus five despite the fact
that he's technically down material
sorry that's
that's weird to be plus five when you're
also Down The Exchange right it's not
something you see every day the move
here is that's also a threat is is F6 I
think that's a threat in the in the
current position or something close to
it uh yeah this is um this is a problem
Hikaru is shaking his head this one got
away from him if we want to bring up the
analysis board real quick I'm just
curious how did this one go so far off
the rails for Hikaru if we can back the
moves up to where we left it real quick
partner there you go Bishop of three I I
you know I liked the D6 playing better
he went for this transition go ahead and
just Blitz through him I'm just curious
yeah this is kind of what we thought
might happen right a double Bishop open
G file and baskaran just went for it
H5 yeah
I guess he underestimated that sack
yeah are we and then it looks like it up
did beat harika jonavali and this game
you know I see the evil part wow Queen
G5 was a sexy move uh but the then white
just start pushing everything forward
but vokito wins which means all the
knights need is one more point total
yeah and I don't think they're getting
it here as you mentioned F6 looks very
powerful pontics E6 you can't even take
back with the Rook cause your Rook on d8
is loose oh wow so that's an issue
that's also an issue you open up the
light score Bishop next every piece is
playing well it might be a little bit of
a Bittersweet moment for MGD one if
bosscaron takes down Hikaru Nakamura but
it doesn't matter and they can't even
make it to the fourth round How how Wild
would that would that be as far as the
story goes but all right
let's oh Bishop B5 okay here comes
Bishop sorry Bishop four was played
Bishop B5 is next
um
that looks like it gives Hikaru a little
bit of Life can you can he take F5 and
just kind of laugh in the face of danger
for a second and say where's the
knockout
this looks like you can even probably
take with a queen on F5 both your
Bishops are shining here black barely
has moves but hikar is ahead on the
clock and we know he survived even worse
positions than this
yeah I thought Queen G1 was an idea of
Queen F5 but you're right the king might
just hide on C3 and that really feels
bad because you have H7 mating yourself
at the end of that line right if you
take and if you check with the queen you
take up two checks it doesn't matter
there's there's a diagonal and H7 is
made
oh Queens on the board you get you get
checkmated with Queens off the board
you'd lose the end game because of the
past Pawn so yeah it's not good let's uh
again vokito of one so let's get out of
this game for a second because all the
Gotham Knights need is one point on
these games and the match is over and
look in the top right Vladimir ferrosev
he is in a winning position against our
generic icing and that might be all they
need as you see in the lower left Akita
has already gotten the job done what a
day what a what a player he is proving
to be for the knights this season but
let's go to that game between iRig icy
and fedo save because as you said
if the big fish gets the job done as
black it won't matter that Hikaru went
down versus Boston run
look at this position black is up a pawn
there's a knight on A3 it looks weird
it's you know out of here Rook A4 Bishop
C2 thank you for an exchange maybe
that's White's best hope to play for
something because otherwise I see these
pawns going down the queen side and it's
just toast
bruh
what a dominant match this has been I'm
just like
you just don't expect it right at this
point you know you're you're getting
into the uh you know you're getting down
to the Conference Finals so to speak
right and then you've got to sweep
uh of one of the teams and I'm just I'm
just blown away by how well the knights
have played obviously MGD one would like
to have some games back they'd probably
say they weren't their best form but it
really feels like the knights just
showed up right they just showed up
ready to play and uh and there you go
I'm I'm expecting this one to go the big
fish way and and for us not even to make
it to the fourth round
no I'm looking at at this position where
Federal save he is just upon ahead and
it's not just any pawn White's extra
pawns are here they're two extra Pawns
in the king side black has three extra
pawns that can be very mobile this one
goes to C4 he plays B6 so he doesn't
drop upon good starting place or federal
save and
there's also going to be a potential
issue on C2 everything is going wrong or
Arjun wow
shout out to Dragon B70 I saw on the
twitch chat using the brilliant symbols
he was featured a minute ago remember
that that guy's the uh the OG guess the
move wait Danny sorry I know you're
saying but do you see the last move that
Arjun played Rook A1 and game is over
matches over that's oh my God
yep that's a free rook in the corner
just not the chest we expected to see
today you know Arjun irigaisi has a
bright future a great career ahead of
him and has been awesome for mgd1 this
season but he just hung a rook in one
move I apologize for losing my focus on
that for a second but uh just like that
we know who's competing for the protest
League Championship tomorrow and it's
the Shanghai Tigers versus the uh
Some Nights the Gotham Knight yeah it's
hard to even say anything about this
match because it's been so incredibly
one-sided in the most unexpected way and
to lose the your playoff match like this
it seems like it's just a microcosm of
the larger picture this would happen to
mgg one all day today nothing went right
and maybe even on board one I I was just
about to say that speaking of things not
going right if Hikaru Wiggles off of
this hook it goes down in in one of his
uh one of his Hall of Fame notes he does
it a lot we say it a lot but this is
this has not been one that was easy
even a draw here is just a massively
successful result for black so yeah
it was completely toast and the only
reason staying in this game is this Rook
is trapped over here it cannot get out
you go Rook at five the Knight goes to
E7 chases it right back so uh for adivan
he might have to bring his King over
here and play it's a draw by repetition
he survived he he did he forget that it
was three moves
he just maybe saw there was no progress
unreal
uh wow
the knights everybody not only are they
better than the Bishops they are
competing for the pro chess League
Championship tomorrow they're up nine to
two it's not even over yet there's one
more game in progress uh and that is uh
the board four versus Board three battle
normanova versus gauche we might as well
head over to there and and get as much
chess as we can because all the fans who
showed up you know looking for looking
for another Thriller this is not going
to be the tight finish we had between
the Tigers and the yogis earlier today
this is a route the definition of one
yeah now this has just been unbelievable
you couldn't have scripted this I mean
just the demolition that we have seen
where the knights can just be
what meeting two a nice try for
background Checkmate but that's game
over so mgg once scores one at the end
Danny but it's way too little way too
late
way too little way too late uh the uh
the Gotham Knights
are gonna be playing for the protest
League Championship tomorrow uh
unfortunately for normanova she goes
down but it's all right she'll probably
be playing tomorrow given that this
lineup seems to be working for Gotham
right don't don't fix it if it's not
broken they they finish with a win
nine to three again
we're not getting 16 games that is your
final score ladies and gentlemen book it
wow 9-3 it's over and it's over look at
the top three for the Gotham Knights two
and a half from ikaru after a miracle
save against ariban three out of three
for both Federal save and volcano that
is unreal they just controlled the match
and vokidov that dude is just on fire he
was looking lost in some of his games he
was down a pawn in a rook end game and
yet he's won every game in the match he
is
and also
an absolute an absolute ulcer I mean
honestly if he has another performance
like this when it comes to who's going
to win the pro chess League MVP award
which is a prize everybody it may not go
to the obvious choice you always think
of Hikaru Nakamura or Vladimir puto save
at this point if you were to rack up the
playoff performances right now vaquita
has been the top the top performer for
the Gotham Knights and that just speaks
volumes as far as how strong your team
is because oh by the way this lineup and
I know this because of the behind the
scenes I'll share with the world there
obviously a lot goes into the scheduling
of this a lot happening laquan Liam not
able to play in this in this protest
League finals weekend Robert so without
Liam lay ferroseev and vaquita stepping
in
they're still just absolutely dominating
their opponents
yes the the lineup is working so why
change the thing but now that we know
based on the early semi-final and this
one and the Tigers and the Knights I
mean this feels like that we have a
really awesome final tomorrow
yeah absolutely and and again the uh I I
want to correct something I I spoke
incorrectly at the very very outset of
the show very few will probably remember
but I said that uh both the yogis and
the Tigers had different lineups that is
not true the Tigers have actually used
the same lineup not just that they had
in the quarters Robert but entire year
they've had the same exact lineup all
year the yogis did change out of course
we remember because you and I covered
Vita Gujarati and others yesterday but
but there you go the tiger is what I'm
speaking to now is that not only are
they using the same lineup that means
they're using the same experienced
players who are super ready for this
battle I know a lot of people are going
to be looking at Gotham as the favorite
because of Hikaru being the household
name because of Akita but the Shanghai
tigers are ready
yeah they are certainly ready and just
like the Joker says in the Dark Knight
they better be ready to bring a new
brand of criminals to Gotham because it
seems like vokidov is Batman and we
didn't know it you expected it was
somebody else but it's vokito of right
now and the Gotham Knights the way they
played in this match today and the one
on Thursday the St Louis archbishops
were a really strong team and they also
outlasted them so Danny I think we have
to say the favorite at least right now
looks like it is the Gotham Knights
crazy crazy to me um the the Gotham
Knights were so dominant today again
vaquita but again you know before we
wrap this up again the show is going so
fast I want to reflect that you really
have to give the kid off credit for how
he's stuck in there because if those who
watch the whole the whole match he was
losing to baskaron stuck it out right he
was losing the urugues he stuck it out
so yes this was a route but man does it
uh does it take volumes to the to the
perseverance and the Practical effort
that that Gotham made in order to make
it a route and there you have the
schedule tomorrow's matchups we will
start off with the third place final
between the two teams from India which
is fun right I know neither of them is
Happy Robert that they're not competing
for the championship but that's going to
be a fun one uh the the two teams from
India and then you have Gotham versus
tigers you and I will have that call
later on tomorrow morning
yeah no it's going to be in really good
consolation match it's not the match
they wanted to play in for the Indian
yogis and team mgd1 but they've had
brilliant seasons and they have
brilliant players but I think all eyes
will eventually be on Shanghai tigers
against the Gotham Knights I did say and
I believe that the knights are favored
but you said it yourself Danny the
Shanghai tigers have they brought the
same lineup each and every week it's
working the Perfection for them it's
clear that they have what it takes to
win the protest League
yeah they sure do both teams I think I
think do and I can't wait to see what
happens tomorrow hopefully no more uh
starting starting off iPad gambits for
for the Tigers for those who watch that
match it was quite a fun start but they
still got the job done Gotham Knights
waiting for them again tune in for the
consolation match first and foremost the
two teams from India make sure you check
that out Robert and I will have the call
later on tomorrow for the entire crew
here crushing it and getting the job
done thank you so much the pro chess
League finals are coming to you we will
see you Sunday
he knows this is all over even though
this position black has enough material
look at Lou though Lou is on the iPad
you know I mean he's playing off the pad
no mouse slips over here buddy yeah you
go
oh now he might have a fill a door
though
position the Shanghai tigers take round
to equalizing the match he wants to get
he wants to get that Queen to Chief oh
my God oh my God
somebody
yeah that I'm still sucks I mean queen
H3 guys he sacked two knights and the
queen that's the game of the year that
could be Game of the Year Chad mg6 wins
the night Knight 886 was the only movie
pregnant resigns and with that way he
has done it the Shanghai Tigers move on
to the finals welcome to the protest
League playoffs boys and girls we have a
weekend ahead this is nice
it's over a queen D5 bro G5 resigns not
looking great for MGD one man both of
those other two games they were better
when we left them dude the knights are
gonna wrap this thing up in two rounds
dude I'm just like I'm Blown Away with
this guy
the game is over matches over oh my God
we know who's competing for the protest
League Championship tomorrow and it's
the Shanghai Tigers versus the Gotham
Knights
[Music]
foreign